FIRST SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING
ON MISSING AN UNIDENTIFIED
PERSONS I AM VERY GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'RE HERE TO JOIN US TODAY
AND FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
BY INVITING ARE PRO TEM TONI
ATKINS TO ADDRESS THE AUDIENCE
AND I THANK HER. VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING US TO ESTABLISH THIS
COMMITTEE AND TO BEGIN OUR WORK
IN THIS IN THIS AREA THANK YOU.
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH- CHAIR
WOMAN AND TO MY COLLEAGUES-
FIVE WANTED TO STOP BY BECAUSE
I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THIS ISSUE
IS A IN THE FORMATION OF THIS
SELECT COMMITTEE- I WANT TO
COMPLIMENT US EARLY CHAIRWOMAN.
LG BECAUSE THIS IT TOO HAS. OF
COURSE NEAR AND DEAR TO HER
HEART AND ON HER CONSCIENCE FOR
MANY YEARS AND I WAS TWENTY
MADE REQUESTS TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT IT THIS. HER AND TO THE
WHO ARE SIR ON THE SELECT
COMMITTEE THERE'S A LOT GOING
ON IN THE CAPITAL RIGHT NOW.
I'M SURE OTHERS WILL JOIN BUT
TO OUR LOCAL EXPERTS IN THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE TO SPEAKTODAY I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ONGOING COMMITMENT TO THIS
ISSUE. AND I CERTAINLY WANT TO
WELCOME I THE EXPERTS FROM
TEXAS AND MY HOME STATE OF
VIRGINIA WHO ARE HERE TODAY TO
BE PART OF THIS PRESENTATION
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THIS.
GOING RELATIONSHIP AS WE GET
UNDER WAY. I HAD TO REALLY TRY
TO LOOK AT THESE ISSUES IN
DEPTH FROM A PROFESSIONAL- LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM A HUMANE
PERSPECTIVE AND- I JUST WANTED
TO. BUY AND VERY QUICKLY
WELCOME YOU ARE TO THIS PROCESS
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CHAIR IN THE
MEMBERS AND JUST THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME A FEW MINUTES TO MAKE
SURE. THAT EVERYONE HERE
UNDERSTANDS THE COMMITMENT THAT
THE SENATE IS MAKING TO THIS
ISSUE AND WHEREVER IT GOES WE
WANT TO STAY COMMITTED AND
ENGAGED. ALL THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK
YOU AGAIN OUR SOCIETY COUNTRY
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE THAT EACH
PERSON WHO EXISTS HAS AND LIVES
WITHIN ITS BORDERS. AND OUR
CONSTITUTION CODIFIED THE
RIGHTS RECOGNIZED DUTY EACH
PERSON. IS WITH THESE THOUGHTS
THAT WE CONSIDER THE SILENT
PERSONS THOSE WHO CONSTITUTE
THE MISSING. AND NOT ACCOUNTED
FOR. IN ADDRESSING MISSING
PERSONS AND MAKE MASTICATION
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE OFFICER
IN TRAINING POST MANUAL STARTS.
BY ADVISING THAT INVESTIGATING
A MISSING PERSONS CASE CAN BE
ONE OF THE MOST CHALLENGING
ASSIGNMENTS. YOU'LL EVER
HANDLE. AND YOUR CAREER. TO
FIND THE MISSING UNHARMED AND
NOT INJURED IS THE BEST ABOUT
COMES FRO MISSING PERSONS
WHILE HARD TO IMAGINE CARING
FOR DECEASED VICTIM PROVIDING A
RESTFUL. A PEACEFUL RESTING
PLACE AND KNOWING WHERE THEY
ARE IS OF SOME CONSOLATION TO
THE VICTIMS LOVED ONES. IN THE
WORST CASES THE VICTIM REMAINS
MISSING AND IS NEVER LOCATED
ALIVE OR DECEASED IS OUR DUTY
TO ENSURE THAT WE PROVIDE BEST
PRACTICES AND TOOLS TO ENABLE
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO LOCATE
MISSING VICTIMS. IT IS IN THIS
SPIRIT THAT WE BEGAN TODAY'S
HEARING WE MUST ENSURE AND THE
KNOWLEDGE THE LATEST
DEVELOPMENTS IN INVESTIGATIVE
TECHNOLOGY AND MAKE THEM A PART
OF OUR CURRENT EFFORTS.
UNDERSTANDING HOW THE USE OF
RACE DATABASES TO HOLD
DESCRIPTOR INFORMATION MISSING
PERSON. THEY KEY FIRST STEP. IT
IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
SUBMITTING MISSING PERSON
INFORMATION IS NOT REQUIRED FOR
ALL OF THEM. SHOULD SUBMISSION
OF MISSING PERSONS DESCRIPTORS
AS PROVIDED AND AT LEAST EIGHT
OTHER STATES BE LEGALLY
MANDATED IS AN OPEN QUESTION.
WE MUST ALSO ENSURE THAT OUR
PRACTICES ARE ALWAYS
INCORPORATING THE NEWEST AND
MOST PROMISING DEVELOPMENTS AND
THAT WE PROVIDE FOR ADVANCEMENT
OF MISSING PERSONS
INVESTIGATION FROM CORPORATE
THE BENEFIT OF TIME AND
TECHNOLOGY. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ALONE THERE WERE
THIRTY NINE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR REPORTED
ADULTS MISSING AND MORE THAN
SEVENTY NINE THOUSAND CHILDREN
REPORTED MISSING. THAT IS
CERTAINLY A LOT OF WORK FOR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
TAKING DOWN INFORMATION
FOLLOWING UP AND MANAGING A
GREAT DEAL OF DATA. THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIA MISSING PERSON
CASES ARE NOW OLDER COLD CASES
COMPLICATING THESE
INVESTIGATIONS IS THE FACT THAT
OFTENTIMES THE INDIVIDUAL IS
ORIGINALLY FROM ONE COUNTY BUT
DISAPPEARS OR THEIR BODY IS
FOUND IN ANOTHER COUNTY. IN
MANY CASES MULTIPLE MONIES ARE
INVOLVED AND THE INVESTIGATING
AGENCY IS OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTY
IN WHICH THE INDIVIDUAL LET.
THESE ISSUES PRESENT MANY
CONFUSING CHALLENGES FOR FAMILY
MEMBERS AND FRIENDS WHO ARE
HESITANT TO CONTACT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR WHO ARE AND
CERTAIN AS TO WHERE THEY SHOULD
CALL WITH NEW INFORMATION OR
POTENTIAL LEADS. IN ADDITION
MANY ARE AND FAMILIAR WITH
JURISDICTIONAL ISSUES BETWEEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AT
THAT SAME TIME THEY'RE COPING
WITH THE LOSS OF THEIR LOVED
ONE. TRYING TO. ALL MAY MATT.
CITY IS FOR CHILDREN WHO ARE
LEFT BEHIND INSURANCE MATTERS
THAT TRACK TODAY WE WILL HEAR
FIRST HAND ACCOUNTS FROM THE
PEOPLE WHO TAKE THE INITIAL
REPORTS TO THE PEOPLE WHO DEAL
WITH THE VARIOUS DATABASES WERE
INFORMATION IS DEPOSITED WE
WILL ALSO HEAR FROM THE PEOPLE
WHO HELPED TO ANALYZE THIS DATA
TO LOOK FOR PATTERNS AND
PROVIDE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
WITH NEEDED ASSISTANCE. I LOOK
FORWARD TO A ROBUST DISCUSSION
THIS AFTERNOON AND I APPRECIATE
OUR GUEST PANELISTS WHO HAVE
AGREED TO TAKE SOME TIME TO
SPEAK ABOUT THIS I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE. AND I WOULD ALSO
BEFORE WE BEGAN MY TO INTRODUCE
MY SHARE OF FROM SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY OUT WITHROW WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL TO HAVE YOU HERE TODAY
AND SO MANY WAS PROMPTED BY THE
FACT THAT WE HAD A TRAGIC
CITIES OF EVENTS THAT OCCURRED
IN OUR DISTRICT BETWEEN NINETY
FOUR AND CAN I EIGHT. TWO BILLS
WHO ARE POSSIBLE NUMBER AND IF
YOU GOING TO SING SOME
RECOVERED I'M DECADES LATER IN
THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND AND- IS.
THERE HAS BEEN US INSIDE. INTO
THE IMPORTANCE OF LOOK AT HOW
ARE WORKING WITH FAMILIES WHO
ARE THE SURVIVORS WHO ARE STILL
WAITING THERE FOR POSSIBLY
BRINGING THEIR LOVED ONE HOME
AT SOME POINT IN TIME. BUT
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY'RE
BROUGHT HOME NOW OR INTO THE
FUTURE IT IS SOMETHING THAT
WEIGHS ON A FAMILY AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE SHOW THAT
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER. TO REMEMBER THEM AND
GIVE THEM THE BEST POTENTIAL
HOPE FOR A BRIEF THE RECOVERY
OF THEIR LOVED ONE AT A LATER
DATE. SO WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO WELCOME UP THE FIRST PANEL.
OUR FIRST PANEL OF WITNESSES
CHARLES EVANS OF POST WHO WILL
GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING MANUAL
FOR THE INVESTIGATION OF
MISSING PERSONS. HE WILL
PROVIDE A DESCRIPTION OF WHAT
THE POST MANUAL SETS FORTH FOR
THE RULES OF THE RESPONDING
PATROL PERSON DISPATCHER AND
THE DETECTIVE AS IT APPLIES TO
MISSING PERSONS. AND HE WILL
IDENTIFY ASPECTS OF MISSING
PERSONS INVESTIGATIONS THAT CAN
BE IMPROVED THROUGH CONSISTENCY
AND TIMELINESS. SECONDLY HAVE
DEPUTY SHERIFF ALYSSA CAROL OF
THE MARIPOSA SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT TO PRESENT AN
OVERVIEW OF HER TRAINING AND
EXPERIENCE AND RESPONDING TO
CALLS CONCERNING MISSING
PERSONS. WE WILL ASK FOR HER TO
PROVIDE HER INPUT AND
SUGGESTIONS FOR IMPROVING
RESPONSES TO A MISSING PERSONS
CALL. AND THE THIRD WE HAVE
TELL COTTRELL WHO'S THE
DISPATCHER OF CITRUS HEIGHTS
POLICE DEPARTMENT WHO WILL GIVE
AN OVERVIEW OF HER TRAINING AND
EXPERIENCE IN HANDLING CALLS
CONCERNING MISSING SINCE. I
ASKED THAT SHE PROVIDE A
DESCRIPTION OF HER
ADMINISTRATIVE DUTIES TWENTY
EIGHT AND THE MISSING PERSONS
CASES AND OF THE RESPECTIVE
DATED DATA IS. THIS FROM. THE
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING WHICH
SETS THE TRAINING STANDS
STANDARDS FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIA
LAW ENFORCEMENT. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND WE'D LIKE TO
HAVE YOU START BY PROVIDING US
WITH A GENERAL UNDERSTANDING OF
POST AND HOW IT WORKS. THE
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN ARCHER
MEMBERS THAN DISTINGUISHED LAW
FOR THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS CHARLES EVANS I'M A
SENIOR CONSULTANT THE SCIENTIST
TRAINING PROGRAM SERVICES
BUREAU COMMISSIONER PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THIS IS
QUITE AN HONOR AND WORDS ARE
INADEQUATE FOR ME TO
COMMUNICATE A GREAT SENSE OF
APPRECIATION THAT POST HAS FOR
BEING IT TO BE DISSIPATED
TODAY'S DIALOGUE REGARDING
MISSING PERSONS I WANT TO ADMIT
UP FRONT THAT I PERSONALLY.
ACTED A TOPIC. SO YOU'RE GOING
TO. YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS A
CHILD I HAD A FRIEND NAMED
JULIUS. OF WHO WAS NOT REPORTED
MISSING IN CLEVELAND OHIO-
WEEKS LATER HE WAS FOUND
HANGING FROM THE RAFTERS OF AN
ABANDONED ATTIC. I CAN'T HELP
BUT BELIEVE AND TRUST. THAT OF
JULIUS HAD BEEN REPORTED
MISSING. A MORE FAVORABLE
OUTCOME WOULD HAVE OCCURRED.
PERHAPS THIS COMMITTEE CAN
INVITE DOCTOR NEEDING BURKE
HARRIS ARE CALIFORNIA GET A
SURGEON GENERAL THE TO THE NAME
DIALOG HOW TO DISCUSS THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES AND
MISSING PERSONS. I WOULD NOW
LIKE TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW. OF THE EVOLUTION OF
POST- BEFORE TALK ABOUT NEXT
WITH TODAY'S TOPIC. THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING
GREW OUT OF A COMPLEX SET OF
ORIGINS FOLLOWING WHAT WERE
TRUE. AS MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
RETURN HOME FROM WAR THEY WERE
CONFRONTED BY THREE MAJOR
CHALLENGES. ENORMOUS
UNEMPLOYMENT AS PEOPLE
TRANSITION FROM A- WAR TIME TO
A PEACETIME ECONOMY. LOCALIST
ABILITY AS FEAR GRIPPED THE
NATION REGARDING THE SPREAD OF
COMMUNISM AND A SYSTEMIC RACISM
AS DISPARITIES REGARDING WEALTH
INCOME CRIMINAL JUSTICE
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING HEALTH
POLITICAL POWER IN EDUCATION
DISRUPTED SOCIETY. IN THE WAKE
OF THESE CONSIDERABLE
CHALLENGES A GROUP OF
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS MOST OF WHOM HAD
SERVED AS VETERANS IN THE
MILITARY. BEHIND A SHARED
VISION. A PROFESSIONAL LIGHTING
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
ADDRESS- THE AFOREMENTIONED AN
EMERGENT CHALLENGES I SUSPECT
THAT THE LESSONS ARE LEARNED
DURING WAR INFORMED THEIR
PUBLIC SAFETY DECISION MAKING.
AND PASSIONS THESE PIONEERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA LAW FOR TO PUT
PROFESSIONALISM MOVEMENT SHARE
THEIR VISION. WITH THE RESPECT
OF- LAFORTUNE ORGANIZATION
THESE ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDED
THE PEACE OFFICER RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
BETTER KNOWN AS PORAC. THE
CALIFORNIA PIECE ALSO SO SHE
XIN WEI. THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. THE LEADERSHIP OF
THESE FOR ASSOCIATIONS
COLLECTIVELY PETITION
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE- IN AN
EFFORT TO MANIFEST REFEREE
ASPIRATIONS OF PROFESSIONAL
LIGHTING CALIFORNIA LAW.
SECONDLY ON JULY ELEVENTH
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE GOVERNOR
BROWN ESTABLISHED POST. IS THAT
THE MINIMUM SELECTION AND
TRAINING STANDARDS FOR THE
PROFESSIONALIZATION OF
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT IT'S
A TORTILLAS CODIFIED IN
CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE THIRTEEN
FIVE HUNDRED. POST OVER ARCHING
MISSION IS TO CONTINUALLY
ENHANCE THE PROFESSIONALIZATION
OF CALIFORNIA'S SIX TWENTY TO
FORTY TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES LOCATED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE'S FIFTY COUNTIES.
PRESENTLY. NINETY THREE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY LAW SIMPLE. OUR PART OF
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT SAFETY NET
SERVING CALIFORNIA'S FORTY
MILLION CONSTITUENTS THIS
NETWORK IS REPRESENTED BY
EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED SWORN OFFICERS FOUR
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED SIXTY TWO
RESERVE OFFICERS AND SEVEN
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
NINETY A PUBLIC SERVICE
DISPATCHERS. OVER THE YEARS
POLLS HAVE EVOLVED TO BECOMING
NATIONAL AND WORLD LEADER. IN
LAW FOR THE SELECTION TRAINING.
TODAY THE POST ORGANIZATION
WITH MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY STAFF MEMBERS. NOW
FUNCTIONS UNDER THE DIRECTION
OF AN DIRECTOR WHO IS APPOINTED
BY COMMISSION THAT HAS BEEN
CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE. AS A
VOLUNTARY INCENTIVE BASED
ORGANIZATION BOTH AGENCIES
AGREE TO ABIDE BY THE STANDARDS
ESTABLISHED BY POST. OF THE
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED PLUS
MUNICIPAL COUNTY A STATE
AGENCIES VOLUNTARILY
PARTICIPATING THE POST PROGRAMS
50% FIFTY SEVEN. ARE NOT
INVOLUNTARY POST PARTICIPANTS.
OTHER DETERMINATION NOT TO BE
POST REIMBURSE AGENT
PARTICIPANT IS BASED ON THEIR
RESPECTIVE INTERNAL
ORGANIZATIONAL CONSIDERATIONS
AND PERHAPS THEIR PENAL CODE
CLASSIFICATION. NOTWITHSTANDING
THESE FIFTY SEVEN AGENCIES
ROUTINELY ATTEND MANY POSTS
MANY OPPOSE FOUR THOUSAND
CERTIFIED COURSES INCLUDING THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
DISPATCHER A MISSING PERSON
TRAINING COURSE. A PART OF POST
PARTICIPATING. WHICH IS PRETTY
AGENCIES ARE ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE- COMMISSION SERVICES
AND BENEFITS WHICH INCLUDE. JOB
RELATED ASSESSMENT TOOLS
RESEARCH INTO IMPROVED OFFICER
SELECTION STANDARDS. MANAGEMENT
COUNSELING SERVICES DEVELOPMENT
OF NEW TRAINING COURSES
REIMBURSEMENT FOR TRAINING
QUALITY LEADERSHIP PROGRAMS AND
AWARDS FOR PROFESSIONALS FOR
VACATIONS TO RECOGNIZE PEACE
OFFICER ACHIEVEMENTS OF
PROFICIENCY. THE POST OF
CERTIFIED LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER AND DISPATCHER MISSING
PERSON COURSE AS A REFER TO
EARLIER IS LEGISLATIVELY
MANDATED FOR PINNACLE SECTION
THIRTEEN FIVE ONE NINE POINT
ONE. EVERY LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS DATA CALIFORNIA'S
REQUIRED TO ATTEND THIS COURSE
IS PART OF THE RECRUIT BASIC
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS. THIS
SIXTEEN HOUR COURSE IS PRESENT
IN MULTIPLE TIMES THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR MY POST SURVIVE
PRISONERS ARE PRIMARY PRESENTER
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TRAINING CENTER. THE
MISSING PERSON COURSES-
DESIGNED TO GIVE STUDENTS
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS IS CENTRAL
TO THE INVESTIGATION A MISSING
PERSONS AND HUMAN BODY
IDENTIFICATION. THE COURSE
PROVIDES AN OVERVIEW OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE MISSING PERSON AN
UNIDENTIFIED PERSON SECTION
MOPS. THE MISSING PERSON SYSTEM
AND ON IT UNIDENTIFIED PERSON
SYSTEM DATABASES MANDATE AND
THE IMPORTANCE OF ASSISTING THE
UNIDENTIFIED LIVING PERSONS
INVESTIGATION. OF COURSE
HIGHLIGHTS A SERVICES MUST CAN
PROVIDE- BUT TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO ASSIST THEM. IN A
MISSING AND I DO NOT THIS IS A
PATIENTS AND TO ANSWER FOR
EQUALLY ANSWER QUESTIONS ASK
QUESTIONS. I WILL ALSO INCLUDE
AN OVERVIEW. OF THE MISSING
PERSONS AND I DID THAT
UNIDENTIFIED SYSTEM- NAME IS.
AND HIGH PROFILE ABDUCTION
INVESTIGATION RECOMMENDATION
THE RESOURCES FINALLY OF COURSE
COVERS RELEVANT FORENSIC
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY. AND
ADVANCES FINGERPRINT ON
TECHNIQUES. AND WITH THAT I'LL
ALAS THE PARTICULAR QUESTIONS.
I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE MY
COLLEAGUES SENATORS ANNA
CABALLERO AND SENATOR BAR
JESSE AND SENATOR RUBIO IF THEY
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE ANY OPENING
REMARKS AS WELL I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US ON OUR
FIRST COMMITTEE HEARING. IN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND I WANT. TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS REALLY
AND OF I DON'T HAVE ANY ANY
STATEMENTS I JUST- HAD A
QUESTION OF OUR- OUR ESTEEMED
GUESTS. THEY IF THAT'S OKAY IF
I JUMP RIGHT IN THERE- IT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION HERE
TODAY IT'S VERY INFORMATIVE AND
THAT THE HISTORY- AND THAT YOU
OUTLINED IS- I THINK IS REALLY.
IMPORTANT AS WELL. IN TERMS OF
THE COURSE REQUIREMENT- THAT
YOU YOU DESCRIBED IS IT TOO
IT'S ONE COURSE EVERYONE HAS TO
TAKE AND I'M ASSUMING THAT
THAT- THE DETECTIVES GET. A
MORE IN DEPTH- TRAINING ON SOME
OF THE SUBJECTS BECAUSE THEY'RE
THE INDIVIDUALS TO GET THE
CASES TRANSFERRED TO THEM IS
THAT RIGHT. WRECKED BECAUSE OF
COURSE THE LEGISLATIVELY
MANDATED COURSE- WE HAVE
MULTIPLE MODULES WITHIN OUR
CREE QUE. THIS IS A LEARNING
DOMAIN TWENTY SEVEN. I IT IS OF
THE MATERIAL I AN OPRY TO YOU.
AND SO EVERY LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER. GRADUATED FROM THE
ACADEMY HAS TO GO THROUGH THE
COURSE- UNDER OUR I SEE I
PROGRAM. OUR DETECTIVE TRAINING
PROGRAM THAT THEY ARE FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO A DISH- FOR
THEMSELVES TO LOOK AT- NUANCES
OF DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF
INVESTIGATIONS INVOLVING
MISSING PERSONS HOMICIDE AND
OTHER. OF THE CASES SO- OUR
PRIMARY PRISON FOR THAT'S THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THEY
CONDUCT ABOUT FOUR CLASSES PER
YEAR. OF THE MISSING PERSONS
COURSE FOR IN SERVICE AND ALL
OUTSIDE OF OUR OUR NETWORK OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THAT'S ALL I HAVE MADAM
CHAIR. SENATOR BY JEFF. URBAN I
DO NOT LIKE MY COLLEAGUE-
CENTER COVER YOUR WOULD LIKE
TO- GIVE THANKS TO CENTER
GALGIANI FOR MAKING US CERTAIN
THAT THIS HEARING HAPPEN AND
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE IS CREATED I
STATEMENTS TO MAKE. I KIND OF
WANT TO JUST ASK YOU IS
LOCATED- WOMAN. WHEN I WAS A
KID I USED TO WATCH. TV SHOWS
AND FOR SOME REASON I RECOLLECT
THAT WITH AN ADULT. THAT THERE
BE A TWENTY FOUR HOUR PERIOD
BEFORE THE AUTHORITIES WOULD
TAKE ACTION ON A MISSING PERSON.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE CASE WITH
YOUNGSTERS OR MINOR HIS ACT IS
THAT. IS THAT ACCURATE OR WAS
ABSOLUTELY WHAT THE WHAT NO I
THINK THE FIRST PART WITH THE
URBAN LEGEND OKAY AND SO THE
SECOND PART IS NOT AND SO-
ANYONE CAN MAKE A MISSING
PERSONS REPORT AT ANY GIVEN
TIME- AGAIN TO ALLOW THE SLAYER
COME TO THE STATION INTO IT.
BUT WITH MORE PROACTIVE WHEN
THE ISSUES RELATE TO
ADOLESCENTS AND YOUNG CHILDREN
THOSE CASES DEPENDING ON THE
AGE OF THE KIDS THE TILES ON
MENTAL ABILITY THOSE THINGS ARE
HANDLED AS A PRIORITY QUE.
WITHIN THE FIRST- TWO HOURS.
I'M. FOR EXACT COLLECT YOU HAVE
TO ENTER THAT INFORMATION INTO
CLASS WITHIN THE FIRST FOUR
HOURS. AND SO WE HAVE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT- TRACKING SYSTEMS
WHICH- PROBABLY DOJ CAN ASK
MORE SPECIFICALLY. IT REQUIRES
TO RESPOND TO THOSE MISSING
PERSON INVESTIGATION ON A
PRIORITY BASIS. ARTS OF BUT IN
TERMS OF THE PATHOLOGY OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCE. IS THE TRAINING
THAT TO INDIVIDUALS RECEIVED
RIPOSTE. DIFFERENT FOR MISSING
ADULTS VERSES MISSING MINERS.
YES AND SO THERE IS THAT THERE
IS A CHECKLIST THIS IS THE THIS
GIVEN TO EACH EDGE THE TRUCK
JOURNAL PATROL OFFICER. AND SO
IT MAKES A SIMPLE THIS WAY THEY
DON'T UNINTENTIONALLY MYTH ANY
STEP THAT IS THE REALLY A-
THREE. STEP OF THE THAT THEY
HAVE TO DO Và AND SO THEY GET
THAT. AND SO ON. YES WE HAVE TO
GIVE IT A DIFFERENCE. TO
JUVENILES BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES. THERE VULNERABLE
AND INNOCENT I KNOW WE'LL GET A
NUMBER THAT A MORE DETAIL AS-
CORE SERVICE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK FOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I WANTED THANK
GOD LAW IF YOU ARE GOING TO
TEST BEFORE US THIS IS. GREAT
IMPORTANT. AND YOUR STORY OF.
YOUR YOUTH IS. REALLY HARBOR
AND DIE IN SOME FOR THE DOING
THIS ON PARTY FOR ME TO WANTED
PART OF AND EIGHTEEN I A- OF A
CONCERT AFFRONT ALSO HER FOR
HER HIS LIP OF THE LITTLE BOY
MISSING FIVE EURO. AND HE FOUND
OUT DATA WELL SO IT'S- IN A WAY
THAT YOU KNOW THEY'RE YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IT BECOMES A
PERSONAL MODELED MATTER TO YOU
AS WELL. BUT I WANT TO CLARIFY
A LITTLE BIT WITH MISTER
BURGESS SAID I'VE HEARD THAT
OVER AND OVER AGAIN EVEN WITHIN
MY CONSTITUENCY A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER. AND THEY WOULD CALL ME
ARE WHEN THEY'RE THEY'RE
TEENAGER WAS GONE NOT
NECESSARILY ADULTS BUT THEIR
TEENAGER OR WAS EIGHTEEN AND
I'VE HEARD THAT OFTEN TO LIKE.
YOU KNOW LET'S WAIT TO SEE HE'S
NOT A RUNAWAY AND SAT. FALLS OR
DO THE SORT OF THAT THE CASES
AND THEN DECIDE THAT. YOU KNOW
I MEAN BASED ON THE HISTORY THE
CHILD BUT I'VE HEARD THAT CAN
EVEN MY CAN IT'S NOT THAT ARE
OUT TO WAIT THE. COME THE NEXT
MORE IN OUR LATE NIGHT I DON'T
KNOW. FOR THE I THINK EACH THE-
IS OF HIS BIG. ALSO I THINK A
LOT. EVERY LAW FOR. A HAS THE-
REGIONAL IDENTITY. AND SO THEY
MAY CHOOSE TO X. HOW THE- OF. I
WAS A CAP WITH THE PT. AS OF
THAT DEFINITELY WOULDN'T. RUN
THE IT WOULD WORK FOR US. AND
SO. IN DIFFERENT JURY. YOUNG
WITH. THERE IS THE WAY THEY WE
SHOULD DO THINGS AND THE WAY
THAT WE AT. DO THE- AND AREA
DEPARTMENT HAS A PARTNERS A-
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE AGENCY. THEIR
FOCUS ON. CRIMES THE- IN ORDER
HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT. DOES
THE IT THE INVESTIGATION
MISSING PART. FALL FROM THE
PRIOR OF YOUR CAR THAT CASE.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE PRIOR IN IT
AND URBAN OR A ROOM DEPARTMENT.
THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT PRIOR IS
A- AND EVERY PART OF. HAS A.
AND SO THE KIDS IS THAT.
BECAUSE THE SYSTEM'S THAT CAN
OF MENTIONED NEMETH. AND. SEE I
SEE. OUR CAT UNIT BECAUSE THIS
ARE IN PLAY. WE NOW HAVE TRANCE
DISCIPLINARY KIND IT INNER IN
AGE. NETWORK SO IT'S TO
DIFFERENT IS NOT LOOK. LOCATED
OR ISOLATE. IN A PARTICULAR AGE
SILO. IF IT'S ACTUALLY BEEN SO.
VIEW TECHNOLOGY. THANK YOU THAT.
REALLY APPRECIATE. OF WHAT IS
IDENTIFIED AS THE MISSING IN
SOME OF OUR JUVENILE HOMES THE
HOME OPERATIVES MAY I
IMMEDIATELY PUT OUT A MISSING
PERSON BECAUSE THEY'VE HAD IN.
A CONFLICT A PERSONALITY
CONFLICT AND SO- DOES LOCATION
BECOME BECOME LIKE REPEAT
COLOCATION. AS THE WE IDENTIFY
IF IN FACT WE GET THREE P. COST
MOST AND LOCATIONS- BUT WHEN A
CALL FIRST COMES IN IT MAY NOT
GO TO THE OFFICER IN FACT IT'LL
PROBABLY BE A TELEPHONIC. INTO
A DISPATCH CENTER AND ALL OF
OUR DISPATCHERS ACTUALLY GO
THROUGH THE SAME COURSE ALSO.
BUILT DEL ASSESS THE SITUATION
AND THEY'LL THE DOLLAR SIGN AT
THE CALL IS A SIGN IMMEDIATELY.
YOU KNOW ITS DEPEND UPON WHAT
WE'RE THAT CALL FALLS IN THE
QUEUE. OF THE OFFICERS RADIO
CALLS THEY SHOULD BE RESPOND TO
THAT. SOONER THAN LATER. AND SO
GOES FROM THE FOR THE REPORTING
PARTY TO THE DISPATCHER. TO THE
POLICE OFFICER NOW DISPATCHERS
A CRUCIAL PLAYS A CRUCIAL ROLE
IN THIS. BECAUSE THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY YOU KNOW TO
NAVIGATE THE AMBIGUITY OF THE
EMOTIONALISM OF THE CALLER- AND
THE SOMETIMES THE CALL IS A
PLAN F. BECAUSE THEY- THEY JUST
WANT TO HAVE SOMEBODY TO STOP
BY THE POLICE. AND SO THE
DEBATE DISPATCHES ARE KEY
THEY'RE ALMOST LIKE A FORENSIC
PSYCHOLOGIST. YOU KNOW DEPEND
UPON HOW LONG BEFORE THE JOB
THE X. BECOME VERY VERY GOOD AT
IDENTIFYING. GETTING TO THE
CORE ELEMENTS AND THAT'S THAT'S
HELPFUL. AND THEN THAT
DISPATCHER HE OR SHE WILL THEN
SEND THE CALL OUT FOR
PARTICULAR DEPUTY. OR A POLICE
OFFER YOU PLEASE ALSO UNIT. AND
THEY'LL GET THE ITEM ON THE
CHECKLIST THAT WE PROVIDED BILL
CALLED. THE DISPATCHERS
ACTUALLY HAVE THAT ALSO. AND SO
NOT ONLY TO THE FIELD OFFICES
HAVE THAT CHECKLIST. THE
DISPATCHERS HAVE A CHECKLIST
ALSO. AND SO. WHEN THE OFFICERS
RESPOND TO THE TO THE LOCATION
THEN THEY'LL WHAT THEY'LL
PROBABLY GET. MOM THE MORE SOME
OF SUBSTANCE OF WHAT THE- THE
NUANCES OF THE BACKSTORY OF THE
REPORT IS. YOU KNOW I LIKE THIS
THAT I LOOK AT TAKE A MISSING
PERSONS REPORT. AS BEING PART
OF A COMPLEX ADAPTIVE SYSTEMS
AND YOUR ON COMPLEXITY- I
CALLED. BECAUSE MANY THINGS ARE
INVOLVED IN TAKING A MISSING
PERSONS REPORT FOR THE COMPLEX.
DATA BECAUSE OF MANY THINGS
REPORTER WITH. THE THERE CHIU.
AND THOSE ME THINGS ALL.
CHANGING IN THAT COULD TO OTHER.
SO OFF HAVE TO. POST ON THEM
AND- LATEST TO COME. AGREE WITH.
TODAY YOU CAN NOW CALL GIRL
COMES THE RESEARCH ON IT AND TO
THE BATCH TO THEN PUTS IT AND
THE OFFICER Q. HOW DO THAT WORK
ANY WALK US THROUGH AT A TIME
LINE SUGGEST WITH TIME IS THAT
SO THAT IN THE GUIDELINE FOR
THE WITH THE QUESTION IS ARE
THERE ANY ARE TIME REQUIRE FOR
THE TO GOOD OF MR PERSONS OF.
AND THE ISSUE IS IT IF THE
JUVENILE YESTERDAY TO GET ON
THAT RIGHT AWAY- IF THEY'RE A
IF IT'S MORE GENERAL. THE
INFORMATION AND THEY'LL
ACTUALLY GONNA START LOOKING
FOR THAT PERSON. BUT DEPENDING
ON THE AGENCY. BECAUSE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES HAVE THE
PREROGATIVE. TO HAVE PUT
DIFFERENT TIME LINES ON THAT
INVESTIGATION. FOR YOU KNOW
THAT WOULD BE- AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT QUESTION WITH POST
BECAUSE POST AS PRIMARILY A
THINK TANK. AND SO WHAT WE DO
WE BRING IN THE VARIOUS SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS. AND THIS THE
EXPERTS WHO BRING AND THE- THE
IDEAS IN THE AREAS THAT WE
SHOULD START FOCUSING MORE
ATTENTION AND FOR THAT BECAUSE-
I THINK WE HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK.
AT DEVELOPING A CALL AGREED A
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIP
REGARDING ENTITIES THAT PROVIDE
A FOR INSURGENCY OLOGY ENTITIES
SUCH AS- C. R. I. GENETICS OR
TWENTY THREE IN ME OR AND
ANCESTRY .COM. FAMILY IN OR FOR
ME. ENTITIES THE PRODUCTS. CUT
IN OUR REALLY. IT'S I'M I'M
HAPPY THAT MAJORITY PEOPLE CALL
MISSARE NOT. REALLY HARM OF
THEM A RETURN. BUT NEVERTHELESS
THAT DOESN'T BURDEN THAT THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF POST. AND SO
I SUGGEST THAT- POST AS A THINK
TANK A RESEARCH AGENCY. DEVELOP
A PROTOCOL OF- JUSTICE FOR
MISSING PERSONS AND MAYBE WE
CAN DEVELOP DEVELOP A MISSING
PERSONS COLLABORATORY. BETWEEN
THE AGENCIES. AND I SUGGEST
THAT WE ALSO TAKE A LOOK AT OF
HELPING GREAT RELATIONSHIPS
WITH ENTITIES THAT HAVE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR EXAMPLE.
THE RAND CORPORATION WERE THE
HERITAGE FOUNDATION OR HUDSON
INSTITUTE THE COUNCIL
FORMULATIONS OF THE PEW
RESEARCH CENTER BROOKINGS
INSTITUTE AND EVEN DARPA.
BECAUSE DARK- DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE ADVANCED WEAPONS I
UNDERSTAND THAT. WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO MILITARIZE OFFERS A
BY THE WAY. IT'S BUT HE IS THAT
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE SOME
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE SHOULD AVAIL
OURSELVES TO. SO IF THEY'RE
ABLE TO HAVE- ON A SYSTEM. THEY
COULD LOCATE A DAY I DID.
DISEASE SEN UNDER THE GROUND IS
JUST SO THEY CAN BE LIKE TRYING
TO FLEE. IN LA P. WE HAVE A
HUGE. ASTRAL DIVISION HEALTH.
AND WE CAN DELIVER THE TRAY. HE
PATTERN PATH OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
RUNNING WITHOUT THE PURSE. IS
IT POSSIBLE WITH ADVANCED THAT
ARE ARE- PARTNERS HAVE BEEN IN
THE MILITARY IS IT POSSIBLE
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY DEVELOP A
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEM WE'RE IN WE CAN LEVERAGE
SOME OF THE TECHNOLOGY THAT
THEY'VE DEVELOPED OVER TIME.
WILL IT BE GREAT IF THE ABILITY
TO LOAD UP LOCATED DECEASED
PERSON UNDERGROUND WAS LIMITED
TO THE K. NINE. WHICH YOU CAN
DO IT ELECTRONICALLY. WOULDN'T
IT BE GREAT. YOU KNOW AND SO
DIDN'T AS WE BEGIN TO TAKE A
LOOK THINGS LIKE EPIGENETICS
MAYBE THEY COULD EVEN TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT ALSO. KNOWING THAT
THE BIOLOGICAL MAKE UP OF A
PERSON UNDERGROUND- CAN BE
PICKED UP. TECHNOLOGY HAS MANY
OPPORTUNITIES OPPOSE MANY
THREATS BUT IT HAS MANY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO
LEVERAGE IN REAL TIME. I
APPRECIATE YOUR SUGGESTIONS
HERE AND I WAS GOING TO BE MY
NEXT QUESTION AS AS TO- AT WHAT
POINT AND HOW IS IT THAT. LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN MAKE
SUGGESTIONS TO POST AND HOW
THAT HOW WOULD THAT BE
INCORPORATED WHAT WOULD THAT
PROCESS. LOOK LIKE. BUT IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL IDEAS AS WELL THAT
ARE ARE WELL YOUR POINTS ARE
WELL TAKEN. WE RECEIVE MOST OF
OUR- INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT IS
POSSIBLE OR GREATER ALL THE
GREAT IDEAS COME FROM THE
OFFICERS IN THE FIELD PROBABLY
EVER DOES COME FROM COMMAND WE
TAKE CREDIT BUT ALL THOSE GREAT
IDEAS COME FROM FROM THEM SO WE
AUDIT EVERY EVERY. TWO PERSONS
CLASS IS THE IS THE OBJECT OF
AN AUDIT WE HONOR THE VALUE WE
TAKE A LOOK AT THE INSTRUCTOR
DELIVERY. IN TERMS ARE THEY
MAINTAIN THE MAINTAINING THE
INTEGRITY OF THE- EXPAND COURSE
OUTLINE. ARE THEY HITTING ALL
OF THE TOPICS THIS EXTREME PUT
TOGETHER BY SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS WHOEVER A PULSE- WE'LL
WE ALL OF THE CURRICULUM. FOR
RELEVANCY FOR CURRENCY I WE
MAKE A DAT ADAPT HAITIANS AS
NECESSARY AND TYPICALLY THE
ADAPTATIONS THAT WE MAKE A VERY
AGILE. AND SO WE WILL WE WILL
MAKE THOSE THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY- WE CAN UPDATE
APPROVED- ACRYLAMIDE EDUCATION
IN TERMS OF ADDING THINGS
WITHIN AN HOUR. GET THAT
INFORMATION OUT. YEAH WE HAVE A
REGIONAL CONSULTANTS THAT ARE
VERY GOOD TO HAVE CLOSE WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH EVERY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. SO BOTH-
HAS A HIGHLY NETWORKED
RELATIONSHIP WITH ALL OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. ON THE LOCAL.
STATE NATIONAL. AND EVEN
INTERNATIONAL BASIS- YOU YOU
PROBABLY DON'T KNOW WHAT BUT-
POST FREQUENTLY WE ENTERTAIN
ENTERTAIN- DIGNITARIES FROM
OTHER NATIONS BECAUSE THEY
THINK THAT WHAT WE HAVE FAR
EXCEEDS. OF THE ADVANCEMENT OF
THEIR CURRICULUM. AND IT'S TRUE
AND IS TRUE IT'S TRUE AND SO
WE'RE VERY PROACTIVE IN THAT
AREA- I THINK THAT WE SHOULD
ALSO TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT SOME
OF THE SOCIAL MEDIA TECHNOLOGY
USED WHEN GET VESTED GATE
MISSING PERSON I TALK ABOUT-
INTO A AS THE ICY. NAME IS A
CLASS- WHICH IMAGE YOU HAVE THE
INTERNET INFORMATION WITHIN
FOUR HOURS- I THINK WE SHOULD
TAKE MORE A CLOSER LOOK AT SOME
OF THE SOCIAL NETWORKING SITE.
WE CAN ELIMINATE SOME OF THE
OLD SCHOOL THINGS LIKE DOOR
KNOCKING BECAUSE THAT'S THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT ALSO BUT I THINK
WE HAVE TO INCREASE OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH SURVEILLING
CERTAIN FOLKS- GPS TRACKING
DEVICES LISTENING DEVICES
HIDDEN MINIATURE CAMERAS A
COVERT BRADY BODY CALMEST ASH
CAN. MAYBE BUT BRIDGE A BRUSH
CAMERA. MILLET IMAGERY SURVEYS
TAKE. FLAT APT OPTICAL LIKE
DETECTION- KINDS OF TECHNOLOGY
I MEAN TO IT THERE'S A FULL
SPECTRUM. OF THINGS THAT WE
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY DO IF WE
HAVE THE WILL TO DO IT. AND SO
OUR OBJECTIVE IS ALWAYS ENSURE
THAT OUR INSTRUCTORS ARE NEVER
TEACHING FROM OF A SILO
PERSPECTIVE. WE ALWAYS WANTED
TO INTERACT. BECAUSE OF THAT
INFORMATION COMES. OUTSIDE YOU
MENTIONED THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE HAS TECHNOLOGY THAT
YOU BELIEVE COULD BE USED TO
INDICATE THE PRESENCE OF
UNIDENTIFIED REMAINS. CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THAT AGAIN PLEASE YEAH
THEY'VE BEEN DOING THAT FOR
EXAMPLE FOR YEARS THE
MILITARY'S ACTUALLY BEEN
INSERTING- BIO INFORMATION
SHIPS IN SOLDIERS. IN THE EVENT
THAT THEY GET SEPARATED YOU
KNOW AND SO- AND THERE IS A LOT
NOW TO REALLY DRILL DOWN TO
FIND OUT THE NUANCES OF THEIR
ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE TO
DEVELOP A GREAT RELATIONSHIP
WHAT I'VE DISCOVERED- IS THAT
MANY OF OUR MILITARY ALL THE
FIVE BRANCHES NOW SIX WITH THE-
THE SPACE BRANCH- MANY OF OUR
BRANCHES OF THE FIVE BRANCHES
AT LEAST. THEY'RE VERY A
SECRETIVE ABOUT THEIR
TECHNOLOGY I THINK WE HAVE TO
BE MORE FOR PROACTIVE IN
DEVELOPING A SHARE
RESPONSIBILITY WITH AND WE MUST
HAVE TO LOBBY AND LIKE MANY OF
YOUR CONSTITUENTS LOBBY YOU AS
A WE ACTUALLY HAVE TO HAVE THAT
KIND OF RELATIONSHIP IN ORDER
TO GAIN ACCESS TO WITH A NO.
AND SO I THINK THAT ARE THERE'S
MUCH THAT WE CAN DO BECAUSE WE
HAVE INFORMATION WE JUST HAVE
TO HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DO IT.
THANK YOU. NOW THE QUESTION.
THIS I'M SORRY IN THE QUESTIONS
ARE JUST MORE CURIOSITY I MEAN
I KNOW IT HAPPENS BUT IT CAN
YOU SHARE WHAT CRITERIA HAS TO
BE MET BEFORE LIKE A LOCAL
AGENCY TRANSFERS A CASE TO THE
FBI MATHIS HIM AT SOME POINT
THE POLICE HANDLES IT UNTIL
THEY CAN NO LONGER SO HOW DOES
A TRANSFER HAPPENED A CALL TO
THE FBI HOW DO THEY GET
INVOLVED I WOULD THINK THAT IF
THERE'S AN INTERSTATE
JURISDICTION HELLO THIS TO YOU
HAVE A- YOU HAVE A- I DON'T
HAVE FILE. LETTER FOLLOWS KNOWN
IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WHEN THE INFORMATION
GOES IN THE NAME IS WORTH THE
ICY WE ACTUALLY OF ABILITY NOW
TO HAVE A NETWORKED INFORMATION
SYSTEM WHERE WE COULD PICK UP
THAT INFORMATION FROM OTHERS
SO. IF THE QUESTION IS WHEN
DOES THE CASE BECOME A COURT
CASE. AND SO. WE HAVE THE CASE
UP TO THE POINT THAT THERE ARE
NO NO FURTHER LEADS. NOW YOU
HAVE TO TALK TO EXPECTED AGENCY
TO DETERMINE WHAT OTHER RAT
WHAT ARE THE LOCAL. ARE
REQUIREMENTS PROCEDURES
POLICIES PROCEDURES REGARDING
WHEN THE CASE GOES COAL. HOW
LONG DO YOU ALLOW THAT TO BE IN
A POSITION IN TYPICALLY STAYS
THERE. UNTIL SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. A COMES IN WE HAD
THAT WITH OUR- WAS THAT THE
STRANGLER HERE. I IN IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE GETTING THIS
NAME. BUT OF. THE TRANSFER IS
NEVER REALLY TRANSFERRED TO
ANOTHER AGENCY. IT'S USUALLY A
SITUATION WE COLLABORATE WITH
ANOTHER AGENCY IF THERE IS A
HIT. AND SO THEY HAVE TO BE A
NEED ACT ACTUALLY OPEN A CO
CASE. SO WHAT'S CONSIDERED A
COLD CASE IN TERMS OF TIMELINE
HAS AND THAT'S THE THIS
QUESTION IS SO EACH DEPARTMENT
WOULD DETERMINE THAT PROCESS
AND HAVE A- DETERMINATION FOR
WHAT A CO CASES. YOU KNOW SO WE
TOOK A LOOK AT THE HOUSE RIGHT
HILLSIDE STRANGLER CASE YOU
KNOW THOSE THINGS HAVE BEEN
DONE DECADES AGO ALMOST A
DECADE AGO BUT THE KEY IS THAT
IT TOOK SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION SO THE KEY REMAIN
COOL SO HOW LONG IS. A CASE A
NOW PUT ON A BURKE ON ON SITE
ON THE SIDE BURNER. IT'S A
LOCAL DETERMINATION SENATE
FIRING SHARE I IT WAS UNDER THE
IMPRESSION THAT IT DIDN'T HAVE
TO BE A COLD CASE MAYBE I'M I
MISUNDERSTOOD AT TIMES WERE THE
FBI COME SOONER TO TRY AND HELP
EXPEDITE LIKE FINDING A MISSING
CHILD OR AT NINE ASSIST WE HAVE
TO REQUEST THAT ALL YOU HAVE
AGENCY HAS TO TRIGGER THAT
REQUEST. AND THERE IS NO
STANDARDIZATION FOR WHEN YOU DO
THAT YOU KNOW AND SALAS JUST
COMES OUT TO A PERSON I'M IN A
RELATIONSHIP YOU KNOW AND SO
THAT THERE THERE IS NO POST
MANDATE OR STANDARD. THAT
REQUIRES YOU CONTACT AN OUTSIDE
AGENCY. OR HOMICIDE
INVESTIGATOR INVESTIGATORS OF
MISSING PERSONS- ARE ARE
TYPICALLY VERY FOCUS. THE RE
PASSION ABOUT RESOLVING EVERY
CASE. BUT AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER EVERY INVESTIGATOR HAS
A PRIOR CASES ON THAT THEY MUST
HANDLE IN THE- I'M NOT ERTAIN
WHAT THE TIPPING POINT IS. FOR
WHEN A CASE GOALS. COLE HAS TO
MY LAST QUESTION IF I MAY I'M
NOT SURE WHO CREATED A REPORT
THAT I READ THAT WAS GIVEN TO
ME. BUT IT STATES THAT
CALIFORNIA IN CALIFORNIA AND
OTHER WERE THIRTY NINE THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR
REPORTED ADULTS MISSING AND
SEVEN NINE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN CHILDREN
IN. TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUT IT
DOESN'T HAVE. THE OUTCOME OF
HOW MANY WERE RECOVERED DO YOU
HAPPEN TO KNOW THAT INFORMATION
AS OPPOSED LIKE YOU KNOW HOW
MANY RECOVERED HOW MANY. WHEN
COLD WE HAVE ANY DATA ON I
DON'T HAVE NUMBERS ON
CALIFORNIA HER THIS YEAR
MENTION THAT NUMBER. I DON'T
I'M NOT AWARE THAT WHEN- BUT I
THINK SOMEBODY IS LOOKING INTO
THAT SOME OF OUR SUCH ABOUT
EXPERTS BIKE HERE MIGHT BE
AWARE THAT. OKAY I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN THAT IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU. AND I WOULD
ADD THAT I HAD A WONDERFUL
MEETING WITH REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE EARLIER IN THE WEEK
AND WE SPOKE TO THAT MATTER SO.
PERHAPS THEY CAN ANSWER THAT
QUESTION- WHEN THEY'RE UP HERE
ON THE PANEL AND THEIR FAMILIES
I THINK THAT HAD BEEN THERE
WILL GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE ON
YOURS ACOSTA PDF OFF THE CHART.
VICE IN LOS ANGELES AND I GET.
ALL IT WILL HOLD. A. SO MY
PARTNER I GO. AND WHEN THE KIDS
WAS JUST KINDA. YOU KNOW NERVE.
SAYING I GOTTA GO TO THE
RESTROOM AMOUNTS TO NOW THAT
JUST STAY HERE. AS SHE SAID GO
AHEAD. AND SOUL. FOR WILL. TO
HAVE. I DON'T THINK IT TO
WISHLIST BY MANNA FROM HEAVEN
AT. INTO IS JUST. COLLECTED
BEHAVE COM EXPERIENCE OVER
TIME. YOU HAVE MORE TO REFER
TO. SO MY INTUITION LET ME TO
LEAN OUT THE- DEPARTMENT AND
LOOKED DOWN THE HALL. AND I SAW
THIS GAUNTLET. OF A MALES
TYPICALLY THE MILK PARA FALLS
IN LA COUNTY JAIL RELEASED. THE
GET VOUCHERS TO STAY IN A
HOTEL. NOW THE HOTELS A TARGET
RICH AREAS FOR. CHILDREN TO BE.
EXPLOITED BY PETA FILES. SO I
LOOKED DOWN I SAW THE KID
DISAPPEAR. LIKE BY MINISTER TO
THE SECOND BECAUSE WITH MY
PARTNER SECONDLY MY PARTNER.
AND BUT- THE REASON THE KID.
WAS GETTING STOP IS BECAUSE THE
THE RESTAURANT ALL THE
BATHROOMS AND SHOWERS IN THE
HOTELS ARE AT THE END OF THE
HALL. SO YOU HAVE TO GO TO THE
END OF THE HALL AND THE KIND OF
THE BEEN THERE. SO I WASN'T
THERE FOR THAT REASON I HAD TO
STAY WITH MY PARTNER AND I
COULD INVESTIGATE THAT. FIVE
YEARS LATER. I'M IN CHARGE OF
VICE- IN DOWNTOWN ONE OF MY
GUYS BRINGS. IN A YOUNG PERSON.
WITH A PROSTITUTE. TURNS OUT
THAT PERSON WAS ONE OF THE KIDS
WHO LIVE IN A HOTEL AND I
WANTED TO MYSELF IS THERE
SOMETHING THAT I COULD HAVE
DONE. FIVE YEARS EARLIER. THE
COULD PREVENT IT THAT OUTCOME A
BEEN A REST AS A PROSTITUTE
FIVE YEARS LATER. SO WHEN WE
LOOK INTO OUR SYSTEM- NEMETH
AND IS THE ICY IT CAME OF THAT
PERSON WAS A MISSING PERSON.
WHAT ARE THE CHANCES OF THAT
HAPPENING. I THINK THE CHANCES
ARE GREAT. AS A WE TAKE A LOOK
AT A LOT OF A LOT OF OUR HOMES
COMMUNITY. HOW MANY PERSONS ARE
ACTUALLY MISSING. PROBABLY A
LOT OF THEM THAT'S WHY I JUST
WANT TO PUT THAT IN THERE
BECAUSE IT'S A SERIOUS ISSUE-
IS NOT EMERGENT IS HERE NOW.
AND SO I THINK WHAT WE WHAT WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH. IS THE
FUTURE NOW. THIS ORDER WHAT ARE
THE- WHAT ARE THE PROBLEM
SOLVING SOLUTIONS THAT WE'RE
NOW. WE HAVE AT OUR FINGERTIPS.
THERE WE CAN LEVERAGE. FOR THE
BENEFIT OF SAVING. THOSE
POTENTIAL MISSING PEOPLE. FROM
BECOMING PERMANENTLY MISSING.
YES. YOU'RE GOING DOWN WHERE I
WAS HOPING TO. DO YOU HAVE ANY
LEGAL THIS POST HAVE ANY LEGAL
OR POLITICAL RECOMMENDATIONS ON
THAT YOU'D BE WILLING TO SHARE.
I SPENT ENOUGH TIME IN POLITICS
BOTH LOCAL AND HERE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT. THERE'S NOT
ALWAYS A SEAMLESS. INTER
OPERABILITY IN GOVERNMENT IT'S
HUMAN INSTITUTION AND ALWAYS DO
IS LOOK BACK AT NINE ELEVEN TO
SEE HOW THE WRITING AND DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT THE LEFT HAND WAS
DOING AND VICE VERSA- U. P.
TALKED ABOUT SEEING PATTERNS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY LEGAL OR
POLITICAL RECOMMENDATIONS OR
HAVE YOU ENCOUNTERED PROBLEMS
INSTITUTIONAL OR SYSTEMIC
PROBLEMS THAT DEAL WITH
LIMITATIONS ON PROFILING WAR
WHETHER PROFILING CAN BE
HELPFUL- YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
PATTERNS OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
MAYBE HAVE BEEN INCARCERATED
PRIOR FOR HAVING GAUGED CERTAIN
MISS BEHAVIORS THAT ARE
UNLIKELY TO- BE RESOLVED. SO
KIND OF LOOKING AT THAT- DO YOU
HAVE ANY POLITICAL LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT COULD BE
HELPFUL. AND IN DEALING WITH
MISSING PERSONS. AS A SENIOR
YOU KNOW POSTED IN A POLITICAL
OUR ORGANIZATION SO WERE
PROHIBITED FROM GIVING THOSE
KINDS OF RESPONSES. BUT BUT
SERVICE TO DO THAT YOU KNOW I
IN A YOU KNOW WE HAVE A- BUT
THE ANSWER IS YES- BUT I DON'T
COMMENT ON THAT BECAUSE I
WANTED TO TROUBLE. OKAY
BREAKING THE LAW I HAVE. AND
THAT BRINGS US TO. THE MISSING
PERSON DATABASES- NCIC VIE CAP
NAME AS- IT'S RATHER CONFUSING-
FOR A FAMILY MEMBER IN
PARTICULAR AND I KNOW THAT IN
MY DISTRICT I'VE HAD. A NUMBER
OF CALLS FROM FAMILY MEMBERS
HIS LEFT LENDS WENT MISSING AND
THEY'RE- THEY'RE HOPING THAT
THEIR FAMILY MEMBER IS THAT
THAT THE STATE'S DOJ WEBSITE.
MAYBE THEY ARE AND ARE
DISCOVERING THAT THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS NOT LISTED IN NAME S.
NCIC IS PRIVATE. SO THE
QUESTION TO YOU IS. DOES POST.
CONCERN ITSELF WITH. WITHIN THE
PROVIDING GUIDELINES OF HOW AND
WHEN A MISSING INDIVIDUAL
SHOULD BE ENTERED INTO EACH OF
THE DIFFERENT DATABASES. AT
THIS IN EXPECT EXPECT COURSE
ALLEN THAT GIVE YOU AND IF I
CAN LEAVE THAT ANSWER TO ONE OF
THE PRACTITIONERS I WOULD FEEL
MORE COMFORTABLE. OKAY THANK
YOU AND THEN FINALLY THE
DISPOSE CONSIDER ITSELF WITH
WITH HOW TO HANDLE AS- A CHILD
CASE AS OPPOSED TO AN ELDERLY
PERSON'S CASE PERHAPS SOMEONE
WHO HAS DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES I KNOW THAT I DID
LEGISLATION IN THE PAST THAT.
THAT REQUIRED A HIGHER LEVEL OF
ATTENTION FOR SOMEONE WHO HAS
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES I
THINK OF IT I THINK- THAT THE
TRIAL AND THE ELDERLY ADULT
WHO'S HAVING- COGNITIVE
CHALLENGES. THE PART OF THIS
THE DIFFERENT SIDES OF THING
GOING. I THOUGHT IT HAS TO BE A
HIGH PRIORITY RESPONSE TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND YES THEY WERE
THERE'S A PROTOCOL FOR THEM
PRETTY CERTAIN THAT. THEY WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THAT AND THAT
PROTOCOL IS INCLUDED IN THE
POST CREDITS IN THE CURRICULUM.
YES IT ALSO INCLUDED A BROKEN I
GAVE YOU- THAT JUST A ON THE
DVD REGARDING THE ORIENTATION
OPPOSE I GAVE YOU ONE HAVE TO
DO WITH ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES ALSO PUT ONE IN
THERE. ON THE CURRICULUM ITSELF
THAT WE HAVE IN A DE. TWENTY
SEVEN. THE CURRICULUM IS THERE.
ALSO PUT IN. THE CURRICULUM FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. AND
THE COURSE THAT THEY TEACH. THE
SO I THINK YOU FOR. ARE YOU.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
YOU'RE YOUR PRESENTATION WAS
EXTREMELY INFORMATIVE. REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR YOU TAKING YOUR
TIME AND ENERGY TO WALK THROUGH
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE MOST
WELCOME THANK YOU. OUR SECOND
WITNESS TODAY'S DEPUTY SHERIFF
ALYSSA CAROL WITH THE MAC
MARIPOSA COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. DEPUTY CAROL HAS
BEEN WITH THE MARIPOSA
DEPARTMENT FOR THREE YEARS AND
HAS A GREAT DEAL OF EXPERIENCE
WITH MISSING PERSONS CASES AND
WE HAVE HOPE TO GET A CLEAR
VIEW OF WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENS
FROM A LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSPECTIVE. WHEN AN OFFICER
ENCOUNTERS IN MISSING PERSONS
REQUEST AGAIN WITH THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE I'D LIKE TO HAVE
YOU ADDRESS A FEW THINGS FOR
STARTERS IN YOUR PRESENTATION.
NUMBER ONE TO THE BEST OF YOUR
ABILITY BASED ON YOUR TRAINING
AND EXPERIENCE IF YOU COULD
DESCRIBE THE NORMAL PROCESS FOR
A MISSING PERSONS CALL STARTING
WITH THE COMPLAINT OR THE OR
THE ADVISORY THAT COMES IN AND
THEN IN YOUR EXPERIENCE WHAT IS
THE NORMAL RESPONSE TIME TO
ANSWERING A MISSING PERSONS
CALL. AND THEN FINALLY HOW DOES%
RESPONDING OFFICER IN TERMS OF
SEEN ASSESSMENT INFORMATION
TAKEN AND DESCRIPTORS OF THE
MISSING VICTIM HANDLE AND
MISSING PERSONS COMPLAINT CALL
IF YOU COULD TAKE US THROUGH
THAT PROCESS. THANK YOU SENATOR
SO AGAIN NAMES ALYSSA CAROL
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR HAVING ME
HERE IT IS VERY MUCH A- A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY AND PRIVILEGE TO BE
HERE SO THANK YOU. AND THE WAY
THAT I'VE LAID OUT MY
PRESENTATION TO YOU DOES COVER
ALL OF THOSE POINTS- THE ONE
THAT I WILL MAKE SURE TO
ADDRESS IS THE NORMAL RESPONSE
TIME. AND BUT I'LL HAVE TO FIND
A GOOD SPOT TO STOP WITHIN MY-
PREPARED SPEECH TODAY TO
DISCUSS THAT THANK YOU OF
COURSE- SO I AM A DEPUTY
SHERIFF WITH AMERICA'S A COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE. MARIPOSA
COUNTY IS THE HOME OF YOSEMITE
NATIONAL PARK. I STARTED MY
CAREER BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN AS A COMMUNICATIONS
DISPATCHER I SPENT TWO YEARS
WITH THE MADERA COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE AS A
DISPATCHER. AND IN RETURN
MARIPOSA COUNTY WHERE I BECAME
A DEPUTY SHERIFF AFTER
COMPLETING THE POST BASIC
POLICE ACADEMY. I'M CURRENTLY
ASSIGNED TO THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND I'M ALSO
ONE OF THE DEPUTIES SEARCH AND
RESCUE COORDINATORS FOR MY
AGENCY. I'M GOING BACK TO THE
WAITING PERIOD QUESTION. WE
OFTEN HEAR THAT THERE IS A
TWENTY FOUR HOUR WAITING PERIOD
IN TV SHOWS ARE IT MIGHT BE IT
MIGHT BE URBAN LEGEND AS WELL
BUT THERE'S ACTUALLY- LAWS.
STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS THAT
PROHIBIT AGENCIES FROM HOLDING
SUCH A TIME PERIOD- TO BE
OBSERVED HELLO WE CANNOT REFUSE
A MISSING PERSON CASE BASED ON.
HOW LONG THEY'VE BEEN MISSING
THEY COULD BE MISSING.
TECHNICALLY I GUESS MINUTES AND
WE STILL HAVE TO DO SOME SORT
OF INVESTIGATION INTO THOSE
CASES- I ALSO WANT TO START OFF
BY HIGHLIGHTING PENAL CODE ONE
FOUR TWO ONE ONE PARENTHESES
HEY. STATES ALL LOCAL POLICE
AND SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS SHALL
ACCEPT ANY MISSING PERSON
REPORT. REGARDLESS OF
JURISDICTION SO THE REPORT MUST
BE TAKEN THEN FORWARDED TO THE
APPROPRIATE JURISDICTION. OF
WHERE THE MISSING PERSON
RESIDES OR THE PLACE WHERE THEY
WERE LAST SEEN. SO THIS MEANS-
MYSELF AS A AS A SHERIFF DEPUTY
SHERIFF IN MARIPOSA COUNTY. WE
COULD RECEIVE A CALL FROM
SOMEBODY LIVING DOWN SOUTH AND-
IN SAN DIEGO. A REPORTING
SOMEBODY MISSING OUT OF.
HUMBOLDT AND WE HAVE TO TAKE
THAT CASE AND FIGURE OUT WHERE.
THAT CASE NEEDS TO BE FORWARDED
TO SO WE- WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
TURN ANYBODY DOWN REGARDING A
MISSING PERSON. SO THERE ARE AN
INFINITE NUMBER ACTUALLY MEET
LET ME BACK UP THERE AS FAR AS
PRIORITIZING MISSING PERSON
CASES IN OUR CUES AND MY AGENTS
YOURS FIRST YOU ARE OUR CALL
THE RESPOND TO US CALLS FOR
SERVICE AND MISSING PERSON
CASES ARE PRIORITIZE OVERALL
PROPERTY CASES- MEANING WE
WOULD GO TO A MISSING PERSON
CASE OVER A BURGLARY OR THEFT
OF SOME SORT BUT- THAT BEING
SAID WE WOULDN'T NECESSARILY
PRIORITIZE A MISSING PERSON
CASE OVER A SITUATION WHERE
THERE IS A THREAT TO LIFE. IN
EARLY HAPPENING SO IF IT'S- IF
IT'S CURRENTLY HAPPENING OR
SOMEBODY'S LIFE OR WELL BEING
IS IN DANGER WE WOULD HAVE TO
RESPOND TO THAT BEFORE A
MISSING PERSON INVESTIGATION IF
THAT MAKES SENSE. SO THERE ARE
AN INFINITE NUMBER OF WAYS
UNDER WHICH SOMEONE CAN GO
MISSING BUT THERE ARE ONLY NINE
CATEGORIES UNDER WHICH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. CAN ENTER THOSE
CASES INTO THE MISSING AND THAT
UNIDENTIFIED PERSON SYSTEM
WHICH OLIVER TO AS MAPS OR THEM
UPS. THE FIRST WILL ADDRESSES
THE MOST COMMON TYPE OF MISSING
PERSON CASE THAT MY AGENCY SEES
WHICH IS RUN AWAY JUVENILES.
THIS IS DEFINED AS MISSING
JUVENILES REPORTED AS A RUN
AWAY. SO THE DISPATCHER
RECEIVES. OF THE CALL FOR
SERVICE ASSIGNED AS A DEPUTY TO
THAT CALL. THE DEPUTY CONTACT
THE REPORTING PARTY IN PERSON
OR BY PHONE DEPENDING ON THAT
PERSON'S LOCATION. THE DEPUTIES
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE TO OBTAIN
THE JUVENILES ALFA INFORMATION
AND BY THAT I MEAN THE NAME
DATE OF BIRTH PHYSICAL
DESCRIPTORS. DESCRIPTION THINGS
OF THAT SORT- WILL BROADCAST A
BILL WELL WHICH IS A BE ON THE
OOK OUT ON OUR RADIO. THE
PURPOSE OF THIS. IS TO LET HER
PARTNERS ON THE CHEF KNOW THAT
THE JUVENILE HAS RUN AWAY AND
NEEDS TO BE RETURNED TO THEIR
PARENT OR GUARDIAN. THIS ALSO
GIVES THAT INVESTIGATING DEPUTY
IT AT AN OPPORTUNITY TO SIT
WITH THAT REPORTING PARTY AND
GET FURTHER INFORMATION FOR THE
FURTHER DETAILED INFORMATION IN
REGARDS TO. MAYBE WHERE THAT
JUVENILES KNOWN TO HANG OUT OR-
MAYBE IT FIND OUT IF THEY ARE
HAVE VISUAL RUN AWAY WHICH WE
OFTEN SEE AS WELL. AND ALSO
PENAL CODE ONE FOUR TWO ONE ONE.
AND THE SEAS D. LIKE DAVID
REQUIRES THAT THE BILL WILL BE
BROADCAST SO THAT'S ALSO
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL.
SATURDAY AT WILL SUBMIT THE
MISSING PERSON REPORTING FORM
TO DISPATCH TO ENTER THAT INTO
MAPS. PENAL CODE ONE FOUR TWO
ONE ONE PARENTHESES HE REQUIRES
THE ENTRY OF THAT INTO MAPS BE
DONE WITHIN TWO HOURS REGARDING
A JUVENILE. AND AS FAR AS OUR
INVESTIGATION GOES WILL ATTEMPT
CONTACT WITH THE MISSING PERSON
WE SOMETIMES SEE THAT SOME
JUVENILES DON'T WANT TO BE
FOUND BY THEIR PARENT OR
GUARDIAN BUT THEY'RE SOMETIMES
WILLING TO TALK TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. OR AN OUTSIDE
PERSON AND THEY JUST MIGHT NEED
SOME TIME TO CALM DOWN AND
CONSIDER COMING BACK HOME SO
WILL ATTEMPT CONTACT PERSONALLY.
SO IN PREPARATION FOR THIS
HEARING. I CAST MYSELF WITH
FOLLOWING UP ON THE STILL
OUTSTANDING MISSING PERSONS
REPORTED TO MY AGENCY. I WAS
ABLE TO LOCATE AND CLEAR ALMOST
TEN RUN AWAY JUVENILES FROM OUR
OUR CASE OR CASES. THAT FOLLOW
A PROCESS STARTED WITH THE
GROUP HOMES WHERE THE RUNAWAYS
HAD BEEN LIVING THE
ADMINISTRATORS PROVIDED ME WITH
CONTACT INFORMATION FOR THE
JUVENILES. SOCIAL WORKERS AND
OR OR PROBATION OFFICERS. THE
SOCIAL WORKERS WERE THEN ABLE
TO TELL ME ABOUT THE CURRENT
LOCATIONS OF THE JUVENILES.
THEN WE HAD THOSE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES MAKE
PERSONAL CONTACT WITH THE
JUVENILES AND WE WERE ABLE TO
CLEAR THEM OUT OF THE SYSTEM.
WHEN IT CAME TO THE JUVENILES
WHO WERE ON PROBATION
UNFORTUNATELY MOST OF THEM WERE
IN CUSTODY IN JUVENILE HALL.
AND THEY'D BEEN ARRESTED AFTER
MY AGENCY ENTER THEM INTO THE
MAPS. UPON SPEAKING TO JUVENILE
HALL STAFF AND THIS IS ACROSS
FOR DIFFERENT COUNTIES IN THIS
STATE. THEY WERE UNAWARE THAT
THE JUVENILES WERE. WERE IN THE
MAPS AND THEY EITHER DID NOT
KNOW HOW OR THEY DID NOT HAVE
THE ACCESS TO CLEAR THE MISSING
PERSON ENTRY. I REACHED OUT TO
SURROUNDING COUNTIES JUVENILE
HALLS- CLOSE TO MY AREA TO
INQUIRE ABOUT THEIR PROTOCOL OF
BOOKING A MINOR. MOST OF THESE
AGENCIES DID NOT READ THE
MINOR'S INFORMATION THROUGH
CLASS. WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
LAW ENFORCEMENT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM- THEY
ONLY FINGERPRINT THEM TO
CONFIRM IN DOCUMENT WHO THEY
HAVE IN THEIR CUSTODY. PROTOCOL
FOR BOOKING AN ADULT- JUST TO
GET A BETTER IDEA OF THIS. IS
IT INCLUDES FINGERPRINTING AND
RUNNING THEIR INFORMATION
THROUGH CLASS SO THEY DO BOTH.
PROTOCOLS THEIR- AND RUNNING
THEIR INFORMATION DO CLASS
WOULD YIELD MISSING PERSON
INFORMATION AND WANTED PERSON
INFORMATION. MY FINDING IS THAT
THE JUVENILE HALL BOOKING
PROCESS SHOULD NOT DIFFER FROM
THIS BECAUSE- HOW TO RUN AWAYS
BEEN CHECKED IN CLASS THEY
WOULD'VE BEEN CLEARED FROM THE
SYSTEM MONTHS EARLIER. AND WE
COULD HAVE. ENSURE THAT THAT
THOSE JUVENILES WERE SAFE. AND
I APOLOGIZE FIVE GOING. GOING
FASTER SLOWER. HE'S ME. AB SO
AGAIN I'M JUST GOING TO TRY TO
GO THROUGH THE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES UNDER WHICH LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN ENTER MISSING
PEOPLE INTO THE SYSTEM THE NEXT
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT IS
DEPENDENT ADULTS THEY'RE
CONSIDERED ANY MISSING ADULT TO
HAS PHYSICAL OR MENTAL
LIMITATIONS WHICH RESTRICT
THEIR ABILITY TO CARRY OUT
NORMAL ACTIVITIES AGAIN THE
DISPATCHER WILL SIGN THE DEPUTY
FOR. A SIGN A DEPUTY TO A CALL
FOR SERVICE FOR MISSING
DEPENDENT ADULT THE MOST COMMON
TYPES OF CASES THAT WE SEE IN
THIS REGARD OUR ELDERLY WALK
AWAY AS WITH ALZHEIMERS OR
DEMENTIA. THIS IS DON. SKINNY
THIS IS AN AUTOMATIC SEARCH AND
RESCUE CALL OUT FROM AGENCY. AS
SARS ASSEMBLING THE
INVESTIGATING DEPUTY WILL
CONTACT THE REPORTING PARTY.
FOLLOW PROTOCOL AS EXPLAINED
BEFORE REGARDING THE MISSING
PERSONS ALFA INFORMATION AND
TRAIN TO CLIENTS. WILL QUICKLY
CHECK THE PROPERTY AND
SURROUNDING AREA WHERE THE
PERSON WAS LAST SEEN IT IS NOT
A TYPICAL FOR A DEPUTY TO
LOCATE THE MISSING PERSON
BEFORE SORRY EVEN ARRIVED ON
SCENE. ONE OF OUR RECENT
SEARCHES OF THIS TYPE WAS FR A
SEVENTY FOUR YEAR OLD MALE WITH
EARLY STAGES OF DEMENTIA HE
WENT ON HIS DAILY WALK ON HIS
THIRTY FIVE ACRE PROPERTY AND
DID NOT RETURN ON THIS
PARTICULAR WEDNESDAY. THIS
IMMEDIATELY TURNED INTO A
SEARCH AND RESCUE MISSION WHEN
THE FAMILY REPORTED HIM MISSING.
THROUGHOUT THREE DAYS OF
SEARCHING SIXTEEN DIFFERENT
AGENCIES RESPONDED AS MUTUAL
AID TO ASSIST IN THE SEARCH
VARYING FROM GROUND SEARCHING
TO FLYING OVERHEAD WITH DRONES
AND HELICOPTERS. TO UTILIZING
SEARCH DOGS. WE HAD ANYWHERE
FROM FIVE TO SEVENTY FIVE
SEARCHERS AT ONE TIME AND ARE
SEARCHES CONTINUE THROUGHOUT
THE NIGHT. THIS MAN WAS FOUND
ALIVE ON SATURDAY AND AS THE
CROW FLIES. HE WAS ABOUT TWO
MILES FROM HIS RESIDENCE. I AM.
I AM PROUD TO REPORT THAT MOST
OF THESE CASES ARE RESOLVED
WITHIN A SHORT TIME FRAME
BECAUSE OF THE DEDICATION OF
OUR SEARCH AND RESCUE MEMBERS.
BUT THERE ARE VERY UNFORTUNATE
INSTANCES WHERE THE MISSING
PERSON SIMPLY CANNOT BE
LOCATED. THEY REMAIN IN THE
MAPS EVEN IF THEY ARE PRESUMED
TO BE DECEASED. THE NEXT
CATEGORY IS. IT CATASTROPHE
VICTIMS CITIES ARE MISSING
PERSONS THAT ARE VICTIMS OF A
DISASTER SUCH AS A BOATING
ACCIDENT PLANE CRASH EARTHQUAKE
FLOOD OR FIRE THE ASSIGNED
DEPUTY WILL RESPOND AND OBTAIN
THE SAME INFORMATION THE SAME
INITIAL INFORMATION AS BEFORE
THESE CASES ARE UNIQUE IN THAT
WE KNOW THE VICTIMS WERE
INVOLVED WITH SOME SORT OF
DISASTER WE JUST DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM
OR WHERE THEY PHYSICALLY ARE.
I'M A GIVE YOU A COUPLE EXACT A
COUPLE OF EXAMPLES OF THE
SITUATION IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN BETWEEN MARCH TWENTY
FIRST AND MARCH TWENTY THIRD.
MARIPOSA COUNTY AND ALONG WITH
MOST OF THE STATE DEALT WITH
THE STORM AND SEVERE FLOODING
THAT FORCED MANY ROAD CLOSURES.
AND SEVERELY DAMAGED
INFRASTRUCTURE THE RESPONSE
ULTIMATELY RESULTED IN A
PROCLAMATION OF A STATE OF
EMERGENCY THE MOST INTENSE DAY
OF THIS STORM WAS ON MARCH
TWENTY SECOND. ON A TWO THIRDS
ON MARCH TWENTY THIRD AMERICA'S
A COUNTY RECEIVED A BILL WELL
THE BE ON THE LOOK OUT. FROM A
NEIGHBORING COUNTY FOR JOHN ON
ESTO WHO WORKED AS A SUBSTITUTE
TEACHER AT AMERICA'S A COUNTY
SCHOOL. THIS IS WHERE HE WAS
LAST SEEN ON MARCH TWENTY
SECOND. WITH THE INFORMATION
THAT JOHN LIVED IN THE
NEIGHBORING COUNTY AND WAS
LIKELY TO USE HIGHWAY ONE
THIRTY TWO TO GET HOME DEPUTIES
CONCLUDED HE WAS POSSIBLY SWEPT
AWAY IN THE FLOOD. THAT TOOK
OUT APPROXIMATELY FIFTY FEET OF
HIGHWAY ONE THIRTY TO
COMPLETELY SHUT DOWN OUR
HIGHWAY. DEPUTIES BEGAN A IS A
FOOT SIR THE DRAINAGE AND LOCAL
LOCATED A SEVERELY DAMAGED
VEHICLE APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT
THREE MILES DOWNSTREAM. FROM
THE WASH OUT ALONG WITH SEVERAL
CAR PARKED. THE VAN MATCHED
JOHNS TOYOTA AVALON WHICH SHE
WAS DRIVING AT THE TIME. DOUBLE
A AND MULTIPLE AGENCIES ARE
OPERATION WAS CONDUCTED.
INCLUDING FOOT SEARCHERS BOAT
SEARCHERS. DOG TEAMS AND DRAWN
OPERATORS. TO DATE ME EITHER
JOHN OR ANY OF HIS REMAINS HAD
BEEN LOCATED BUT THE SEARCH
CONTINUES. ALSO ON MARCH TWENTY
SECOND TWENTY EIGHTEEN CAROL
BROWN WAS REPORTED MISSING BY
HER HUSBAND. CAROL HAD GONE
OUTSIDE TO CHECK ON THE HORSES
DURING THE STORM HER HUSBAND
LOCATED THE UTILITY VEHICLE
WHICH SHE HAD BEEN DRIVING
OVERTURNED IN THE FLOODED CREEK
SEARCH AND RESCUE RESPONDED. TO
SEARCH FOR CAROL THIS INCIDENT
ALSO TURNED INTO A MULTI DAY
SEARCH. CAROL PARTIAL REMAINS
WERE LOCATED BY A CADAVER DOG
IN JUNE TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AS WE
RESEARCH THE CREEK AND DEBRIS
PILES IT WAS CONFIRMED THROUGH
DNA TESTING THAT THERE REMAINS
WORK CAROL BRAUN THE I'M NOT
DIVISION AT DOJ WE ARE TO KEEP
HER CASE IN THE MAPS AND TELL
ALL OF HER REMAINS ARE LOCATED.
THE NEXT IS WEB. TITLED AS A
VOLUNTARY MISSING ADULT WHICH
IS TWENTY ONE EIGHT AGE TWENTY
ONE AND OVER. WHICH IS A
MISSING ADULT WHO IS LEFT ON
HIS OR HER OWN FREE WILL THE
DISPATCHER WILL ASSIGN A DEPUTY
THEY'LL AN AS BEFORE WE GATHER
THE VICTIMS INFORMATION ENTER
THEM INTO MAPS AND ATTEMPT
CONTACT. DURING OUR
INVESTIGATION WE TYPICALLY WILL
RUN THE LICENSE PLATE TO SEE IF
THEIR VEHICLE WAS TOWED WHICH
COULD DIRECT US TO THE AGENCY
THAT TELL THEM AND FOLLOW UP
WITH THEM TO SEE IF THEY HAD
ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT CONTACT.
AND WE ALSO CONTEXT ROUNDING
AGENCIES SUCH AS CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL TO INQUIRE ABOUT
TRAFFIC ACCIDENTS. WE SHARE
INFORMATION OF THIS QUE OF OUR
CASES WITH OUR PARTNERS ON
SHIPS SO THEY CAN ALSO BE WELL
AND CROSS REFERENCE ANY
ASSOCIATES THAT MAYBE. MYSELF I
MYSELF OVERLOOKED. AND THE CASE
REMAINS OPEN UNTIL THE SUBJECT
IS CONTACTED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE NEXT IS THE STRANGER
ABDUCTION. WHICH IS A MISSING
PERSON TAKEN BY A STRANGER THIS
INCLUDES CASES OF UNKNOWN OF
DOCTOR WHO IS NOT A FAMILY A
FAMILY MEMBER. AN EXAMPLE FROM
POST IS A TEN YEAR OLD GIRL WAS
REPORTED MISSING WHEN SHE FAILS
TO COME HOME FROM SCHOOL AND A
NEIGHBOR REPORTS SEEING HER
BEING PHYSICALLY FORCED INTO A
VAN BY AN UNKNOWN MAN. THE
DEPUTY HAS THE SAME
RESPONSIBILITY REGARDS TO
GATHERING INFORMATION BUT THIS
SITUATION WITH THE TO AN AMBER
ALERT. AMBER ALERT HAS VERY
SPECIFIC. THE FIRST IS THE
ELDEST AND ADOPTED OR AKEN BY
ANYONE INCLUDED BUT NOT LIMITED
TO A CUSTODIAL PARENT OR
GUARDIAN. THE VICTIM IS
SEVENTEEN YEARS OF AGE OR
YOUNGER OR HAS PROVEN HAS A
PROVEN MENTAL OR PHYSICAL
DISABILITY. THE VICTIM IS IN
IMMINENT DANGER OF SERIOUS
INJURY OR DEATH AND THERE IS
INFORMATION AVAILABLE THAT IF
SHARED WITH THE PUBLIC. COULD
ASSIST IN THE CHILD SAFE
RECOVERY THIS IS A CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL FUNCTION THE H.
B. HANDLES THE MESSAGING IN
COORDINATION WITH A P. B. NET.
YES AND THE WE ARE. BLUE ALERTS
AND SILVER ALERTS WOULD ALSO
FALL INTO THIS CATEGORY AS FAR
AS THE MISSING PERSON ENTRY
GOES AND AS SUCH AS BLUE ALERTS
AND SILVER ALERTS AND THEY'RE
ALSO INITIATED THROUGH C. H. P.
THE REST THE NIGHT. THAT I WANT
TO ADDRESS I DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE PERSONAL EXAMPLES OUT
THERE JUST. EXAMPLES THAT I'VE
RECEIVED FROM POST FROM THEIR
GUIDELINES IN HANDLING MISSING
PERSON CASES. THE NEXUS
PARENTAL OR FAMILY ABDUCTION.
AN EXAMPLE WOULD BE A SEVEN
YEAR OLD CHILD HIS REPORTED
MISSING BY THE CHILD'S MOTHER.
WHO IS THE CUSTODIAL PARENT
AFTER THE BOYS PICKED UP FROM
SCHOOL BY THE BOY'S FATHER AND
TAKEN TO AN UNDISCLOSED
LOCATION. NEXT IS UNKNOWN
CIRCUMSTANCES. A MANAGER PORTED
MISSING AFTER HE FAILED TO
RETURN HOME. IN A REASONABLE
AMOUNT OF TIME AFTER TAKING THE
FAMILY DOG OUT FOR A WALK.
SUSPICIOUS CIRCUMSTANCES
EXAMPLE IS A WOMAN WHO IS EIGHT
MONTHS PREGNANT AND LIVES WITH
HER PARENTS AS REPORTED MISSING
WHEN SHE DOES NOT RETURN HOME
FROM A SHOPPING TRIP AND IS
LAST SEEN GETTING INTO A
VEHICLE. AND LEAVING THE
PARKING LOT WITH TWO MEN. THE
LAST CATEGORY IS LOST WHICH IS
A CHILD OR ADULT WHO IS
REPORTED TO HAVE STRAIGHT AWAY
AND HIS WHEREABOUTS ARE UNKNOWN.
CHEN C. WITH. THEY WERE IN
REGARD OCCURS OR LOST HUNTERS
WE SEE SOMEONE OFTEN OUR
BACKYARDS ARE WOODED AREAS. IN
ANY CASE IS THE PRACTICE
AMERICA'S A COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE TO HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
MAKE PERSONAL CONTACT WITH THE
MISSING PERSON BEFORE YOU WE
REMOVE THEM FROM THE MAPS AND
CLOSE THE CASE ONE RECENT
EXCEPTION TO THIS WAS A CASE
INVOLVING A WOMAN WHO WAS
REPORTED MISSING OF TO HAWAII.
IS ARREST AND HOW THE N. NCIC
ADVISE THE BOOKING INFORMATION
WOULD SUFFICE TO- SHOW THAT SHE
WAS NO LONGER MISSING FROM OUR
PANEL REPORT APPERTAINING THE
BOOKING INFORMATION FOR THE
CASE FILE WAS ABLE TO CLEAR
THAT. THIS PERSON THE MAPS AS
FAR AS AN UNIDENTIFIED REMAINS
GO OUR MOST RECENT MAPS ENTRIES
OF THOSE TYPES ORIGINATED IN
YOSEMITE NATIONAL PARK PARK
RANGER PARK RANGERS HANDLE
THEIR OWN INVESTIGATIONS WE ARE
JUST THE CORNERS THEY LOCATE
SUCH PAINS IN REGARDS TO RECORD.
AND I. UNLIKE PROMISED I DID
NOT FIND A DECENT SPOT FOR ME
TO TALK ABOUT MY TIME RESPONSE.
I WOULDN'T SAY THAT THERE'S A
NORMAL TIME RESPONSE IN IN
EVERY SINGLE CASE. PENAL CODE
ONE FOUR TWO ONE ONE DOES
DESIGNATE THAT WE HAVE TO
SUBMIT THE ENTRIES INTO MAPS
WITH AND- FOR TWO HOURS FOR
JUVENILES OR FOUR HOURS
OTHERWISE. BUT AS FAR AS
GETTING TO THE ORIGINAL PARTY
THERE'S NO TIME FRAME FROM WHEN
I READ THE CALL TO ONE EIGHT
CONTACT THEM IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR OKAY.
BECAUSE IT IT JUST QUESTIONABLE
IF WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
DIFFERENT- HIGH PRIORITY CALL
WE HAVE TO FINISH THAT AND SEE
IF WE CAN OPEN SOMEBODY ELSE UP
TO RESPOND THERE'S JUST A LOT
OF THINGS IN PLAY WHEN IT WHEN
IT COMES DOWN TO. GETTING THAT
HAPPY TO PHYSICALLY GO TALK TO
THE REPORTING PARTY OR GIVE
THEM A CALL. CERTAINLY IT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE DEPENDING ON
WHAT OTHER PRIORITIES ARE ON
YOUR DESK AND WHETHER YOU'RE-
HANDLING ANOTHER MISSING PERSON
CASE AT THE SAME TIME WHATEVER
IT MIGHT BE BUT- I THINK YOU
MADE THE POINT CLEAR TO US
THAT. THAT YOU DO RECOGNIZE AND
UNDERSTAND THAT MISSING PERSON
CASES. SHOULD BE HANDLED THE
HEAD OF PROPERTY CASES AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE WERE
LOOKING FOR. WE ALL UNDERSTAND
THAT. IT'S A MATTER OF
RESOURCES AND WHAT'S HAPPENING
AT THE SAME TIME BUT- I THINK
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT. THIS IS A
MISSING PERSON CASE IS HANDLED
AHEAD OF. OF SOME OF THE OTHER
CASES THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE
ABSOLUTELY AND OUR DISPATCHERS
PRIORITIZE AT THE SAME WAY AS
WELL ANOTHER QUESTION I HAD- I
UNDERSTAND THAT NCIC IS. IS THE
NATIONAL DATABASE FOR
COLLECTION OF MISSING PERSON
RECORDS. WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENTERING SOMEBODY INTO AND SEE
I SEE IS THAT. IS THAT
SOMETHING WHERE YOU YOU'VE
ENTERED INTO THE CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM AND IT AUTOMATICALLY
UPLOADS OR DO YOU HAVE TO
UPLOAD. YOU HAVE TO ENTER INTO
AND SEE I SEE SEPARATELY HOW
DOES THAT WORK IT IS.
AUTOMATICALLY UPDATED SO WE
MAKE THE ENTRY INTO THE
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT.
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM INTO
THE MISSING AN UNIDENTIFIED
PERSON SYSTEM. AND IT
AUTOMATICALLY GETS UP LOADED.
TO NCIC. AND JUST FOR
UNDERSTANDING AND SEE I SEE IS
THE NATIONAL SYSTEM SO I'M NOT
SURE WHAT OTHER STATES USE AS
FAR AS THEIR THEIR STATE
SYSTEMS BUT ALL OF THOSE SHOULD
BE TALKING TO NCIC WHICH IS WHY
WHEN I RUN SOMEBODY'S
INFORMATION IN CLASS I CAN SEE
IF THEY'RE MISSING OUT OF TEXAS
OR IF THEY'RE WANTED OUT OF
TEXAS FOR EXAMPLE. ANY WHAT
CASE WULD YOU ENTER SOMEBODY
INTO THE FEDERAL SYSTEM BY CAP
THE VIOLENT INFORMATION. I'M
EVEN DRAWING A BLANK ON EXACTLY
WHAT THAT STANDS FOR. THE
VIOLENT CRIME AND APPREHENSION
PROGRAM I PERSONALLY DON'T HAVE
ANY EXPERIENCE WITH BY CAP AND
ESPECIALLY IN REGARDS TO
MISSING PERSONS SO IF THAT'S
THE- SHORTCOMING THAT WE HAVE
ADDRESSED- YOU'VE ADDRESS THEN
THAT. YOUR ANSWER I DON'T HAVE
ANY- EXPERIENCE WITHOUT THAT'S
OKAY SOMEBODY ELSE MIGHT B
ABLE TO ANSWER THAT. THANK YOU-
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS. MAP PLEASE. I'M A
LITTLE CURIOUS ABOUT DOUBT ONE
OF THE NINE CATEGORIES THAT YOU
X. OF THAT A FEW EXPLAINED OR
SHARED WITH US RATHER- YOU
TALKED ABOUT TWENTY ONE AND
OLDER LEFTON THEIR OWN. WHY
WOULD THEY BE REPORTED MISSING
IF THEY'RE AN ADULT LIKE CAN
YOU SURE THE CIRCUMSTANCES AT
THAT POINT I FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
ADULTS THE WALKED AWAY. WHY
WOULD YOU FIND THAT AS A-
PERSON. WHY WOULD I. ENTER IT
IS MISSING BUT WHY WOULD
SOMEONE REPORTS SOMEONE THAT'S-
AN ADULT WHO JUST LAUGHED I
THINK YOU JUST SAID THEY HAVE
TO BE TWENTY ONE AND OLDER. WHO
LEFT ON THEIR OWN. SO I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND- THE
CATEGORIES TO FILE A MISSING
PERSON. BEING BEING IN THE
FIELD AM I TRULY FEEL THAT THE
VOLUNTARY I'M NOT SURE WHY IT'S
CALLED ON TERRY MISSING THAT'S
JUST WHAT'S BEEN DESIGNATED
FROM DOJ AS A CATEGORY FOR US
TO AND PUT SOMEBODY. AND I FEEL
LIKE THIS IS- MORE OF A CATCH
ALL IF THROUGH OUR
INVESTIGATION IT'S- DETERMINED
THAT THAT PERSON MISSING.
DOESN'T FALL UNDER THE OTHER
CATEGORIES THAT WE KNOW THAT
THEY'RE MISSING WE DON'T
NECESSARILY FEEL THAT THEY ARE
A- CASH REBATES. OR THAT
THEY'RE LOST IN THE WOODS
SOMEWHERE BUT THEY ARE MISSING.
DO SOME SORT OF INVESTIGATION
AND THE P. REQUIRES HAVE TO
ENTER THEM INTO WE JUST NEED TO
CUT THEM IN THE SYSTEM- BUT
GOING BACK TO THE WOMAN WHO IS
FOUND. IN HAWAII. HER MOTHER
WAS THE THAT REPORTED HER.
MATTER OF FACT THAT THAT PERSON
DOESN'T WANT TO BE FOUND BY
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS SO THAT
THAT'S ANOTHER ASPECT YOU HAVE
TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. SENATOR CAVEA THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY HE WAS
REALLY WELL ORGANIZED AND
UNDERSTANDABLE I APPRECIATED
VERY MUCH IN TERMS OF THE-
PROCESSING THE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES IN THEM UP SYSTEM.
AND MANY OF THE JURISDICTIONS
HAVE COMPUTERS IN THEIR IN
THEIR VEHICLES IS- IS IT
POSSIBLE TO DO THE INPUT INTO
THE SYSTEMS FROM THE VEHICLE OR
IS THIS THE KIND OF THING THAT
YOU'D NEED TO GO BACK TO YOUR-
YOUR- STATION IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO. INPUT WITH AMERICA'S
ACCOUNT I CAN ONLY SPEAK TO
WEAR FOR THE COUNTY AND MADERA
COUNTY- SO BEING A DISPATCHER
FOR BOTH AGENCIES. THAT'S HOW
WE HANDLE THEM. THE INPUTS INTO
MAPS ARE THAT THEY GO THROUGH
DISPATCH AND THAT THAT MIGHT
JUST BE FOR RECORD KEEPING.
SIDE OF IT- BUT EVEN THOUGH
SOME AGENCIES YOU HAVE ACCESS
AND THEIR VEHICLES. THOSE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS MIGHT NOT
HAVE THE TRAINING TO ACTUALLY
AND PUT THEM INTO CLASS BECAUSE
THERE'S DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
CLASS TRAINING THAT WE HAVE TO
GO THROUGH TO GET DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF ACCESS TO CLASS SO I
IS A DEPUTY IN THE FIELD ONLY
HAVE ACCESS TO INQUIRE INTO
CLASS AS OPPOSED TO MY
DISPATCHERS WHO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO AND PUT OKAY SO YOU
ACTUALLY GO THROUGH YOUR
DISPATCHERS IN ORDER TO FILE
THOSE REPORTS RIGHT IN I'M- AND
BUT- YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
APPRECIATE IT THANK. YOU I
ASSUME THAT THERE'D BE SOME-
INTERNET. ET COMPLICATIONS-
BECAUSE I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH
THAT NOT HAVING INTERNET RURAL
CALIFORNIA- EVERYWHERE YOU GO
BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE. IT
PROBABLY MAKES A LOT OF SENSE-TO GO TO THE DISPATCHERS
BECAUSE THEY'RE LOCATED. AND
MAKE THEIR THEIR JOB IS TO
HANDLE KIND OF THE DATA RIGHT
AND SO I APPRECIATE THAT THANK
YOUR AT TO OF COURSE. AND IN MY
DISTRICT IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE AND WE HAD THE RECOVERY
OF THREE WOMEN FROM A WELL IN A
BABY AND THEN TWO OTHER WOMEN
FROM CALAVERAS COUNTY- MOST OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS HAD GONE
MISSING IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
NINETEEN NINE. NINE EIGHTY FIVE
AND ONE MORE NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT. CELL ACTUALLY ALL OF
THOSE CASES THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WENT MISSING BEFORE THE STATE
HAD A DATABASE. AN INTACT
BECAUSE THE STATE STATUTE
DIDN'T GO INTO A FACT INTEL TWO
THOUSAND THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND
SO. WE HAD FAMILY MEMBERS
COMING FORWARD- CALLING THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE CALLING LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT WANTING TO
PROVIDE DNA. CAN YOU DESCRIBE
FOR US. AT WHAT POINT IN HOW
YOU DETERMINE. WHEN A FAMILY
MEMBER SHOULD BE PROVIDING DNA
FOR A MISSING PERSON BECAUSE
YOU'VE YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT
JUVENILES HAVE GONE MISSING
THAT YOU'VE YOU FIND THEM FORTY
EIGHT HOURS LATER. I AN
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE REMAINS ARE
FOUND SO WHAT A HOW DO YOU
PRIORITIZE AND- AND GO BACK TO
THOSE FAMILY MEMBERS AND ENSURE
THAT THEIR DNA IS COLLECTED IN
ADDED INTO THE- A FEDERAL
REPOSITORY OF DNA. SO PENAL
CODE I GOT THIS. BET IT'S
CALLED REPORTING REFERENCE
CHART DIRECTLY FROM DOJ WHICH
WAS VERY INFORMATIONAL AND IT
LAYS OUT THE DIFFERENT AGES OF
A MISSING PERSON AND SOME
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT BASES IN REGARDS TO
HANDLING THE CASE THERE ONE
THAT SPEAKS TO DNA AND- THE
NECESSITY TO ADVISE FAMILY THE
RIGHT TO SUBMIT SUCH A SAMPLE
AND MUST BE DONE WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS AND THAT'S PER PENAL CODE
ONE FOUR TWO FIVE ZERO
PARENTHESES FEE PRACTICES TO.
SELL IT ACTUALLY IN PENAL CODE
THAT WE HAVE TO GIVE THEM THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE A SAMPLE
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS. BUT IT IT
JUST DEPENDS ON THE SITUATION I
WOULD NECESSARILY A WRIST BE
THE RESPONDING OFFICER AND TAKE
THE INFORMATION OF A LOVED ONE
GOING MISSING AND SAY OKAY WELL
ARE YOU READY TO PROVIDE A DNA
SAMPLE BEFORE WE EVEN TRY
MASTICATING M. THAT'S WHY I
THINK THAT THE TIME FRAME IS
IMPORTANT TO STICK TO ABOUT
THIRTY DAYS BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
TRY SOME OTHER OPPORTUNE TAKES
UP OTHER OPPORTUNITIES TO DO.
AN INVESTIGATION OTHERWISE.
WOULD YOU WOULD IT BE YOUR
BELIEF THAT IF SOMEONE TO ROUTE
WERE TO REPORTED MISSING FAMILY
MEMBER TODAY. THAT AND IF THEY
WERE NOT FOUND WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS THAT THAT FAMILY MEMBER
WOULD HAVE A REASONABLE. RIGHT
TO ASSUME THAT. THE DNA THEY
PROVIDED WOULD EXIST AT THE
STATE LEVEL. AND AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. OR IS IT THAT THERE'S
NOT QUITE CERTAINTY ABOUT
WHETHER THERE THE DNA WOULD BE
IN A FEDERAL RESERVE POSITIVE
WORRY MY UNDERSTANDING SO WHEN
WE GO. WHEN WE OBTAIN A DNA
SAMPLE FROM A LOVED ONE OR FROM
A FAMILY MEMBER. IT GOES INTO
THE- LOTUS WHICH IS COMBINED
DNA INDEX SYSTEM. AND KODY'S
SPEAKS TO NCIC AND MOPS SO. IF
YOU REMEMBER IN MY
PRESENTATION- REGARDING CAROL
BRAUN WE HAVE TO KEEP HER ENTRY
AND MOPS UNTIL ALL OF HER
REMAINS ARE FOUND AND THAT'S
PER DOJ THAT'S A GOOD POINTING
SYSTEM TO SHOW ANY ADDITIONAL
REMAINS. WE CAN POINT TO THAT
CODE IS CENTURY AND WHAT IT IS
THE SAME REMAINS SO. CODICE
DOES SPEAK TO BOTH OF THEM.
EVEN THOUGH THEY COME FROM THE
NATIONAL LEVEL AND STATE LEVEL.
IF THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION I
THINK SO I THINK SO I KNOW
THAT- IN THE CASE OF SANDY
VANDER HIDING WHO WENT MISSING
FROM MY DISTRICT IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT AND SHE WAS ONE OF
THE MISSING WOMEN WHO WERE
RECOVERED IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE FROM CALAVERAS. THERE IS
A PARTIAL. OF CANDY- IN OR
AROUND FEBRUARY ELEVENTH
TWELFTH AND THEN. A LATER THAT
MONTH THERE WAS A SECOND
RECOVERY EFFORT WHERE.
ADDITIONAL REMAINS WERE
RECOVERED- FOR SANDY SO I
UNDERSTAND AND RECOGNIZE THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF ENSURING
THAT EVEN THOUGH SOME PARTIAL
REMAINS MIGHT BE RECOVERED FOR
AN INDIVIDUAL THAT THAT
INDIVIDUALS DNA REMAINS IN THE
STATE AND FEDERAL SYSTEM RAY
AND I DON'T KNOW NECESSARILY
WHERE WHERE IT'S HOUSED-
CURTIS'S INFORMATION. BUT WE
SEND IT OFF TO THEM AND THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO STORE IT
INDEFINITELY THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THANK YOU. TO
HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. NOW OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AND NEXT WE ARE GOING TO
GO OUT OF ORDER JUST A BIT- IN
ORDER TO ACCOMMODATE TRAVEL
PLANS ON WITH THIS NEXT WE HAVE
MAKING ACTUAL MEN WHO IS THE
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR THE MISSING
AN UNIDENTIFIED PERSON SECTION
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE MISSING AN UNIDENTIFIED
PERSONS UNIT WHICH IS ALSO
REFERRED TO AS MOPS AND TO
PREACH THE CORE AERATION.
ASSISTANT OVERSIGHT PROVIDED BY
UPS TO CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND ALSO WITH HER
IS THE IS LINDA ASH WAY WHO IS
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR FOR THE
VIOLENT CRIME INFORMATION
CENTER BRANCH FOR CALIFORNIA
DOJ MONTHS- WE ARE LOOKING TO
HAVE YOU PROVIDE AN-
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
PROCESS THAT CALIFORNIA LAW
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND
MUD ATTEMPTS TO IDENTIFY AND
IDENTIFIED RECOVERED REMAINS IN
ADDITION TO DESCRIBING THE
DATABASE THAT IS USED FOR
TRACKING MISSING PERSONS AND
HOW THE MISSING PERSONS
DATABASE UGH COMMUNICATES WITH
AND COORDINATES WITH THE
UNIDENTIFIED REMAINS DATABASE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR GALGIANI
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LINDA SWAG AN ASSISTANT BUREAU
DIRECTOR WITHIN THE JUSTICE
DATA AND INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES
BUREAU WITH OVERSIGHT OVER THE
VIOLENT CRIME INFORMATION
CENTER BRANCH I AM PLEASED TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY ON
BEHALF OF ATTORNEY GENERAL BUT
SERRA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH BACKGROUND ON
CRITICAL WORK TO LOCATE.
MISSING PERSONS AND IDENTIFY
UNKNOWN LAW AND DECEASED
PERSONS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY AND FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS IMPORTANT SUCH. VIOLENT
CRIME INFORMATION CENTER ALSO
KNOWN AS IF HE'S I SEE AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WAS ESTABLISHED IN
1988% IN A CUT SECTION FOURTEEN
TWO HUNDRED. YOU SEE I SEE IS
MANDATED SILICON FORSMAN
AGENCIES WITH VIOLENT CRIME
INVESTIGATIONS INCLUDING THE
IDENTITY. AT APPREHENSION
PERSONS. FOR THE DISAPPEARANCE
AND EXPLOITATION OF PERSONS
EXPRESSLY CHILDREN AND AT RISK
ADULTS THE SERVICES INCLUDE OUR
BUT ARE NOT LIMITED TO THE FOR.
APPROACH I'LL AS LOW LONG FOR
AGENCIES AND DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S. AS THE GET IT AND
ASIAN. THIS WAS. PACIFIC MY
NAME IS DESCRIPTION FROM AND
PHOTO OF MISSING PERSONS TO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES NONPROFIT
AGENCIES SCHOOLS AND PROVIDING
STATISTICS ON MISSING PERSONS
HANNAH AT RISK ADULTS INCLUDING
AS MAY BE APPLICABLE FAMILY
ABDUCTIONS NON FAMILY
ATTRACTIONS VOLUNTARY MISSING
AND LOST CHILDREN ARE LOST AT
ALL THAT RISK. THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS ALSO A- REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE TRAINING ON THE
SERVICES PROVIDED BY THE CENTER
THE LINE PERSONALES SUPERVISORS
INVEST IN THE FOLLOWING FIELDS
LAW ENFORCEMENT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS COURT
MEDIATION SERVICES AND KERRY.
THE CI SI IS COMPRISED OF THE
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES PROGRAMS
AND THE SOME SUPPORT AS WELL
CALIFORNIA SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY PURSUANT TO PENAL CODE
SECTION TWO NINETY AT ALL THE
I. S. P. AND AS THIS P. IT.
CAPTION TEAM. THROUGH FIFTY.
SPECIFICALLY YEAH I IS
COMPRISED OF THE MISSING AND
IDENTIFY PERSONS UNIT THE
VIOLENT CRIME INVESTIGATIVE
SUPPORT UNIT AND THE CALIFORNIA
SEX AND ARSON REGISTRY SECTION.
THE CALIFORNIA SEX AND OURS
REGISTRY PROGRAM IS COMPRISED
OF THE CALIFORNIA SEX AN ARSON
REGISTRY AND THE TERRACE
SUSSMAN SECTIONS. THE CIC IS
STAFFED WITH SEVENTY TWO
PERMANENT PERSONNEL AND SIXTY
FIVE LEARN LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS COMPRISED PRIMARILY
OF CRIME ANALYST AND PROGRAM
TECHNICIANS. WITH ME TODAY IS
MEGAN ASHLAND PROGRAM MANAGER
FOR THE MISSING AN UNIDENTIFIED
PERSON SITE AND WHO ALSO
OVERSEES THE VIOLENT CRIME
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES SECTION.
AGAIN WILL PROVIDE YOU EIGHT
OVERVIEW OF THE MAP SECTION AND
ITS WORK AT WORK IN ANY DONE A
FINE AND LOCATING MISSING
PERSONS AND LIVING AND DECEASED
PERSONS AND CAL. WE ARE ALSO.
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE THANKS VERY MUCH.
AND PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
GALGIANI AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MEGAN NATIONAL MEN
AND I'M THE PROGRAM MANAGER FOR
THE MISSING AN UNIDENTIFIED
PERSON SECTION ALSO KNOWN AS
MAPS I AM PLEASED TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU TODAY ON BEHALF OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO SARAH AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO PROVIDE YOU
BACKGROUND ON OUR CRITICAL WORK
TO LOCATE MISSING PERSONS AND
IDENTIFY UNKNOWN LIVE AND
DECEASED PERSONS. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
AND YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC THANK YOU FOR
ACCOMMODATING- I REQUEST TO
SPEAK A LITTLE EARLIER I'VE WE
ARE THE HOST THE TWO DAY POST
CERTIFIED TRAINING THAT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER. A AND R. O.
IN SAN DIEGO CA I NEEDED TO FLY
DOWN THERE SO I CAN. THE
MISSING AN UNIDENTIFIED PERSON
SECTION WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ASSIST
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AGENCIES IN
LOCATING MISSING PERSONS AND
IDENTIFYING UNKNOWN LIVE
INDICES PERSONS THROUGH THE
COMPARISON OF PHYSICAL
CHARACTERISTICS FINGERPRINTS
AND DENTAL AND BODY X. RAYS.
THE MAPS MAINTAIN STATEWIDE
FILES CONTAINING THE DENTAL
RECORDS MEDICAL RECORDS
PHOTOGRAPHS AND PHYSICAL
CHARACTERISTICS OF BOTH MISSING
AN UNIDENTIFIED PERSONS. THE
PHYSICAL IDENTIFICATION
COMPONENT COMPARES REPORTS OF
MISSING PERSONS AN UNIDENTIFIED
PERSONS AGAINST EACH OTHER FOR
POSSIBLE MATCHES POSSIBLE
MATCHES CAN BE MADE FROM
COMPARISON OF PHYSICAL
CHARACTERISTICS SUCH AS HAIR
COLOR EYE COLOR HEIGHT AND
WEIGHT OR FROM COMPARISON OF
OTHER FARE PHYSICAL IDENTIFIER
SUCH AS CLOTHING JEWELRY. SCARS
OR TATTOOS. PHYSICAL
IDENTIFICATION STAFF ALSO MAKE
INQUIRIES INTO A VARIETY OF
GOVERNMENTAL AND PRIVATE
DATABASES SUCH AS ACCURATE
DEFINED INFORMATION WHICH MAY
RESULT IN THE LOCATION OF
PERSONS REPORTED MISSING OR TO
PROVIDE AN INDICATION OF LIFE.
ANY INFORMATION FOUND IS
DISCLOSED TO THE REPORTING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. THESE
DATABASES ARE ALSO USED TO
ASSIST IN LOCATING NEXT OF KIN
PROJECT NOTIFICATIONS. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE
CALIFORNIA BECAME THE FIRST
STATE TO IMPLEMENT A STATEWIDE
DENTAL IDENTIFICATION PROGRAM
TO PROCESS DENTAL RECORDS
SUBMITTED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND CORONERS AND
MEDICAL EXAMINERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER STATES.
ARE STAFF CLASSIFY INDEX AND
COMPARED DENTAL RECORDS OF
MISSING AN UNIDENTIFIED PERSONS
AGAINST EACH OTHER FOR POSSIBLE
MATCHES IF A MATCH IS MADE
BASED ON DENTAL RECORDS THE
CONTRIBUTING AGENCIES ON BOTH
SIDES ARE NOTIFIED. MAPS OFF
OPERATES THE CALIFORNIA MISSING
CHILDREN'S CLEARING HOUSE WHICH
PROVIDES A NATIONWIDE TOLL FREE
HOTLINE TO RECEIVE TIPS ON THE
WHEREABOUTS OF MISSING PERSONS
FROM THE PUBLIC AND THAT NUMBER
IS ONE EIGHT HUNDRED. TWO TWO
TWO FIND. THE CLEARING HOUSE
WORKS CLOSELY WITH THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR MISSING AND
EXPLOITED CHILDREN ALSO KNOWN
ITS NECK MAC TO AID IN LOCATING
CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEEN ABDUCTED
AND TAKEN OUT OF CALIFORNIA OR
BROUGHT INTO CALIFORNIA. THE
CLEARING HOUSE PROVIDES FREE OF
CHARGE FINGERPRINT CARDS TO
AGENCIES FOR VOLUNTARY
FINGERPRINTING OF CHILDREN.
MAPS OPERATES AND MAINTAINS THE
CALIFORNIA MISSING PERSON
SYSTEM OR M. P. S. WERE LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ENTER
MISSING PERSON RECORDS AND
INFORMATION WHICH IS THEN
IMMEDIATELY ELECTRONICALLY
FORWARDED TO THE FBI'S NATIONAL
CRIME INFORMATION CENTER OR AND
SEE I SEE. MTS IS ACCESSIBLE TO
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT VIA THE
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM OR
CLASS. AND PS WAS FIRST
MANDATED IN CALIFORNIA IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE. AS OF
MARCH FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THERE
WERE NINETEEN THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE ACTIVE
MISSING PERSON RECORDS IN THE
CALIFORNIA MISSING PERSON
SYSTEM AN INTERN IN NCIC. ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY ONE OF THOSE CASES HAVE
DENTAL INFORMATION ON FILE WITH
MAPS. ELEVEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO OF THOSE
CASES ARE CASES WHERE THE
PERSON HAS BEEN MISSING FOR
OVER ONE YEAR. TO HELP LOCATE
MISSING PERSONS THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ALSO PRODUCES AND
DISTRIBUTES A MONTHLY POSTER OF
MISSING CHILDREN AND A
QUARTERLY BULLETIN OF MISSING
CHILDREN AND DEPENDENT ADULTS.
THESE PUBLICATIONS ARE
DISTRIBUTED TO LOCALLAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC THAT
SUBSCRIBES TO RECEIVE THEM.
CURRENT APPLICATIONS ARE ALSO
AVAILABLE ON THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S WEBSITE.
ADDITIONALLY THE MAPS HAS
PARTNERED WITH THE FBI IN THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE TO COORDINATE AND HOST
ANNUAL MISSING IN CALIFORNIA
EVENTS TO RAISE AWARENESS OF
THE ISSUES AND IMPACTS
SURROUNDING MISSING PERSONS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS THE
DIRECTOR RESPONSIBLE FOR
COORDINATING CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSE TO MISSING PERSONS.
THE DIRECTORS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ASSISTING LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AT THEIR REQUEST WITH
TIMELY SEARCH AND RECOVERY OF
MISSING CHILDREN. FOR
MAINTAINING UP TO DATE
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERTISE OF
THOSE PROTOCOLS BEST PRACTICES
AND TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE MOST
EFFECTIVE FOR RECOVERING
MISSING CHILDREN IN A TIMELY
MANNER. ATTENDING VARIOUS
SEMINARS TRAININGS AND
CONFERENCES. FOR MAINTAINING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND OTHER ENTITIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
INVESTIGATION OF MISSING
PERSONS IN THE STATE. AND
MAINTAINING RECORDS AND MAKING
THE COMMISSION ON POST OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING
GUIDELINES FOR HANDLING MISSING
PERSON INVESTIGATIONS DOCUMENTS
AVAILABLE TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES UPON REQUEST. MAPS
MAKE SPECIFIC INFORMATION
AUTHORIZED FOR DISSEMINATION
REGARDING BOTH MISSING AN
UNIDENTIFIED PERSON CASES
ACCESSIBLE TO THE NATIONAL
MISSING AN UNIDENTIFIED PERSON
SYSTEM ALSO KNOWN AS NEMETH
WHEN REQUESTED TO DO SO BY
EITHER THE REPORTING AGENCY.
FOR THE REPORTING PARTY. AS OF
MARCH TENTH AM TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY THERE ARE
TWO THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FOUR ACTIVE MISSING
PERSON CASES PUBLISHED FOR THE
PUBLIC TO VIEW. ON NAME AS-
MAPS PROVIDES TRAINING ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S SERVICES TO LINE
PERSONAL SUPERVISORS AND
INVESTIGATORS WITHIN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. IN ADDITION TO THE
TWO TWO DAY POST CERTIFIED
TRAININGS PROVIDED EACH YEAR
LIKE THE ONES HAPPENING TODAY
AND TOMORROW TRAININGS ARE
PROVIDED AS REQUESTED. WE TRAIN
LAW ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL HOW
AND WHEN TO ENTER THEIR CASE
DATA INTO M. P. S. AN NC I SEE
AS WELL AS OTHER VARIOUS
DATABASES SUCH AS NAMYS NECK
MAC AND THE F. B. I.'S FILING
CRIME CRIMINAL APPREHENSION.
PROGRAM OR BY CAP. MUCH
TRAINING IS ALSO ADMINISTERED
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD ABDUCTION TASK
FORCE WITH SOUL WHICH HOLDS AN
ADDITIONAL SIX TO TEN TRAINS
ACROSS THE STATE ANNUALLY. I'M
ALSO HERE TODAY FROM OUR
DEPARTMENT'S BUREAU OF FORENSIC
SERVICES IS ASSISTANT BUREAU
DIRECTOR NIKITA THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I WANT
I WANT TO START BY THANKING YOU
FOR ALL OF YOUR HELP THAT YOU
PROVIDED TO MY OFFICE I KNOW
THAT WE'VE PROVIDED SOME
INFORMATION ON SOME OLDER COLD
CASES THAT. WERE INDIVIDUALS
WENT MISSING MANY MANY YEARS
AGO AND YOU HAVE BEEN VERY
HELPFUL IN MAKING SURE THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN ADDED. INTO THE
STATE SYSTEM SO I AM VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT- YOU
MENTIONED THAT AT. AT THIS
NUMBER OF RECORDS THAT HAVE
DENTALS ASSOCIATED WITH THEM
CAN YOU GIVE US THOSE FIGURES
AGAIN ENSURE AN APPROXIMATE
PERCENTAGE OF THE- OF THE TOTAL
OF THOSE WHO ARE STILL MISSING.
SOAP CREEK CURRENTLY ACTIVE IN
THE SYSTEM WE'RE CLOSE TO
TWENTY THOUSAND SO IT'S
NINETEEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY NINE. ACTIVE MISSING
PERSON RECORDS THAT WAS AS OF
MARCH FIRST. AND OUT OF THAT
NUMBER WE HAVE DENTAL RECORDS
ON FILE AT MAPS AND ALSO IN
NCIC. FOR ONE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND NINETY ONE OF THEM
SAID THAT'S LESS THAN TWO
PERCENT. 2% CAN YOU DESCRIBE
FOR US SOME OF THE REASONS WHY
THAT NUMBER WOULD BE SMALL AND
IF THAT. CHANGED OVER TIME OR
IF THAT'S BEEN A PRETTY
CONSISTENT PERCENTAGE OVER
TIME. I'M EIGHT IT'S GROWN A
LITTLE BIT OVER TIME JUST
BECAUSE OF PROVIDING TROUT
TRAINING AN OUT REACH. THERE'S
MANY REASONS WHY THAT NUMBER'S
PRETTY SMALL ONE OF WHICH WOULD
BE MANY CHILDREN DON'T HAVE ANY
DENTAL RECORDS AVAILABLE-
THERE'S ALSO CASES WHERE.
DENTAL RECORDS ARE NOT ACTUALLY
THERE THERE'S NO- GUIDELINES
FOR DENTAL OFFICES TO MAINTAIN
DENTAL RECORDS. AS A GENERAL
PRACTICE THE WILL KEEP THEM FOR
ABOUT SEVEN YEARS BUT IF A
PATIENT DOESN'T RETURN AFTER A
YEAR SOMETIMES THEY'RE
DESTROYED- WITH MANY LOCAL
PRACTICES. GOING OUT OF
BUSINESS BEING BOUGHT BY AND
BIG DENTAL CORPORATIONS THEIR
OLDER RECORDS ARE OFTENTIMES
DESTROYED AS WELL- SO IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN SOMEBODY
IS REPORTED MISSING TO OBTAIN
THOSE DENTAL RECORDS IN A
REALLY TIMELY MANNER. SO THAT
THEY CAN BE COLLECTED AND
MAINTAINED IF THEY'RE SUBMITTED
TO US AT DOJ. WE MAINTAIN THEM
INDEFINITELY SO IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF THEY'RE OBTAIN ONE
TIME FOR SAY A RUN AWAY AND
THAT PARTICULAR CHILD COMES AND
GOES IN AND OUT OF THE SYSTEM
MANY TIMES WILL JUST KEEP
UPDATING THE SYSTEM WITH THOSE
DENTAL RECORDS. AND THEN ALSO-
SOMETIMESFAMILY MEMBERS DON'T
KNOW WHERE THEIR LOVED ONES-
WENT TO THE DENTIST ESPECIALLY
IF PEOPLE ARE COMING FROM OTHER
STATES. ON YOU KNOW I'VE
PERSONALLY I'M FROM
PENNSYLVANIA BUT I'VE BEEN HERE
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT SO
MY MOM WOULD HAVE NO IDEA WHO
MY DENTIST AS- HERE. A GOOD
EXAMPLE. IF A FAMILY MEMBER
WERE TO COME FORWARD AND I WILL
GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF A YOUNG
WOMAN WHO SEND STOCKTON WHOSE
MOTHER WENT MISSING FROM
HAYWARD BUT SHE'S NOW LIVING IN
STOCKTON AND SHE CAME TO ME A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO AND WANTED
TO PROVIDE DNA TO BE UPLOADED
INTO THE STATE SYSTEM AND INTO
THE FEDERAL SET SYSTEM. WHAT IS
THE GUIDANCE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR FAMILIES ARE
BOTH ON HOW THAT SHOULD BEST A
QUICK OCCUR. TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT THE DNA WOULD BE UPLOADED
INTO THE STATE SYSTEM AS WELL
AS THE FEDERAL SYSTEM. A WELL
WE ALWAYS ENCOURAGE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO BE AS
ACCOMMODATING WITH THE FAMILIES
AS POSSIBLE SO IT SHOULDN'T
MATTER WHERE THAT FAMILY
MEMBERS SIDES- WE OFTEN
PROVIDE- A LIAISON WITH OTHER-
AGENCIES AND OTHER STATES TO
OBTAIN. THAT DNA SAMPLES SO
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO COME TO
CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE THEIR
SAMPLES AND NO ONE SHOULD HAVE
TO GO TO THE- LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY THAT HAS
JURISDICTION OVER THAT REPORT.
TO PROVIDE A SAMPLE SO. SHE
WOULD BE ABLE TO GO TO HER
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO
PROVIDE A SAMPLE- BUT OF COURSE
AT OUR BUREAU OF FORENSIC
SERVICES HANDLES ALL OF OUR DNA.
COLLECTION PROCEDURES AFTER
THAT POINT. IS THERE A CLEAR
WAY FOR FAMILY MEMBERS TO KNOW
WHETHER THERE IS DNA ON FILE
FOR THEIR LOVED ONE IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT'S INDICATED AND
RECORDS THAT ARE PUBLIC I NOTED
AT THE CALIFORNIA DOJ THERE'S
THE PUBLIC SYSTEM AND THEN
THERE'S THE SECOND SYSTEM THAT
IS USED STRICTLY BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO IS THERE A WAY
FOR A FAMILY MEMBER TO LOOK UP
THEIR LOVED ONE. AND KNOW WITH
ANY CERTAINTY WHETHER THERE IS
DNA ON FILE FOR THEIR LOVED ONE
WE WOULD ADVISE THEM TO SPEAK
WITH THE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY THAT HAS JURISDICTION
OVER THAT PARTICULAR
INVESTIGATION OKAY AND THEN FOR
THAN THE NUMBER OF CASES THAT
YOU GAVE THAT ARE STILL ACTIVE-
DO YOU HAVE IT I THINK YOU SAID
EARLIER THE NUMBER THAT YOU
BELIEVE ARE STILL MISSING AFTER
YEARS TIME. CAN YOU GIVE US
THAT NUMBER YES AFTER AFTER ONE
YEAR AS OF MARCH FIRST TWO
THOUSAND AND 201-100-0500 AND
TWENTY TWO CASES ARE STILL
ACTIVE IN THE SYSTEM. SO THAT
WOULD BE APPROXIMATELY HALF.
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN HALF OKAY.
AND SO JUST SO THAT I MAKE SURE
THAT I UNDERSTAND THIS
CORRECTLY WHEN LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT RECEIVES A REPORT
OF A MISSING PERSON THEY
REPORTED TO. CALIFORNIA MOPS.
AND THE INFORMATION IS
COLLECTED THROUGH CLASS CRACKED
AND TRANSFERRED INTO THE
STATE'S DATABASE AND
AUTOMATICALLY ENTERED INTO AND
SEE I SEE WHERE DOES IT REQUIRE.
DOES IT IS IT REQUIRED THAT.
CALIFORNIA DOJ PERSONNEL
SEPARATELY ENTER INTO AND- LOW
IT'S AUTOMATIC IT'S AN
AUTOMATIC TRANSFER SO ONCE SO
ONCE IT'S ENTERED INTO CLASS
IT'S AUTOMATICALLY TRANSFERRED
INTO NCIC CRACKED OKAY SO NCIC
IS THE SYSTEM THAT WE SHOULD.
THINK OF AS THE PRIMARY FEDERAL
DATABASE FOR ALL MISSING PERSON
REPORTS AND THEN YOU WHEN YOU
MET WITH ME THE OTHER DAY YOU
YOU DESCRIBE FOR US THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BY CAP CODE
IS NAME AS PERHAPS YOU CAN- FOR
THE BENEFIT OF MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR BARGES- AND THE
AUDIENCE. WALK US THROUGH WHAT
OCCURS WITH THE OTHER DATABASES
AND MAYBE SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY HAVE WITH
COMMUNITY COMMUNICATING WITH
ONE ANOTHER IN OTHER WORDS.
BECAUSE SOMETHING IS BECAUSE A
MISSING PERSON IS UP LOADED
INTO ONE SYSTEM DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN THAT THEY CAN
BE AUTOMATICALLY UPLOADED INTO
ANOTHER SYSTEM AND THEIR
REASONS. THAT SOMEONE SHOULD BE
ENTERED INTO BY CAP. AS OPPOSED
TO NOT BEING ENTERED INTO PHI
KAPPA PERHAPS YOU CAN WALK US
THROUGH THAT. I'M SO THE I MEAN
FEDERAL AND STATE MANDATES
INDICATE THAT A LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY ABSOLUTELY
MUST ENTER ANY MISSING PERSON
INTO THE MISSING PERSON SYSTEM
AND I'M JUST FOR CLARIFICATION
IT'S NO THERE'S NO LONGER THE
FOUR HOUR REQUIREMENT FOR
ADULTS- THAT LARGE CHANGE I
THINK IN TWENTY FIFTEEN. SO
IT'S TWO HOURS ACROSS THE BOARD
FOR ANYONE AT RISK OR ANY CHILD
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE.
AND THEN WITHOUT DELAY FOR
ANYONE ELSE. FOR THERE WAS A
FOUR HOUR DELAY WITH. THEIR
WEST UP TO TWENTY FIFTEEN YES I
BELIEVE TWENTY FIFTEEN BUT I'D
HAVE TO DOUBLE CHECK TO OUR-
MUST BE COMPLETE TRANSMISSION
WITHIN TWO HOURS FOR. FOR ANY
ANYONE UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY
ONE AND ANYONE CONSIDERED AT
RISK AND THE PENAL CODE
DESCRIBES WHO'S CONSIDERED AT
RISK I DON'T KNOW THE CRITERIA
OF THE TOP OF MY HEAD. BUT IT
WOULD INCLUDE DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED ADULTS- ANYONE WHO'S
CONSIDERED TO BE AT HARM
PHYSICAL PHYSICAL HARM THERE'S
ABOUT FIVE DIFFERENT SETS OF
CRITERIA FOR AT RISK IS THERE
MUCH I'M SORRY. IT SAYS HERE
FIRST TWELVE TO TWENTY FOUR
HOURS AT THE MOST CRITICAL FOR
A MISSING PERSON. IS THAT
ACROSS. IS THAT ACROSS THE
BOARD WITH. MINERS AND ADULTS
OR IS IT DIFFERENT. FOR MINOR'S.
IT DEPENDS ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF THE CASE IF THE MINOR IS A
RUNAWAY VERSES THE MINERS BEEN.
TAKEN BY AN ADULT- THE NUMBERS
ARE ARE GREATLY DIFFERENT. SO
THERE'S THE WASHINGTON STATE
STUDY- THAT LOOKED AT. CHILDREN
THAT WERE ABDUCTED FOR SEXUAL
PURPOSES AND THEN SUBSEQUENTLY
MURDERED- THOSE NUMBERS THE
TIME FRAME IS MUCH SHORTER SO
THE CRITICAL TIME FRAME FOR
THOSE CASES IS THREE HOURS. AND
THEN THE RATE OF LIKELIHOOD OF
THEM BEING FOUND DECEASED GOES
UP 291% I BELIEVE WITHIN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS. IF THEY'RE NOT
RECOVERED WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS. IN THEIR UNDER EIGHTEEN
THEY HAVE A 90% OR FICTION IF
THEY RENTAL. FOR THAT THAT
UNIQUE CATEGORY. 90% EXPECTED
TO SEE STRAIGHT. BUT I CAN GET
YOU THAT STUDY AS WELL IF YOU'D
LIKE I WOULD ADD TO THAT STATE
LEGISLATION PREVIOUSLY REQUIRED
THAT THE REPORTS BE DONE FROM
THE LOCAL LEVEL TO THE
CALIFORNIA DOJ ONLY FOR MISSING
CHILDREN AND YOUNG PEOPLE UNDER
THE AT THE AGE OF I BELIEVE IT
WAS EIGHTEEN. POINT NINE THAT
RECENTLY AND IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
WE CHANGED THE LAW WITH SENATE
BILL TEN SIXTY SIX REQUIRE
REPORTING OF ALL MISSING ADULTS
IN ADDITION TO TWO CHILDREN
YOUNG PEOPLE. CAN YOU CAN YOU
DESCRIBE FOR US YOUR
INTERACTION WITH NAMYS YES- SO
WE AT. WITHIN MAPS AND WE WORK
WITH NAY MISS EVERY SINGLE DAY-
WE DO HAVE ONE POSITION WHEN
ANALYST POSITION THAT IS
ASSIGNED TO NAME S. WE
COLLABORATE WITH THEM SO- IF A
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY OR
A FAMILY MEMBER. REQUEST THAT
WE- PROVIDE INFORMATION TO NAME
S. WE DO SO AND THAT'S
GENERALLY BIOMETRIC
INFORMATION- FINGERPRINTS.
DENTAL RECORDS PHOTOGRAPHS. IF
WE HAVE CASE REPORTS ON FILED
WILL PROVIDE THAT AS WELL-
ENTRIES CAN BE MADE INTO NAME
IS BY LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES OR BY FAMILY MEMBERS
OR BY ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC.
I'M CURRENTLY OUR METHOD OF
GETTING THAT INFORMATION AND TO
NAME A SO IS MANUAL. WITH WE
ENTER THE DATA INTO OUR STATE
DATABASE AND THEN WE TURN
AROUND AND LOG INTO NAME S. AND
WE ENTER THE DATA INTO THEIR
MANUALLY WE DID LOOK AT PROCESS
I SEE THERE'S NO WAY TO
DIRECTLY TRANSFER ANY OF THE
INFORMATION TO NAME S. THERE'S
NOT A SINGLE BUTTON WE CAN
HEAD. AND SAY PLEASE THAT MET
THE CINEMAS AND UPLOAD THIS NOW
SO IT'S JUST NOT THAT SIMPLE.
BUT IT IS A GREAT RESOURCE AND-
AS I STATED EARLIER IT THEY'RE
ONE OF THE PARTNERS THAT WE
TRAIN WITH AT ALL OF OUR
TRAINING- IN FACT I THINK THE
NAME IS PRESENTATION MIGHT BE
GOING ON RIGHT NOW. IN SAN
DIEGO. IF THERE WAS EL A STATE
LAW TO BE IMPLEMENTED TO MAKE A
REQUIREMENT THAT INDIVIDUALS BE
UPLOADED INTO EIGHT NAME IS
WHAT WOULD BE AN APPROPRIATE
TIME FRAME IN YOUR VIEW. FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL TO BE MISSING BEFORE
MANDATE BE ISSUE THAT THEY BE.
REPORTED TO NAME S. AS WELL. I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK FURTHER INTO AND
PROBABLY DISCUSS DIRECTLY WITH
NAME S. AS WELL. AS TO THE
CAPABILITIES- FOR BOTH OF OUR
SYSTEMS TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
IN ADDITION THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WOULD PROBABLY WANT TO
PROVIDE IMPACT AS TO. HOW LONG
THAT MIGHT TAKE IF SOMEONE IS
SUPPOSED TO MANUALLY ENTER
SOMEONE INTO. IN DOUBLE
SYSTEMS. ABSOLUTELY AND WE
WOULD IT WOULD HAVE TO BE IN ON
WE WOULD HOPE AN ELECTRONIC
INTERFACE WHERE WE COULD SEND
THAT DATA ELECTRONICALLY. IF
YOU WERE TO HAVE A WISHLIST
FROM THE LEGISLATURE- WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE TOOLS THAT THAT WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO GIVE TO YOU IN
THE FUTURE TO- EASE
TRANSMISSION AND- HELP WITH.
THE COLLECTION OF ELECTRONIC.
DATA COMMUNICATING BETWEEN
DATABASES IT SECTOR WHAT WOULD
BE SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE A
TOOL OR TOOLS THAT WE COULD
GIVE TO YOU TO- STREAMLINED AND
HELP YOU IN RESOLVING SOME OF
THE CASES. ON THE TOP OF OUR
LIST WOULD BE A CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM MORE WE COULD TAKE OUR
MANUAL FOLDERS WE HAVE
THOUSANDS OF MANILA FOLDERS
WHERE WE HAVE ALL OF OUR
REPORTS AND MISSING PERSONS
REPORTS AND ALL THE DOCUMENTS
AND WE MAKE OUR NOTES BY HAND.
AND WHEN WE NEED TO LOAD
SOMEONE UP TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S WEBSITE WE LOG INTO A
SEPARATE THING AND WE LOVE THAT
UP THERE AND WHEN THAT CASE
GETS CLOSED OR CHANGES IN THE
MISSING PERSON SYSTEM WE HAVE
TO MANUALLY TAKE THAT
INFORMATION AND CHANGE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S WEBSITE. WE
ARE IN DESPERATE NEED OF A CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT WOULD
IMPROVE OUR TECHNOLOGIES AND
OUR SERVICES THAT WE COULD
OFFER TO CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
FOR MISSING PERSONS AN
UNIDENTIFIED PERSONS SO WE
COULD HAVE. A CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO
ELECTRONICALLY INTERFACE WITH
OUR AG'S WEBSITE AND OTHER-
INTERFACES AS WELL SUCH AS NAY
MATH AND ALLOW US TO
ELECTRONICALLY MANAGE OUR
RECORDS AND HAVE THESE RECORD
STORE TO MAINTAIN AN ELECTRONIC
FORMAT. THAT WOULD BE AT THE
TOP OF OUR LIST THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND PERHAPS WE CAN
CONSIDER THAT GOING FORWARD. I
WOULD AGREE WITH YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT OPTION. DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS CENTER
PORCHES. OKAY I'M SURPRISED
THAT THEY HAVE DINNER. THAT
THAT THE SYSTEMS ARE COMPATIBLE
ENOUGH THAT IF CHANGES IN ONE
ARE AUTOMATICALLY TRANSFERRED
OVER TO THE PARTNERING.
RECEIVING ENTITY IS IT A TECH
ISSUE YOUR TIME A DATA
MANAGEMENT BUT IT IS THIS NOT A
TECH ELIGIBLE SOLUTION IT'S
BOTH THE TECHNOLOGY COULD EXIST
IF WE BECAUSE OUR SYSTEM OUR
STATE SYSTEM IS. FAIRLY OLD I'M
IT'S BUILT ON MESSAGE KEYS- THE
COURT SYSTEM MESSAGE WHAT'S-
THERE IS TECHNOLOGY THAT WOULD
ALLOW YOU TO DO IT BUT IT'S
RESOURCES MONETARY RESOURCES
AND M HAVING THE EXPERTISE TO
COME IN AND HELP US DO THIS.
I'M IT CAN BE DONE IT'S JUST.
TAKES MONEY. THE RIGHT NOW I
JUST THE I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
YOUR CLEAR AND I THINK I AM WE
ARE MOVING ON. THIS IS GONNA
SOUND- TO METRIC ORIENTED BUT
WE LIVE IN. A DATA DRIVEN WORLD
LISTEN THE LEGISLATIVE SIDE IF
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BUDGET
APPROPRIATIONS AND TRYING TO.
PUSH FOR THE IMMEDIACY OF THE
SITUATION. IF WE'RE USING. TIME
OF UNDER TWENTY FOUR HOURS IN
SOME INSTANCES AND UNDER THREE
HOURS IN CERTAIN INSTANCES. ARE
THERE INSTANCES WHERE IS THERE
ANY METRICS ARE ANY HIT DATA
HISTORY THAT INDICATES THE TIME
IT TAKES TO UPLOAD INFORMATION.
FROM ONE SOURCE INTO A SECOND
AND THAT SECOND BEING WITH IN A
JURISDICTION THAT COULD HAVE
OTHERWISE BEEN HELPFUL IN
TRACKING AN INDIVIDUAL. USING
THE TIME LINES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. IS THERE ENOUGH
JUSTIFICATION FOR THAT
APPROPRIATION COULD SOUND LIKE
THERE WOULD BE. THAT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY SAVING LIVES BY A
INTEROPERABLE IMPROVING THE
INTER OPERABILITY OF THESE
SYSTEMS. WE WOULD BE IMPROVING
THE INTER OPERABILITY BUT WE DO
HAVE A SYSTEM IN PLACE THROUGH
CLASS THAT ALLOWS US TO GET
THAT INFORMATION TO US INTO THE
NATIONAL SYSTEM WITHIN THE
MANDATED TIME FRAMES NOW. THIS
WOULD ALLOW US TO BETTER MANAGE
IT MORE EFFICIENTLY AND TO MAKE
SURETHAT ALL OF OUR SYSTEMS
AND THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL DATA TO ADDITIONAL
SYSTEMS AND SO YES IT IS. I
THINK IT WOULD DEFINITELY IF WE
COULD. UTILIZE THE SYSTEM TO
FOR INSTANCE- CONNECT WITH C.
H. P. AS AS INDICATED EARLIER.
FOR THE MAJORITY OF THE
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA AND TACK
WHICH IS THEIR EMERGENCY SYSTEM
THAT'S OPEN TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY ITS HEADQUARTERED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THAT'S TO FOR THE
MOST PART ISSUES AMBER ALERTS
SILVER ALERTS ENDANGERED
MISSING ADVISORIES- IF WE COULD
EASILY TRANSMIT INFORMATION
DIRECTLY TO THEM AS WELL THAT
WOULD BE INCREDIBLY HELPFUL TO
YOU TAKEN. SYSTEM SURE THE IN
IN IN IN OUR SYSTEM THE MISSING
PERSON IS A BLONDE. AND THAT
WAS A MISTAKE. IN AND ACTUALLY
A BRUNETTE. AND IF THAT GOES
OUT TO A DIFFERENT SET OF
AUTHORITIES. YOU'RE SAYING THAT
THE FOR YOUR SYSTEM IT WILL
EVENTUALLY. BE MADE AVAILABLE
IN INFORMATION IN A IN A
DIFFERENT JURISDICTION WHETHER
BE FEDERAL OR YOU NAME IT.
YOU'RE ABLE TO IMPROVE YOU'RE
ABLE TO TRANSMIT THAT
INFORMATION IN ENOUGH TIME THAT
YOU SATISFIED THE- THE
STATUTORY DEMANDS OR WHATEVER
HE'S LEGISLATION CONTROLS ON
THIS ISSUE. BUT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SAVING EVEN MORE TIME SO
THAT IF THE HAIR COLOR IS
DIFFERENT FROM THE INITIAL DATA
ENTRY POINT TO THE SECOND
UPDATED DATA POINT IN YOUR
SENDING OUT INFORMATION I THINK
COACH ARGUMENT COULD STILL BE
MADE THAT. THE FASTER
INFORMATION IS EXCHANGED AND
MADE AVAILABLE ACROSS
JURISDICTIONS ACTUALLY DEALS
PRECISELY ON HELPING DEAL WITH
MISSING PERSONS. CERTAINLY I
BELIEVE YOU JUST MADE THE CASE
FOR WHY THEY NEED THE
ELECTRONIC MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
WHICH I WOULD AGREE WITH THAT
THAT MAKES. MAKE MAKE SENSE. IS
THERE ANYTHING MORE THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ADD. WE HAVEN'T
HAD ENOUGH TIME TO THINK ABOUT.
WELL WE LOOK FORWARD TO
INCLUDING YOU AND FUTURE
HEARINGS THAT THIS COMMITTEE
WILL HAVE AND REALLY THANK YOU
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO DO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING TIME OUT TODAY TO BE TO
PRESENT TO OUR COMMITTEE AND
WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ZERO. YEAH. OKAY TIMELINE.
NEXT I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
CHIRLA CONTROL WHO IS THE
DISPATCHER OF THE CITRUS
HEIGHTS POLICE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE AS THE WITH AN OVERVIEW
OF HER TRAINING AND EXPERIENCE
IN HANDLING CALLS CONCERNING
MISSING PERSONS AND PROVIDE A
DESCRIPTION OF HER
ADMINISTRATIVE DUTIES TO
INITIATE AN INTER MISSING
PERSON CASES INTO THE
RESPECTIVE DATABASE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND MADAM CHAIRWOMAN FOR
INVITING ME AND DETECTIVE RAINY
KEYLESS WHILE IT'S VERY RARE
THAT A DISPATCHER IS ASKED TO
PARTICIPATE. IN ANY SORT OF
THESE LEGISLATIVE REVIEWS AND
SO IT IS AN HONOR TO BE
INCLUDED. I AM WHEN A REPORTING
PARTY CALLS INTO THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND- W. CARROLL DID
A REALLY GOOD JOB OF EXPLAINING
THE INITIAL PROCESS. BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THE DISPATCHER HE TAKES THAT
INITIAL CALL FOR SERVICE. MUST
UTILIZE ACTIVE LISTENING SKILLS
WHILE ENGAGING IN A PRECISE
INTERROGATION OF THAT REPORTING
PARTY. SO OFTEN TIMES IF IT'S A
REPEAT MISSING PERSON SUCH AS A
CHILD FROM A GROUP HOME. YOUR
REPORTING PARTY MAY BE A
MINIMUM MINIMUM WAGE STAFF
WORKER WHOSE BURNED OUT. WHO
HAS A LITTLE BIT OF COMPLACENCY
AND THEY MAY NOT BE PROVIDING
AS MUCH INFORMATION AS IS
REQUIRED TO DO A QUALITY MAPS
ENTRY. SO THAT'S A CHALLENGE TO
THE DISPATCHER FACES AND IT'S
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
GETTING AFTER THE ACCURATE
INFORMATION. I'M ANOTHER
COMPLICATION THAT CAN HAPPEN
WITH THE REPORTING PARTY. IS
THAT IT'S A TRAGIC EVENT IT'S A
IT'S A TRUE CRITICAL MISSING
SUCH AS A YOUNG CHILD OR A
LOVED ONE. AND THE DISPATCHER
MUST NOT ONLY DO THAT PRECISE
INTERROGATION. BUT ALSO USE ALL
THIS ALL THE SKILLS AT THEIR
DISPOSAL TO CALM THAT REPORTING
PARTY. MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
GETTING ACCURATE INFORMATION
ALL SAME SIMULTANEOUSLY
GATHERING THAT DATA FOR THE
RADIO DISPATCHER TO SEND THE
RESPONSE. OFTENTIMES I'M
SPEAKING ONLY AS FIVE
DISPATCHER WHO'S WORKED IN A-
COMMUNICATIONS AYE THAT'S IN A
HOUSE IN A POLICE DEPARTMENT
OUT OF SOME OF HIS WORK
CONSOLIDATED COMMUNICATIONS
WHICH IS AN OFF SITE. TYPE OF
DISPATCH CENTER. OFTENTIMES WE
WORK AS THE INITIAL INCIDENT
COMMANDER. ORGANIZING THE
RESPONSE INTELLIGENCE A COMMAND
POST TO SET UP AN INCIDENT
COMMANDER IS NAMED. SO DURING A
CRITICAL MISSING YOUR RADIO
DISPATCHER MAY ACTUALLY BE
ORGANIZING THAT SEARCH GRAD.
FIGURING OUT WHAT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED SUCH AS-
HELICOPTER SEARCH AND RESCUE. A
CANINE WHAT ADDITIONAL
TECHNOLOGICAL RESOURCES WE HAVE
SUCH AS DOING WHAT WE CALL AN
EVER BRIDGER REVERSE NINE ONE
SYSTEM TO NOTIFY THE PUBLIC OF
THE MISSING PERSON. AND USING
SOCIAL MEDIA IN ORDER TO ALERT
THE PUBLIC. I'M AND WE ALSO
WHILE WE'RE- DOING ALL OF THOSE
THINGS SIMULTANEOUSLY. WE ALSO
HAVE TO ENSURE THAT WORK TAKING
OFFICER SAFETY IS RESPONDING
INTO MIND. AND MAKING SURE THAT
WERE ASKING THOSE QUESTIONS AS
WELL BEFORE THE UNITS RESPOND.
AFTER THE INITIAL INTERROGATION
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE THE LAST
KNOWN LOCATION OF THE MISSING
PERSON. THEIR NAME DATE OF
BIRTH DESCRIPTORS BUT THEIR
LAST SEEN WEARING. I'M A
POSSIBLE DESTINATION OR
DIRECTION OF TRAVEL. WHAT THE
TIME ELEMENT WAS WHEN THEY WERE
LAST SEEN. AND ANY SORT OF
HEALTH CONDITIONS ARE AT RISK
FACTORS SUCH AS MENTAL HEALTH
OR COGNITION THAT'S ALL THAT
INITIAL INTERROGATION AT THE
DISPATCHER HAS TO DO. THAT WE
NEED TO SET THE TONE FOR THAT
RESPONSE AND I THINK THAT THERE
IS A- NOT A MISCONCEPTION BUT I
THINK THAT A MISUNDERSTANDING
OF. THE DISPATCHERS ONE THAT
THAT SAYS THAT PRIORITY SO YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT HOW LONG DID
IT TAKE SOMEONE TO RESPOND A
MISSING PERSONS CALL. IF AS YOU
KNOW IT WAS OF A FOR ITS AS-
VOLUNTARY MISSING ADULT WHO
JUST DOESN'T WANT TO HAVE
CONTACT WITH THEIR FAMILY. THAN
ANYTHING THAT'S IN PROGRESS
SUCH AS A WEAPONS CALL OR IF I
CALL FOR A CAR ACCIDENT IS
GONNA BE DISPATCHED PRIOR TO
THAT VOLUNTARY MISSING ADULT
AND THE DISPATCHERS WHEN IT'S
MAKING THAT DETERMINATION. IF
IT IS A CRITICAL MISSING PERSON
THEN WE'RE GOING TO USE EVERY
RESOURCE AT OUR DISPOSAL AND
THEY'RE GONNA BE THE ONE THAT
SAYS THAT EMERGENCY. RESPONSE
THEY'RE GONNA NOTIFY THEIR
SERGEANT WHO IN TURN IS GOING
TO FOLLOW THEIR NOTIFICATION
MATRIX UP THE CHAIN OF COMMAND
AND IF NEEDED THEN WE'RE GOING
TO ALSO ASK FOR ALLIED AGENCIES
TO COME IN AFTER THE RESOURCE
FOR US. I'M. IN TURN THE
DISPATCHER I AM. WHO IS
RECEIVING INFORMATION AFTER THE
OFFICER RESPONDS AND GETS THE-
MISSING PERSONS FORM BACK FROM
THE OFFICER WHO'S DOING THE
DATA ENTRY THEY HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE USING EVERY
RATE RESOURCE AT THEIR DISPOSAL
THAT THEY'RE USING THE MOST
ACCURATE UP TO DATE
INFORMATION. AND YOU WE HAVE
THIS TERM THAT WE GET FROM THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE CALL PACKED
THE RECORD AND WHAT THEY MEAN
BY THAT IS PUT EVERY SINGLE
THING THAT YOU CAN INTO THAT
INITIAL ENTRY AND THERE'S A LOT
OF DIFFERENT FIELDS THAT WE CAN
USE IN CLASS AND THAT
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS DATABASE. TO
DOCUMENT INFORMATION AND THAT
COULD BE. OURS MARKS ARE
TATTOOS WHICH WE COULD USE FOR
IDENTIFICATION. AND SENATOR
BOAR JUST ASKED ABOUT YOU KNOW
IF THEY ACCIDENTALLY BUT THAT
THEIR BLONDE ANOTHER BURNETT.
SO THOSE THINGS CAN BE UPDATED
IN THE MISCELLANEOUS FIELD AS
WELL SO WE CAN LIST THEM AS-
YOU KNOW THE LAST KNOWN.
DISCOVERS THAT WE HAD OF THEM
WAS THAT THEY WERE A BLIND BUT
MISCELLANEOUS FEEL WE COULD SAY
AT TIMES SHOWS AS A BURNETT. SO
WE CAN ACTUALLY DOCUMENT BOTH
OF THOSE THINGS IF NEEDED. I'M
AND WE CAN ALSO USE DIFFERENT
SYSTEMS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE GETTING. THE MOST UP TO
DATE INFORMATION AS POSSIBLE.
SO THEY ARE USING EXAMPLE OF
pYOU KNOW MY- I AM FROM OUT OF
STATE MY MOM MIGHT NOT KNOW
WHAT DENNIS TO USE. WELL WE CAN
USE THINGS LIKE AN UPDATED
DRIVER LICENSE TO GET
INFORMATION. WE CAN ACTUALLY
RUN THEIR ADAM CRIMINAL HISTORY
TO SEE IF THERE'S AN UPDATED
TATTOO LISTED FROM AT A MORE
RECENT BOOKING. THE FAMILY MAY
KNOW WHAT. I'M AND ANOTHER
EXAMPLE I'D LIKE TO. EMPHASIZE
IS WHEN OFFICERS ARE OUT DOING
FIELD INTERVIEW CARDS ON THEIR
DAILY PATROLS. WE CAN. IF THE
PERSON WHO'S MISSING IS KNOWN
TO OUR SYSTEM IT IN AN ARC
INTERNAL DATABASE. SOMETIMES AS
IF I CARDS HAVE MORE UPDATED
INFORMATION. THEN THE FAMILY
MAY HAVE ABOUT WITH THIS PERSON
LOOKS LIKE NOW CHANGES TO. WAIT
DID A LIVING OUT IN THE
ELEMENTS. ANY TATTOO AND HIS
CAR THINGS LIKE THAT. OR WHAT
THEY WERE LAST SEEN CLOSE
WEARING CLOTHING WEISS. SO WE
CAN USE MULTIPLE SOURCES. AND
TO SUPPORT IN ORDER TO GET THAT
RECORD ACCURATE FOR THE INITIAL
CLASS ENTRY. AND AN- AS- YOUR
ADAM COUNTERPART WAS ASKING
ABOUT. THE POPULAR BELIEF THAT
AND IT'LL HAVE TO BE MISSING
FORTY TO SEVENTY TWO HOURS OF
THERE'S NOTHING ELSE THAT COMES
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE IF WE
COULD DO SOME PUBLIC OUTREACH
TO DISSUADE THAT RUMOR WE
WORKED AT AT IN OUR CITY WHERE
WE PUT OUT SOCIAL MEDIA
BROADCASTING HEY THIS IS THIS
IS ACTUALLY NOT TRUE. AND
ANYTIME YOU HAVE CONCERN FOR A
MISSING PERSON PLEASE YOU CALL
US IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE THE
FIRST TWENTY FOUR HOURS IS
CRITICAL AND WE TALKED ABOUT
YOU KNOW WHY IS THAT WHY IS
THAT FIRST TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
SENSITIVE EVEN IF YOU'RE TRYING
TO BACKTRACK WHERE PERSON SPEND
SOMETIMES PEOPLE DON'T HANG ON
TO SURVEY SURVEILLANCE VIDEO
FOR MORE THAN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
THEY WHITE BUTTON. REQUIRE BACK
OVER IT AND A LOT OF THOSE
CLUES GO COLD SO. THINGS LIKE.
I AM. USE LPR WHICH IS THAT
LICENSE PLATE READING DATABASE.
SO THOSE RECORDS ARE HELD FOR.
A FINITE NUMBER OF DAYS SO
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT OKAY
THIS PERSON MISSING IN THIS CAR
AND IT'S TOO LATE AFTER THE
FACT TO PULL UP THAT DATA
BACKDATED COULD BE GONE THAT'S
WHY THESE. MISSING PERSONS
REPORT SHOULD BE MADE IN A
TIMELY MANNER. CAN YOU ANSWER
FOR AS HOW LONG THE LICENSE
PLATE READER DATA IS MAINTAINED.
I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE I KNOW IT
IT VARIES I AM. AND I BELIEVE
IT CAN BE A NUMBER OF MONTHS
BUT I DO BELIEVE THERE'S A
FINITE NUMBER OF HITS THAT CAN
BE NINETEEN PER PLATE SO I'D
HAVE TO LOOK INTO THAT FOR YOU.
CAN YOU DESCRIBE TO US HOW
YOU'RE TRAINED BY POST. SURE SO
AM I START MY DISPATCHING KERR
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND THREE.
AND WHEN YOU GET YOUR INITIAL.
I AM. POSTED STASHING
CERTIFICATE THERE IS A SECTION
THERE REGARDING MISSING
PERSONS. AND SO THAT'S THAT'S
PART OF YOUR INITIAL BASIC POST
DISPATCHING COURSE. AND THEN AS
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION COMES
OUT SUCH AS THERE'S A THERE'S A
RECENT LAW THAT WAS CHANGED IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN. THOSE COME OUT
IN THE DOJ BULLETINS AND COME
OUT AS UPDATES AND THEN WE ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE AND- A
REQUIRED AMOUNT OF HOURS OF
TRAINING THE DOJ AND A LOT OF
THAT DOES REQUIRES MISSING
PERSON AFTER THIS IS FILE. OKAY
AND AS A DISPATCHER DO YOU HAVE
ANY INTERACTION WITH DOING ANY
INPUT INTO THE CLOUDS DIRECTLY
YOURSELF YES MA'AM SO AND MY
CURRENT POSITION IS AND THE
DISPATCH SUPERVISOR NOW BUT I
WORKED AS AT LINE LEVEL
DISPATCHER FOR MY CURRENT
AGENCY FOR THE LAST NINE YEARS
AND WE DO MAPS ENTRIES O A
REGULAR BASIS. AND THE- ONCE
THAT WE DO THE MOST OFTEN ARE
THOSE REPEAT RUN AWAY FROM THE
GROUP HOMES. AND THE REASON WHY
I BRING TO LIGHT THE
COMPLACENCY FACTOR REGARDING
THE REPORTING OF THOSE
JUVENILES IS BECAUSE- CONTRARY
TO POPULAR BELIEF IT'S- IT'S
ACTUALLY MORE DANGER SOME MORE
OFTEN THEY GO MISSING. YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY IF IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S OUT OF CHARACTER THIS
CHILD IS YOU KNOW A MODEL
STUDENT STRAIGHT DAYS NEVER
GONE MISSING BEFORE AN OFFICE
AND THEY'RE GONE. THAT'S A
CRITICAL MISSING. BUT THESE
JUVENILES WHO LIVE IN THESE
GROUP HOMES WHO ARE ESSENTIAL.
ESSENTIALLY THROWAWAYS THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS HAVE GIVEN UP ON
THEM. THERE WERE TO THE COURT
AND THEY'RE CHRONICALLY RUNNING
AWAY AND THERE. THE ACCURACY OF
THE RECORD CONTINUES TO DWINDLE
AS PEOPLE. BECOME COMPLACENT
WITH THEIR BEHAVIOR THOSE ARE
THE ONES AND UP IN THE
RECEIVING HOME AND THOSE ARE
THE ONES AND UP. BEING
TRAFFICKED. AND SO THOSE AT. IT
IS DIFFICULT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE DOING THOSE ENTRIES AS
ACCURATELY AS WE CAN BECAUSE
THEY DO HAPPENED SO OFTEN
SOMETIMES TWO OR THREE TIMES A
DAY YES I WAS AMAZED TO LOOK AT
SOME FEDERAL STATISTICS AND
STATE STATISTICS AS WELL AS- TO
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO.
WENT MISSING WHO WERE WHO WERE
RUNAWAYS AND HOW MANY WERE
ENTERED INTO THE SYSTEM AND
THEN TAKEN BACK OUT. BECAUSE
THEY WERE FOUND IN AND THE
NUMBER IS ASTOUNDING IT IS AND
IT CAN BE. EXHAUSTIVE
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT'S THE SAME
KIDS OVER AND OVER MULTIPLE
TIMES A DAY. AND SO THAT WOULD
BE WHAT I WOULD. CAUTION
AGAINST IS AYE COMPLACENCY BOTH
ON THE REPORTING PARTIES BEHALF
AND ON THE INTERAGENCY. AND
PERHAPS WHEN THAT IS OCCURRING
PERHAPS THAT SHOULD TRIGGER
SOME ADDITIONAL REPORTING TO.
ANOTHER ENTITY WHO CAN CAN COME
IN AND PROVIDE SUPPORT. AT AS
AN AD PSYCHOLOGICAL COUNSELING
LEVEL- JUST TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO SOMEBODY THAT
THEY KNOW HAS THAT HISTORY BUT-
NOW WITH THE BEHAVIOR IS MAKING
THEMSELVES. A GREATER TARGET
FOR. BECOMING A PERMANENT
MISSING PERSON DOWN THE ROAD.
ABSOLUTELY I UNDERSTAND AS THE
CITRUS HEIGHTS POLICE
DEPARTMENT PARTNERS WITH
PROJECT LIFESAVER CORRECT CAN
YOU DESCRIBE THAT PRIOR THAT
PROGRAM FOR US I WOULD I WOULD
VERY MUCH LIKE TO SO. I THINK
EVERY PERSON THAT'S BEEN APT
HERE HAS TALKED ABOUT A STORY
THAT HAS BROUGHT THEM TO THIS
TABLE. I'M AND SOMETIMES IN
ORDER FOR REAL EFFECTIVE CHANGE
BE MADE WE HAVE TO EXPERIENCE
FAILURE. AND JUST LIKE. YOU
KNOW THE AMBER ALERT SYSTEM WAS
NAMED AFTER AN AMBER HAGERMAN.
MY AT MY STORY WITH PROJECT
LIFE THERE ARE STARTED WITH A
MAN THAT WILL CALL VICTOR. SO
VICTOR'S FAMILY WAS HISPANIC
AND THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE BEST.
RELATIONSHIP WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT THEY WERE A LITTLE
BIT APPREHENSIVE TO CALL US IN
THE FIRST PLACE. I'M VICTOR Y.
AS AN ELDERLY GENTLEMAN HE WAS
IN HIS SEVENTIES AND HE HAD
SEVERAL HEALTH CONDITIONS. HE
HAD DEMENTIA HE HAD A HEART
CONDITION AND HE WAS DIABETIC
THAT REQUIRED MEDICATION. AND
VICTOR LIVED AT HOME WITH HIS
FAMILY AND IT THEY DID THEIR
VERY BEST TO TAKE CARE OF HIM.
ONE DAY VICTOR WENT MISSING I
AM AND HIS FAMILY LOOK FOR HIM
THE BEST THAT THEY COULD AND
AFTER TWO HOURS THEY FINALLY
CAME TO THE DECISION THAT THEY
HAD TO CALL FOR HELP AS MUCH AS
THEY WERE. SCARED TO DO SO. AND
SO THEY DID SO WE ARE ALREADY
TWO HOURS BEHIND. BEHIND THE
TIME OF WHEN HE LAUGHED WHEN HE
ELOPED. AND I WAS WORKING AS AT
LINE LEVEL DISPATCHER THAT DAY
AND WE THROUGH EVERYTHING THAT
WE COULD AT THIS CASE. WE DID
EXACTLY WE'RE SUPPOSED TO THE
CRITICAL MISSING WE DEPLOYED
EVERY SINGLE AVAILABLE UNIT. TO
THE POINT LAST SEEN WE SET UP A
C. P. WE CIRCULATED THE AREA.
AND WE WERE UNSUCCESSFUL. SO
THEN WE DID THE NEXT THING
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO DO WHICH IS
ASK FOR HELP RIGHT SO WE-
CONTACTED OUR NEIGHBORING
TERRACE DEPARTMENT WE ASK FOR
AIR SUPPORT. WE ASK FOR SEARCH
AND RESCUE. AND WE GOT
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES OUT THERE
WE DID THE I OVER WE GOT THE
DOGS OUT. AND WE COULDN'T FIND
VICTOR. SO THEN WE HAD ANOTHER
YOU. SHIFT OF OFFICERS COME ON
AND WE TO PLAY THEM AS WELL NO
WAY TO FULL SHIPS OF OFFICERS
WE HAD TWO AIRSHIPS AB WE HAD
SEARCH AND RESCUE OUT THERE THE
DOGS. MEDIA STARTS TO SHOW UP
AND STILL WE CAN'T FIND VICTOR
WE SEARCH A LONG INTO THE NIGHT
AND WE SEARCH FOR OVER EIGHTEEN
HOURS AND I DID THE MATH ONE
DAY. AND WE HAD UTILIZED OVER
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
RESOURCES AND WE ENDED UP.
LOSING THAT CALL FOR SERVICE
WHAT. FINING HIM. AND I WENT
HOME THAT NIGHT. FEELING LIKE
AN ABJECT FAILURE. AND I
REMEMBER CONTACTING MY PARTNER
NICKY HIS HERE TODAY AND I
REMEMBER SAYING TO HER. I FEEL
LIKE WE FAILED AND WE NEED TO
DO BETTER AND SO THAT PROMPTED
US TO START LOOKING FOR. A
SOLUTION AND HOW COULD WE
PREVENT THIS FROM HAPPENING WE
KNEW THAT VICTOR WAS AT RISK
FOR WANDERING DUE TO HIS
COGNITIVE DISORDER. AND SO
WE'VE ADDED A COUPLE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS AND WE LANDED ON
PROJECT LIFESAVER IS BEING THE
BEST FIT FOR OUR PARTICULAR
AGENCY. BECAUSE IT WAS
NONPROFIT. IT WAS CREATED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. IT HAD A- SIXTY
THREE THAT WAS PROVEN OVER A
NUMBER OF YEARS. THERE WERE
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WERE GPS
BASED THAT WERE FLASH YEAR HAD
NEWER TECHNOLOGY. BUT WE WERE
CAUTIOUS ABOUT THEM BECAUSE
THEY REQUIRED. THE FAMILY
MEMBERS TO PAY FOR A MONTHLY
SERVICE FEE. AND THE COMMUNITY
THAT WE SERVE. THEY'RE WORKING
CLASS CITIZENS AND WHEN YOU
HAVE SOMEONE IN THE FAMILY THAT
IS SPENDING. ALL OF THE TIME
THAT THEY COULD BE WORKING.
CARING FOR A LOVED ONE THEY
USUALLY 'T
TO THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS TO
SPEND A MONTH FOR MONITORING
SERVICE. SO WITH PROJECT
LIFESAVER MY PARTNER NICK AND I
WENT OUT AND WE SOLICITED.
GRANTS WE AND FUND RAISING OUR
COMMUNITY WE FIND REYES WITH
OUR LOCAL SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS. AND WE'RE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THIS NO COST
PROGRAM. TO OUR RESIDENTS IT
HAS COST THE CITY ZERO DOLLARS
AND IS COST THE CITIZENS HERE
DOLLARS TO PARTICIPATE. I'M ARE
THE BATTERIES FOR THE BAND THAT.
DAYS AND WE HAVE A CADRE
AMAZING VOLUNTEER THAT GOES OUT
AND DOES THAT SERVICE FOR US SO
IT DOES NOT TAKE ANY OF THE
OFFICERS TIME DOES NOT TAKE.
TIME AWAY FROM CSOS BEING OUT
ON THE STREET FIELDING CALLS
FOR SERVICE. AND HOW IT WORKS
IS IT'S A RADIO FREQUENCY BASED
LOCATING PROGRAM. IF THE SAME
THING THAT- WILDLIFE TRACKERS
USE WHEN THEY'RE- TRACKING
WILDCATS ARE WOLVES LIKE OUT
AND IN THE WILD. BUT OBVIOUSLY
WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE A LARGE
CONTRAPTION ON THESE PEOPLE SO
IT'S SMALLER. I'M AND SO
USUALLY GOES EITHER ON THE
ANKLE AT OUR CHILDREN WHO ARE
PART OF THE PROGRAM. OR ON THE
REST LIKE A WATCH FOR THE TEENS
FOR THE ADULTS. AND IT EMITS AS
SILENT RADIO FREQUENCY SIGNAL
EVERY SIXTY SECONDS. THAT WE
HAVE THE RECEIVERS TO AND
MONITOR. SO IN THE EVENT NOW
THAT ONE OF OUR PROJECT PLACE
OF OUR CLIENTS BECAUSE MISSING
WE HAVE PROVIDED THEM A SCRIPT.
AND BECAUSE WHEN THEY DO CALL
ME WHEN THEY'RE NERVOUS. IT'S
NERVE WRACKING THEIR LOVED ONE
IS GONE THEY THEY'RE WORRIED
FOR THEIR- FOR THEIR- FOR
EITHER THE CLIENT OTHER FAMILY
MEMBER. AND SO WE PROVIDE THEM
A SCRIPT THAT THEY CAN CARRY IN
THEIR WALLET OR THE WE'VE MADE
THEM A MAGNET THAT THEY CAN PUT
ON ON THE FRIDGE. AND IT TELLS
THEM EXACTLY WHAT TO SAY WHEN
THEY CALL NINE ONE- INCLUDING
THE FREQUENCY THAT IS UNIQUE TO
THAT CLIENT. I WOULD LIKE A
VERY SMALL DEMONSTRATION YES
PLEASE OKAY. SO THIS IS LASSEN
EIGHTY. THIS IS ADAM. WHAT THE
RECEIVER LOOKS LIKE AND AS YOU
CAN SEE IT'S VERY SIMPLE ALL IT
IS JUST LIKE A RADIO RECEIVER
LIKE YOU'D SEE BACK IN THE
SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES. AND BUT
THE REASON WHY WE CHOSE THIS IS
BECAUSE THE TOP LOCKERBIE IN
CITRUS HEIGHTS IS SUCH THAT WE
HAVE LARGE OPEN GREEN SPACES WE
HAVE SEVERAL MILES OF CREEK
AREA BUT WE ALSO HAVE APARTMENT
BUILDINGS IT'S A BEDROOM
COMMUNITY FOR PEOPLE THAT CAN
MEET FOR WORK. SO WE HAVE THESE
HUGE APARTMENT COMPLEXES WE
HAVE EIGHTY THE AM I EIGHTY
THAT RUNS THROUGH THE CITY WE
WANT THIS BILL TO WORK THROUGH
CONCRETE WE WANT THIS TO WORK
THROUGH STEEL AND THAT'S WHY WE
CHOSE A RADIO BASED PROGRAM AS
OPPOSED TO A GPS PROGRAM. LESS
EXPENSIVE IT DOESN'T NEED TO BE
CHARGED EVERY TWELVE HOURS AND
IT WORKS THROUGH ALL OF THESE.
HERE'S THE OTHER ISSUE THAT WE
FOUND WITH A LOT OF THE GPS
SOLUTIONS. WAS THAT YOU HAVE TO
KEEP TAKING IT OFF OF THE
CLIENT IN ORDER TO CHARGE IT
OVERNIGHT. WELL WHEN THESE
FOLKS. WONDER SOMETIMES IT'S
DUE TO SUNDOWNERS IF YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THAT TERM HAM
WITH FOLKS I HAVE DEMENTIA. AND
SO THEN THEY HAVE TAKEN OFF THE
DEVICE TO CHARGE IT AND THEN
THAT'S WHEN THEY WONDER. OR
WITH THE KIDS DOUBLE AND RAN
AND IT'S LEFT ON THE CHARGING
STATIONS WE WANTED THIS DEVICE
TO NEVER COME OFF THEIR BODIES
SO. THE ACTUAL TRANSMITTER THAT
THEY WHERE IS AND WATER
RESISTANT SO THEY CAN STILL DO
THEIR WATER THERAPY THEY CAN
SWIM THEY CAN BATHE AND IT
STAYS ON THEIR PERSON. THE ONLY
TIME WE TAKE OFF IS WHEN WE TO
ABOUT AND WE PUT IT RIGHT BACK
ON. WE'VE HAD BEEN RAMP. SEVEN
YEARS. AND I'VE GROWN UP WITH
IT SOME OF OUR LITTLE GUYS. AND
THEN WE HAVE AND SOME OF OUR
OLDER CLIENTS. THAT HAVE BEEN
ON THE PROGRAM FOR A SHORTER
TIME. AND IN THE NAY H. OUT OF
THE PROGRAM AS WELL. SO MY
PARTNER NIKKI IS WEARING ONE OF
THE DEVICES ON A REST. AND
BASICALLY ONCE YOU GET A
SIGNAL. THE AVERAGE RECOVERY
TIME WITH THIS DEVICE IS THIRTY
MINUTES OR LESS. WHICH I A
HUGE BECAUSE IT TAKES A SEARCH
THAT THE AVERAGE SEARCH TIME
FOR AN ALZHEIMER'S PATIENT IS
NINE HOURS. NATIONALLY AN
AVERAGE. COST OF A SEARCHES
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
HOUR WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT.
HOW MANY RESOURCES HERE
UTILIZING. SO WITH THIS PROGRAM
WE HAVE GOTTEN THAT SEARCH TIME
FROM THE- FROM ONLY START THE
SEARCH WITH THE EQUIPMENT TO
THIRTY MINUTES OR LESS AND YOU
ONLY NEED. THREE OFFICERS TO
OPERATE AS YOU'RE NOT TO PLAN
YOUR ENTIRE CADRE FOLKS
NECESSARILY. COURSE OF THE
CRITICAL MISSING WE STILL DO
INITIALLY BUT- AND- SO THIS
PLAN HAS TO BE ON A SIX BECAUSE
THIS OPERATES ON A TWO ONE SIX
MEGAHERTZ CHANNEL AND THESE
LAST THREE BUTTONS HAVE TO BE
ON THE UNIQUE FREQUENCY FOR THE
CLIENTS EACH CLAN MEMBER HAS A
UNIQUE THREE DIGIT FREE
CONCERTS ASSIGNED TO THEM AND
THEN ONCE YOU HAVE THE SIGNAL
IT'S REALLY LIKE PLAYING PONG
COLD THE LOUDER THE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT YOU ARE.
TICKETS CHOIR GOING THE WRONG.
THAT'S HOW SIMPLE IT. BOB JUST
PERFORMED. YOU HAD TO BE. SO
THAT'S WHAT I'M LISTENING FOR
IF I GO THIS WAY. IT GETS HIRED
SOMEONE THE WRONG WAY. THEN A
LOWLY TURN. YES NOW I KNOW THAT
THIS WAY IS THE RIGHT PERSON
YOU HAD A LITTLE BIT OF THE
DELEGATE BUT DANCING SOMETHING
THAT'S METAL IN THE ROOM BUT I
KNOW THIS FOR. OUR HEY. AND IT
JUST KEPT GETTING LOUDER AND
LOUDER. YEAH THAT MIGHT BE IN
IT WHILE IS THE AYE WHILE IS A
REQUIREMENT SO IT SMALL. AND IT
IS IT'S SMALL AND IT'S COST
EFFECTIVE AND IT'S NOT
BURDENSOME FOR THEM TO WEAR
SOME OF THE CASES WE'VE
ACTUALLY START ORDERING AND
SOME FUN COLORS FOR THE
CHILDREN AND THAT ARE AUTISTIC-
HAVE DOWN SYNDROME OR DRAMATIC
BRAIN INJURY. SO THEY CAN
CHOOSE A COLOR THAT THEY LIKE
AND THEN THEY'RE MORE AT THAT
LIKELY TO WEAR IT. AND WE HAVE
SOME FABRIC BANDS LITTLE BIT
MORE COMFORTABLE FOR OUR OLDER
FOLKS WHO ARE IN CARE HOMES TO
WEAR BECAUSE IN OTHER SKIN GETS
VERY FRAIL THE ONE THAT IS
COMFORTABLE FOR THEM TO WEAR.
AND YOU WOULD THINK THAT EVEN
IF THEY'RE NOT A LOCKDOWN
TREATMENT CENTER THAT
SPECIALIZES IN MEMORY KERR THAT
THEY WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO WANDER.
YOU'RE SURPRISED. THEY ARE SO
CLEVER. AND I HAVE TO SMILE A
BIT BECAUSE WE HAD A CLIENT
AND- HER NAME IS DOROTHY AND I
WAS VERY FOND OF HER. AND WE
WOULD WATCH HER AND YOU IN
ORDER TO GET OUT OF HER
CAREFULLY YOU HAD TO HAVE TWO
PEOPLE PUSH BUTTONS ON OPPOSING
WALLS IN ORDER FOR THE FRONT
DOORS TO OPEN. AND SHE WAS
STAND THERE AND WAIT TO
INTEREST WITH BY AND THEN SHE
TRIED TO BRIBE. TO PUSH THE
OTHER BUTTON. AND SHE ACTUALLY
GOT OUT ONE TIME SHE WAS
SUCCESSFUL IN WRITING SOME TO
PUSH THE OTHER BUTTON SO SHE
COULD. HELLO AND SHE WENT AND
SHE FOUND AN UNLOCKED CURRENT
SHE SAT IN IT. AS AN OFFICER
CAME BY AND SAW HER AND KNOCKED
ON THE WINDOW WAS LIKE. YOU
KNOW DOROTHY ARE IS ARE YOU IN
THERE SHE SAID. I KNOW THIS IS
MY CAR I'M GOING TO WORK. AND
YOU KNOW AND SHE WAS JUST VERY
CLEVER SO EVEN WHEN THEY ARE.
THE WALK DOWN MEMORY WAR IT'S
GOOD TO HAVE THIS EXTRA LAYER
PRECAUTION. AND FOR AND THAT
HAVE THIS PROGRAM EVEN WHEN
THEIR CHILD. AND WHAT WOULD
SEND. BEEN A PART OF IT. IT'S
AN ADDED WELFARE CHECK AND IT'S
AN ADDED LAYER OF RESOURCES FOR
US TO GIVE TO THAT FAMILY.
THERE ARE A FEW THINGS-
LONELIER THAN BEING A
CAREGIVER. I THINK THOSE OF US
WHO HAVE HAD CHILDREN AND
NOTICE LIKE TO BE. THERE FOR
LONG DAYS A SMALL CHILDREN THAT
CAN BE MENTALLY TAXING. BUT TO
THINK ABOUT DOING THAT FOR A
PARENT WHOSE. HAS YOU KNOW
THESE MOMENTS OF ANGER AND
CONFUSION. IT BECOMES EVEN
LONELIER STILLNESS STRETCHES
OUT FOR YEARS THEY DON'T GROW
OUT OF THAT PHASE LIKE A
TODDLER DOES IT JUST PROGRESSES.
AND WE'VE HAD OUR VOLUNTEERS GO
OUT AND TO DO THESE BATTERY
CHANGES AND IT'S BECOME KIND OF
A SMALL WELFARE CHECK FOR THE
FAMILY. JUST ASK HOW ARE YOU
DOING DO YOU NEED RESPITE CARE
TINO RESPITE CARE IS CAN WE GET
YOU CONNECTED WITH AN OMBUDSMAN
OR SOMEONE FROM SOCIAL WORK
THAT COULD COME IN AND HELP
YOU. AND WE'VE HAD TIMES WE'VE
GONE OUT DURING THE HOLIDAYS
AND THERE'S NO DECORATIONS SO
WE'LL SEE WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE C. WILL WE
FEEL SCARED TO GO OUT AND SHOP
BECAUSE OUR CHILDREN MIGHT
LEAD. AND WE WORK TOGETHER AS
AN ORGANIZED INTO. THEM AT AT
YES. SO IT IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS WHERE IT IS A PROGRAM
THAT WAS DESIGNED. TO ALLEVIATE
THESE AT RISK MISSING PEOPLE.
BUT IT'S BECOME. AN ADDED WAY
FOR US TO CONNECT WITH OUR
COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE AND TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AS
A POLICE DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU
FOR WHAT YOU DO AND THANK YOU
FOR DEMONSTRATING THAT TO LESS
AT A CERTAINLY I CAN SEE THE
NEED FOR IT AND IT WOULD LOVE
TO SEE EXPANDED. SELF
CONGRATULATION FOR WHAT YOU'RE
DOING WITH YOUR DEPARTMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU HAVE ANY. I
CAME. NEXT WE HAVE BJ SPAMMER
WHO IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF NAMYS AND SHE'S HERE FROM
TEXAS SO THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
FOR TRAVELING SO FAR TO BE WITH
US TODAY AND SHE WILL GIVE US
AN OVERVIEW OF THE NATIONAL
MISSING AN IDENTIFIED PERSON
SYSTEM WHICH WE CONTINUE TO
REFER TO HIS NAME IS AND SHE
WILL DESCRIBE HOW IT ACCEPTS
INFORMATION CONCERNING MISSING
PERSONS AND DESCRIBE HOW
CALIFORNIA CAN CONTRIBUTE TO
THE MISSION OF NAME S. AND THE
MOST EFFICIENT PROCESS FOR THE
ENTRY OF MISSING PERSONS INTO
THEIR DATABASE WELCOME AND
THANK. THANK SENATOR GALGIANI
OF SO HONORED HERE TODAY AND
PART OF THIS DISCUSSION THANK
YOU FOR THE WORK DOING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THIS IMPORTANT
IT AND TO GET AN OVERVIEW OF
NAME S. OR THE NATIONAL MISS
UNIDENTIFIED PERSON SYSTEM NAME
THIS IS A PROGRAM OF THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE
SO IT'S FULLY FUNDED BY A GRANT
ISSUED BY AN AYE JAYE A I AM A
KOREAN T. SO I ACTUALLY WORK
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF NORTH
TEXAS CENTER FOR HUMAN BENEFIT
XIN OR WE CALL YOU ANTI HIV.
YOU ANTI H. AT THE GRANDADDY
THAT MANAGE THE DAY PARADE
CONSERVE NAMYS ACE TECHNOLOGY
JUST ALL GIVE YOU AN SOME OF
THE NATIONAL RESEARCH THAT
BEHIND THE SISTER. NAME IS.
SUPPORT FAMILIES WHO HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE DEATH OR
pWE HAVE SOME GENEROUS SUPPORT
FROM THE OFFICE FOR VICTIMS OF
CRIME. THAT HAS ALLOWED US TO
STEP UP THAT VICTIM SERVICES
UNIT I MEAN WE'RE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON A PEER TO PEER
SUPPORT NETWORK SO THAT WHEN WE
HAVE FAMILIES THAT ARE IN THAT
PLACE EMOTIONALLY THAT THEY CAN
SUPPORT OTHER FAMILY. WHO ARE
IMPACTED BY THE- LOVED ONE. H.
THOSE THOSE FAMILY MEMBERS WITH
PEER MENTORS WE ALSO PROVIDE
VICTIM REUNIFICATION SERVICES.
SO IF MISSING LOVED ONE IS
FOUND DECEASED WE HAVE SOME
FUNDING THAT CAN SUPPORT.
REUNIFYING THAT FAMILY SO
SOMETIMES EVEN EXHUMATIONS
TRANSPORTATION REINTERMENT OF
THOSE REMAINS. SO FAMILIES CAN
BRING THEM BACK FOR PROPER
BURIALS. SO WE HAVE A LOT OF
SERVICES BEHIND THE DATABASE
TECHNOLOGY NONE OF THEM ARE
DESIGNED TO BE A REPLACEMENT
FOR EXISTING LOCAL OR STATE
RESOURCES. THEY'RE THERE TO
FILL THE GAPS THAT OF THEIR
THEIR FOR AGENCIES THAT MAY NOT
HAVE THOSE RESOURCES AVAILABLE
TO THEM. OF COURSE WE IN
CALIFORNIA THERE IS AN
EXCELLENT LABORATORY THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE THE PROFILES ALL OF DNA
SAMPLES. FOR FAMILIES OF
MISSING PERSONS WHO WERE LAST%
SEEN IN CALIFORNIA SO. IN THOSE
CASES WE DON'T PROVIDE THE
DIRECT. ANALYSES SERVICES WE
CAN HELP COORDINATE DNA
COLLECTIONS MAYBE OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO GET THOSE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO MAY BE NO LONGER
LIVE IN THE STATE. COLLECTED
WITH THE CAL DOJ KIDS AND
RETURN TO THE LABORATORY.
SETTLING TO THE DATABASE
TECHNOLOGY ITSELF WE HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT IS ACCESSIBLE TO
EVERYONE AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT MAKES NAME IS TRULY
UNIQUE. NOW OF COURSE THERE ARE
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE SO THAT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SENSITIVE
INFORMATION IS ONLY VIEWABLE TO
ARE VETTED REGISTERED
PROFESSIONAL USERS. LIKE OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT USERS MEDICAL
EXAMINERS CORNERS. SO THERE ARE
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE TO PROTECT
THAT INFORMATION THAT'S ONLY
VISIBLE TO THOSE PROFESSIONAL
USERS BUT FAMILY MEMBERS VICTIM
ADVOCATES. JUST BETTER WITH THE
GENERAL PUBLIC DO YOU HAVE A
CLOSE TO A LARGE AMOUNT OF. IN
NAME. HELPS TO THE SYSTEM.
WHICH PERFORM COMPARE. WE HAVE
HAD FAMILY MEMBERS SIT DOWN TO
THE KEYBOARD AND SEARCH NAY
MISS AND FIND A MATCH TO THEIR
MISSING LOVED ONE. I CAN THINK
OF. NOT POWERING. THANKS FOR.
THEM WE HAVE OTHER SISTER A MAN
WHO HAD BEEN MISSING FROM THE
CITY JERRY FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS MR HAD BEEN MISSING. SHE
HEARD ABOUT THE NAME IS STAFF
ACE LOGGED IN FRANCE SEARCHES
OF THE AND I DE I JUST. THIS AN
HERS AND- MIDWAY THE CASE
RESULT CALLED ON A CASE. THE
CASE FILE NAME IS OPENED SHE'S
A COMPOSITE IN HIS SHE SOUGHT
FOR MAY ABOUT TATTOO AND SHE
SAID HE- REALLY. SHE WAS HER
SISTER PAUL. HOW ONE OF THE IS
THAT WE FIND IN THESE QUE IS
TEN. SOME OF THE MEDITATOR NOT
BE CORRECT SO NOT FOR HUMAN
ERROR SOME IT'S JUST BECAUSE
THAT'S THE INFORMATION THAT WAS
KNOWN TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AT THE
TIME OF THE ENTRY AND THAT
PARTICULAR CASE PAUL WAS NOT.
WHO DIDN'T LIVE AT HOME SO BY
THE TIME SHE WENT MISSING NO
ONE REALIZE SHE HAD ALREADY
BEEN MISSING FOR SEVERAL DAYS
SO HER DATE OF LET CONTACT. WAS
ENTERED INTO DATABASES AS BEING
SEVERAL DAYS PRIOR TO THE DATE
HER BODY WAS ACTUALLY FOUND.
BUT THE SISTERS SEARCHING FOR
JUST DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION IN
THE NAME IS DATABASE WAS OVER
TO. ABLE TO OVERCOME THAT
CHALLENGE. AND THERE ARE SO
MANY NUANCES TO THESE CSES AND
SO MANY CHALLENGES WE COULD
TALK ALL DAY ABOUT THOSE. BUT I
THINK SUCH AN EMPOWERING TOOL
TO HAVE. SO MANY PEOPLE
OPERATING IN ONE SYSTEM TO HELP
LOCATE THESE CASES AND BRING
THESE LOVED ONES HOME. SO THE
NAME IS DATABASE STORES MADE ON
MISSING PERSONS. UNIDENTIFIED
DECEDENTS AND ALSO UNCLAIMED
PERSONS SO THESE ARE DECEDENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY
NAME BUT FOR HOME NEXT OF KIN
HAS NOT YET BEEN LOCATED TO
MAKE. THAT BUT IF OCCASIONS OR
HAVE THOSE BODIES CLAIM FOR
BURIAL CURRENTLY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE ONE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED SIXTY SIX
OF THOSE UNCLAIMED BODIES IN
THE NAME IS DATABASE. AND WE
JUST WRKED WITH SAN BERNADINO
COUNTY CORONER'S OFFICE TO
IMPORTS A LARGE NUMBER OF CASES
INTO NAME IS SO THAT THEY COULD
START UTILIZING THAT SYSTEM
MORE. LEAVE MAKING GAVE I'M
SITTIN ON THE MISSING PERSONS
ALREADY WE HAVE ALMOST TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED PUBLISHED MISSING
PERSON CASES IN NAME S. AS OF
TODAY. AND ON THE ON IDENTIFIED
DECEDENT SIDE WE HAVE OVER TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED CASES
CAN YOU GIVE US THOSE NUMBERS
AGAIN I'M SORRY MA'AM. ON THE
MISSING PERSON SIDE WE HAVE
ALMOST TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND THESE ARE THE
PUBLISHED ASUS SO THESE OF ALL
BEEN VETTED. WE HAVE PERMISSION
OF THE INVESTIGATING AGENCIES
TO PUBLISH THOSE IN OUR SYSTEM.
ON THE IDENTIFIED TO SEE INSIDE
WE HAVE CURRENTLY TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
UNIDENTIFIED PERSONS IN NAME IS
FROM CALIFORNIA. THE UNCLAIMED
PERSONS WE HAVE ONE THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX AND
THAT JUST FROM CALIFORNIA YES
MA'AM. AT THE SAME TWENTY FIVE
PUBLISHED IS JUST FROM
CALIFORNIA AS WELL JUST FROM
CALIFORNIA'S. SHOULD WA. OVER
SEVEN THAT THOUSAND. ACTIVE
MISS PURSING. THE US VICE WE
HAVE THIRTY THOUSAND CASES. NO
ONE OF THE PRIME PUSHES THE
CREATION OF NEW IS K. FROM THE
EXAMINER. COMMUNITY BECAUSE WE
HAD AGENCIES WHO WERE TASKED
WITH IDENTIFYING REMAINS WHO
HAD VERY LITTLE TOOLS AT THEIR
DISCRETION TO DO SO. THEY
DIDN'T HAVE A CENTRAL DATABASE
THAT THEY COULD ALL ACCESS 80%
OF OUR MEDICAL EXAMINERS IN
CORNERS IN THE UNITED STATES
RARELY OR NEVER USE NCIC.
MAJORITY HAVE NO ACCESS TO NCIC
SO THEY HAVE TO RELY ON THEIR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
OR OTHER STATE AGENCIES. TO
ENTER THAT WAS ON IDENTIFIED
CASES FOR THEM. THE OTHER SIDE
OF THAT COIN IS THAT THEN THEY
HAVE NO DIRECT ACCESS TO SEARCH
FOR A MISSING PERSON MATCHES.
FOR THE MEDICAL EXAMINER
CORONER COMMUNITY WAS A LARGE
DRIVING FORCE BEHIND THE
INITIAL ROLLOUT OF NAME AS OUR
FIRST SECTION OF THE DATABASE
THAT WENT LIVE WAS ON
IDENTIFIED DECEDENTS. AND TODAY
THOSE. THIRTEEN THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED NINETY SIX AND IDENTIFY
CASES THAT WE HAVE NATIONWIDE.
FOR PASSES NUMBER OF DECEIT
BETTER IN AND THE ICY BECAUSE
OF THAT ACCESS. ONE THING
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE WITH
NAME S. IT IS A VERY UNIQUE
SYSTEM INCORPORATES EVERYONE
INTO ONE DATABASE. SO WE DO
ALLOW ANYONE TO MAKE AN INITIAL
MISSING PERSON REPORT TO NAME
S. SO ANYONE A MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC CAN REGISTER FOR PUBLIC
ACCOUNT. AND CREATE A BRAND NEW
MISSING PERSON CASE NOW THAT
INFORMATION WILL NEVER BE
VIEWABLE TO ANYONE OTHER THAN
INTERNAL NAME IS STAFF. UNTIL
OUR STAFF HAVE VETTED THAT CASE
WITH THE PROPER JURISDICTIONAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
BECAUSE OF COURSE WE WANT TO
PROTECT THE PRIVACY AND THE
SAFETY. OF INDIVIDUALS REPORTED
MISSING TO NAME THIS SO WILL
REACH OUT TO THE INVESTIGATING
AGENCY WILL VERIFY THAT THEY DO
HAVE A MISSING PERSON REPORT ON
FILE SOMETIMES THEY DO NOT HAVE
THAT REPORT. THAT AND WE CAN
HELP THAT FIT ONLY MAKE BACK
ACTION. PROPER INVEST. OR
AGENCY TO. REPORT ONCE THAT
AGENCY HAS REVIEWED ALL THE
INFORMATION AND THE NAME IS
CASE FILE TO MAKE SURE IT'S
ACCURATE. IT'S COMPLETE AND
IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR PUBLIC
VIEWING THEY'LL GIVE US
PERMISSION AND WILL PUBLISH
THAT CASE IN OUR SYSTEM. ANY
QUESTIONS I CAN ANSWER. I'M YES
SOMETHING DOES COME TO MIND SO
RICK G. ANY WHO WAS FROM
CALAVERAS COUNTY AND HIS WIFE
CAME FORWARD WHEN THE EVENTS
OCCURRED IN MY DISTRICT AND SHE
BELIEVE THAT HER HUSBAND HER EX
HUSBAND'S WOMEN REMAINS WERE.
IN THE- LET TRY TO AMEND TO THE
STATES THE DOJ MAP SYSTEM BUT
WE LEARNED THAT THERE WAS NEVER
A MISSING PERSON REPORT FILED
AND YOU CAN IMAGINE IF YOU KNOW
IF HE WAS ESTRANGED FROM HIS
WIFE AND HIS SON WAS ONLY TEN
YEARS OLD THE EX WIFE IS
STAYING THAT THIS THE SUN IS
AVAILABLE AND WILLING TO
PROVIDE THE AND THEN WE LEARNED
THAT. WAS NO EVEN ENTERED.
THERE WAS NO MISSING. FIVE IN A
CASE LIKE THAT IS THERE A
RECOMMENDATION THAT YOU WOULD
HAVE OF YOU KNOW HOW THE HOW
YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
A LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT ANY TT
TO TRY TO LOCATE A FAMILY
MEMBER. YES AND WE DO THAT
COMMONLY SO WE CURRENTLY HAVE
ALMOST EIGHT THOUSAND
PROFESSIONAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
MEDICAL EXAMINERS CORNER USERS.
IN THE NAME A SYSTEM RIGHT NOW
SO WHEN A FAMILY REPORTS TO
NAME MISS AND THERE'S NOT A
MISSING PERSON REPORT ON FILE
ALREADY WE CAN OFTEN REACH OUT
TO ONE OF THOSE CONTACT THAT'S
ALREADY IN THE NAME IS NETWORK.
SO THEY'RE ALREADY FAMILIAR
WITH THE CHALLENGES FACING
PERSON CASES WE CAN REACH OUT
TO THEM TO HELP THAT FAMILY GET
A REPORT FILED. OUR ANALYTICAL
DID. ALSO PROVE. PORTAL ON
FORCE. LOCATE THOSE FAMILY
FIRST. BECAUSE OFTEN WE
RECEIVED VERY LONG TERM CASES
IN NAME IS AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT I MENTION THAT IN THE
BEGINNING STAGES 95% OF THE
CASES THAT ARE REPORTED TO NAME
S. ARE FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
MISSING ONE YEAR OR MORE. WHAT
A LOT OF AGENTS MIGHT DEEM A
COLD CASE AND I KNOW WE TALKED
ABOUT DEFINITIONS OF COLD
CASES. FOR ME THAT'S A CASE
WHERE THE POOR STATE AGENCIES
HAVE BEEN EXHAUSTED ALL OF
THEIR INVESTIGATIVE RESOURCES.
AND THEY FEAR THAT FELL PLAYS
IT HEARD IN THERE LOOKING TO
COMPARE THAT MISSY PERSON.
IDENTIFY DECEIT. SO WE HAVE
STAFF MEMBERS BY. THE NAME IS
SYSTEM THAT WE CALL REGIONAL
PROGRAM SPECIALISTS. OR OUR P.
S.'S. THESE ARE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS IN THE FIELD OF MISSING
AN UNIDENTIFIED THAT SERVICE.
REALLY A FORCE MULTIPLIER FOR
THE AGENCIES THAT WORK WITH
NAMYS. SO THEY'RE AN EXTRA SET
OF EYES THERE AN EXTRA BEST TO
GET OF SUPPORT TO THE AGENCIES.
THAT CAN HELP THEM TRACK DOWN
THOSE FAMILY. FIRST AND EVEN
FACILITATE THOSE THE IN
COLLECTIONS SOMEONE MISSING IN
CALIFORNIA MIGHT HAVE A
RELATIVE IN MARYLAND. WE HAVE
AN INVESTIGATOR IN MARYLAND
THAT WE CAN REACH. THE FACILITY
THAT DNA COLLECTION. SO WHAT IF
FAMILY MEMBER WE- THAT THERE
MISSING ONE IS THE SYSTEM. AND
THEY'VE MOVED AND THEIR CONTACT
INFORMATION HAS CHANGED. DOES
THE SYSTEM HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ALLOW THE FAMILY MEMBER TO
ACCESS THE SYSTEM AGAIN AND
MAKE A CHANGE IN UPDATE THEIR
CURRENT CONTACT INFORMATION.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION SO
FAMILY MEMBERS IF THEY MAKE THE
PRIMARY ENTRY INTO NAME S. WHEN
THEY HIT THAT DO YOU CASE
BUTTON TO CREATE A CASE FILE
THEY WILL SEE EVERY FIELD IN
THE NAME OF SYSTEM. SO THEY CAN
ENTER EVERY PIECE OF
INFORMATION THEY KNOW ABOUT
THEIR MISSING LOVED ONE
INCLUDING THEIR OWN CONTACT
INFORMATION. NOW ONCE THE CASE
IS ACCEPTED INTO NAME AS THE
VIEW WILL CHANGE TO A PUBLIC
NEED LEAVE. AND SOME OF THAT IN
FOR. LONG SPENT MIGHT BECOME
BACK IN ADDING TO THAT ENTRY
THAT THE ONLY CREATED LAW
ENFORCEMENT MY HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL SENT. FOR ME THE AND
IS THE- PUBLIC VIEWING. SO WHY
THANK CASES X. THE FOR MEMBER
STILL HAS PUBLIC ACCESS TO
THEIR CASE FILE AND THEY HAVE A
POINT OF CONTACT THAT'S LISTED
RIGHT ON THEIR NAME IS CASE
FILE. FOR THE REGIONAL PROGRAM
SPECIALIST SO THEY CAN REACH
BACK IF THEY HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. OR
UPDATED INFORMATION AND I THINK
THAT'S ALSO ONE OF THE BENEFITS
OF HAVING THIS PUBLICLY
VIEWABLE SYSTEM. IS WE OFTEN
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO WILL Q.
A THEIR OWN CASE FILE AND THEY
WILL CALL US TO SAY YOU DON'T
HAVE INFORMATION ABOUT THAT
TOO. OR THAT PIECE OF JEWELRY
THAT SHE ALWAYS WORE SOMETIMES
FAMILY GIVING US ADDITIONAL
NATION THAT WE KNOW ABOUT
BEFORE. AND THAT'S- FINE FOR
SOMEONE FOR MEMBER HIS WAITED
FOR SO MANY YEARS AND THERE'S
LEV ONE STILL MISSING TO AT
LEAST BE ABLE TO. ACCESS
THINKPAD INFORMATION. UPDATE
THAT MEANS MORE THAN THAN YOU
CAN IMAGINE IT ABSOLUTELY DOES
BECAUSE WE HEAR FROM FAMILIES
WHO HAVE SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN.
OUR FAMILY MEMBERS OFTEN HAVE
SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN MISSING FOR
DECADES. AND THEY DON'T GET
REGULAR UPDATES FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE THERE IS NO
REGULAR UPDATES TO PROVIDE
THERE'S NOTHING NEW. FOR LAWN
FORCED TO SHARE WITH THAT
FAMILY BUT THEY CAN LOG INTO
THAT NAME IS SYSTEM ANYTIME.
AND THEY CAN REVIEW THEIR OWN
CASE THEY CAN SEARCH FOR
POTENTIAL MATCHES IN THE NIGHT
OF FIGHTS WE CAN HAD VICTIM
ADVOCATES MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. NO STANDING IN A KILLER
CASE WHO RUN THE SEARCHES AND
ARE ABLE TO COME UP WITH
COMPARISONS. HAVE LED TO I'D
NOW THE SYSTEM WILL
AUTOMATICALLY COMPARE MISSED.
THIS TO A DENTAL TO SEE. ON THE-
SUB OF CRITERIA SO. JEAN RATE
THIS DE SAC HIGH EIGHT BUT
ALSO. SOME EVER BEEN XIN IT
SAYS SEARCH. SO FAR A MISSED.
ONE WITH THE RAY TATTOO. I CAN
DO A WORDS FOR ROAST. I CAN
LOOK FOR THAT TIMEX WATCH I CAN
LOOK FOR THAT SHOE SIZE OR THAT
NAME BRAND OF CLOTHING THAT I
KNEW THEY WERE WEARING. HIS
SEARCH FOR SCARS MARKS TATTOOS
ALL OF THAT INFORMATION IS
SEARCHABLE TO THE PUBLIC. CAN'T
PUBLIC MEMBER KNOW WHETHER
THERE IS DNA ON FILE FOR THEIR
LOVED ONE WE DO NOT PROVIDE
THAT INFORMATION PUBLICLY AND
THERE'S A COUPLE OF REASONS FOR
THAT. THE FIRST IS WE HAVE A
LOT OF CASES WHERE MAYBE FAMILY
MEMBERS AREN'T IN CONTACT WITH
ONE ANOTHER AND SO FOR PRIVACY
REASONS WE DON'T DISCLOSE THAT
THIS RELATIVE GAVE DNA VERSES
THIS RELATIVE WHO DID NOT. THE
OTHER REASON WE THERE USED TO
BE MORE INFORMATION AVAILABLE
IN NAME IS THAT. BASICALLY JUST
THE DNA IS AVAILABLE OR IS NOT
AVAILABLE. WHAT WE FOUND IS
WHEN THE VICTIM ADVOCATE
COMMUNITY WAS RUNNING SEARCHES
THROUGH NAME IS FOR POTENTIAL
MATCHES THEY WERE MAKING
ASSUMPTIONS THAT BECAUSE THE
SYSTEM SAYS DNA IS AVAILABLE I
DON'T NEED TO REPORT THIS TIP.
BECAUSE DNA WOULD HAVE MADE THE
MATCH. THAN IN A IS AVAILABLE
BUT- AS THEIR ASSUME NEW. THESE
WILL MATCH. DNA IS NOT ALWAYS
GOING TO PRODUCE AN
ASSOCIATION. WE MAY NOT HAVE
ENOUGH FAMILY FRIEND SAMPLES WE
NEED TWO OR MORE CLOSELY
RELATED FAMILY MEMBERS FOR
EVERY MISSING PERSON CASE. SURE
THE PROPER SEARCHING IS
HAPPENING IN CODIS NEED TO MAKE
SURE NUCLEAR AND CON THE IS.
SOME MY HAVE ONLY TROPHY PRINT
EIGHT AT THE BECAUSE THE
DECEDENT. UP WHO IDENTIFIED IS
THE- WEEK GET A TEN FINGER CARD
SO ALL OF NEW. TO THE BIOMETRIC
DATE. MAKE IT WRITTEN FOR THE
SUBJECT EXT BEHIND SYSTEM TO
VALUE EIGHT. OKAY WELL THANK
YOU VERY THAT SIX INFORMAL AND
WHAT TERM RESOURCE ESPECIALLY
SENSE ON THE PUBLIC IN FAMILY
MEMBERS CAN HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
SYSTEM YES MA'AM AND THE ONLY
OTHER THING I SHOULD HAVE
MENTIONED IS WE ARE- WE HAVE
DEVOTED A LOT OF RESOURCES IN
THIS LAST YEAR TO ENHANCING OUR
TECHNOLOGY TO ENABLE DATA
IMPORTS AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE HEARD TALKED ABOUT
TODAY BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT HAS
BEEN A MANUAL PROCESS CENTER
CASES INTO NAME AS- WE'VE NOW
COMPLETED THE WORK TO ALLOW A
FRONT END USER TO UPDATE. A
SPREAD SHEET OR A CSP YEAR
AJAY'S ON FILE OF CASE DATA
INTO NAMYS AND WE'RE NOW
WORKING ON THE SERVER TO SERVER
DATA IMPORTS THAT IS GOING TO
TAKE US A BIT OF TIME BUT WE DO
FEEL LIKE WITHIN THIS NEXT
CALENDAR WILL HAVE THAT WERE
COMPLETE AS WELL THAT'S GREAT
NEWS. GOODNESS THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH. AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR WAITING FINALLY WE
WILL BRING UP KEVIN PAPPA NO
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATOR WITH THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE TO DESCRIBE
HIS TRAINING AND EXPERIENCE
WITH THE HANDLING OF MISSING
PERSONS INVESTIGATIONS AND HOW
CASES ARE HEADED FOR THE POLICE
OFFICER TO THE DETECTIVE FOR
FOLLOW UP. AND THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US TODAY
REVEREND THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME. OF A LITTLE BACKGROUND ON
MY EXPERIENCE I TOOK OVER
MISSING PERSONS FOR THE
CONTRACT CITY OF ELK GROVE WHEN
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
DECENTRALIZED MISSING PERSONS
UP UNTIL THAT POINT THEY HAD.
ONE DETECTIVE WHO WAS IN CHARGE
OF MISSING PERSONS FOR THE
ENTIRE DEPARTMENT. AND FRANKLY
THE GUIDELINES SAID TO ME NO IF
YOU HAVE A MISSING PERSON CALL
THIS GUY AND THEN HE WAS
LEAVING SO. WHEN THEY
DECENTRALIZED- AND DECEIVE OVER
WAS JUST STARTING UP AS A
CONTRACTED GETTING READY TO
START THEIR OWN POLICE
DEPARTMENT. I DID SOME-
RESEARCH INTO. THE LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS THE TIME REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND FOLLOW UP. AND
DEVELOPED A SYSTEM THAT WAS
EVENTUALLY TAKEN- DEPARTMENT
WIDE THROUGH THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT SO THAT EVERY.
INDIVIDUAL STATION HOUSE WAS ON
THE SAME PAGE- FOLLOWING. THE
SAME GUIDELINES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THINGS WEREN'T WEREN'T
FALLING THROUGH THE HOLES. AS
WE HAD FOUND OUT THAT. QUITE A
BIT THAT THERE WERE- AT THAT
TIME. DETECTIVE WAS PRETTY MUCH
THE PRIMARY POINT OF CONTACT ON
EVERY MISSING PERSON CASE. IT
HAS DEVELOPED NOW AS YOU'VE
HEARD A LOT OF THE RESOURCES-
THEN IT WOULD BE A DETECTIVETHAT WOULD HAVE TO CALL OF
SEARCH AND RESCUE. THAT WOULD
BRING OUT THE VARIOUS
TECHNOLOGIES- AND RESOURCES-
DOES HAVE. I DON'T WANNA SAY
PUSH DOWN BUT HAS BECOME COMMON
NOW THAT. THAT INITIAL SEARCH
WHEN SOMEBODY'S REPORTED
MISSING THE FIRST TWENTY FOUR
FORTY EIGHT HOURS IF IT'S A
GROUND SEARCH FOR AN
ALZHEIMER'S PATIENT OR-
ANYTHING LIKE THAT THAT IS
HANDLED BY PATROL THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND THE ABILITY. TO
FOLLOW FOLLOW THOSE LEADS PUT
BOOTS ON THE GROUND AND- THE
ROLE OF DETECTIVE BASICALLY HAS
GONE TO WHERE- WE- GET INVOLVED
IN THE CASE OR TAKE OVER THE
CASE WHEN. ONE OF TWO THINGS
HAPPENS THAT INITIAL SEARCH
COMES UP EMPTY AND THINGS ARE
GOING TO TURN LONG TERM WHERE.
THE INVESTIGATION TURNS INTO.
ESSENTIALLY A SEARCH OF THE
REST OF THE WORLD- AND USING
INVESTIGATIVE DATABASES AND
MANY OF THE SOURCES NAY MISS-
THAT TO BE ONE. TO TRY AND
LOCATE THOSE PEOPLE IF THEY
TURN UP SOMEWHERE ELSE. SO WHEN
IT'S JUST GONE LONG TERM. THE
OTHER WAY THE DETECTIVES GET
INVOLVED IS AT FROM THE OUTSET
IF IT APPEARS THAT THERE'S A
CRIME INVOLVED SO IN OBJECTION.
A KIDNAPPING THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS WERE IT APPEARS TO BE A
CRIME FROM THE BEGINNING-
THAT'S WHERE A DETECTIVE
IDEALLY IS IN CHARGE OF FROM
THE OUTSET OF THE- OF THE CASE.
AND DIRECTING ALL OF THE
AFOREMENTIONED RESOURCES TO-
INTO USE IN THE INVESTIGATION
APPROPRIATELY. AND DIRECTING-
CANVASES- NEIGHBORHOOD AREA
CAMPUSES- IN A VERY DETAILED
FASHION. BECAUSE THE SEARCHES
NOW MORE THAN LOOKING FOR. THE
MISSING PERSON THE SEARCHES
DEAD TO IDENTIFY AND DOCUMENT
EVERY POSSIBLE CLUE THAT MAY
BECOME IMPORTANT AT SOME POINT
DOWN THE LINE. SO THAT WAS
BASICALLY THE TWO WAYS THAT-
INVESTIGATORS AS A DETECTIVE
NOW GETS INVOLVED IN- A MISSING
PERSON CASE. SO ONCE IT'S
BECOME CLEAR THAT THEM THE
MISSING PERSON HAS. THERE
APPEARS TO BE A CRIME. AT THAT
POINT IT WOULD HOW WOULD YOU
COMMUNICATE WITH THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO ENSURE
THAT THAT THERE IS FAMILIAL DNA
ON FILE FOR A MISSING PERSON.
WELL SOMETHING THAT'S ALREADY
TAKEN CARE OF BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS IT SOMETHING
THAT YOU NEED THAT YOU WORK
WITH THEM TO VERIFY WELL IN
SPEAKING- JUST JUST TO CLARIFY
MIKE MY CURRENT ROLE IS AS A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATOR WITH THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
THAT'S BEEN THE LAST TWO YEARS-
PRIOR TO THAT I SPENT SIXTEEN
YEARS AS A DETECTIVE WITH THE
SECOND A SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
AND THE OLD GROVE POLICE
DEPARTMENT. SO KIND OF WHAT I'M
SPEAKING FROM IS THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT- DETECTIVE POINT OF
VIEW- AS TO HOW WE WOULD WE
WOULD HANDLE THOSE CASES- IN
ANY MISSING PERSON CASE- FROM
THE OUTSET YOU KNOW WE INFORM
THE- FAMILY THAT THEY HAVE A
RIGHT IN HIGH RISK SITUATIONS
TO SUBMIT. DNA AND THAT'S A
RIGHT AND GO DO THAT WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS HOWEVER IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT SOME AND IT'S SUCH A
CHILD ABDUCTION OR SOMETHING
WE'VE- YOU KNOW TALK ABOUT
ABOUT TWO. TIMES X. AND BECOME
LESS LIKELY THAT WE'RE GOING TO
FIND A LIVING VICTIM- IT CAN BE
YOU KNOW IT IS OUR PREROGATIVE
RIGHT UP FRONT TO ASK PEOPLE TO
VOLUNTEER THAT. BERMAN SAID
DETECTIVES POINT OF VIEW AND TO
QUESTION EVERYTHING A LOT OF
MISSING PERSON CASES ARE
HOMICIDES AND THE MISS TEEN.
THE PERSON REPORTING THE
MISSING PARTY IS ACTUALLY THE
SUSPECT. AND THAT IS AND I
THINK WHY IN TRAINING MISSING
PERSON TRAINING A LOT OF IT- IT
GOOD FOCUSES. TO LOOK AT IT
FROM THE OUTSET WHETHER YOUR
PATROL OFFICER OR DETECTIVE-
FROM THE OUTSET HAS AN
INVESTIGATION AND TO. HAVE A IN
ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT PRESENCE
PERSONALLY AT THE MISSING
PERSON WHEN THE REPORT IS MADE.
REFERENCING BACK A WELL
PUBLICIZED CASE THAT WE'VE
LEARNED A LOT FROM WAS THE
SCOTT PETERSON CASE. AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. FOR PURPOSES OF
EFFICIENCY AT SOME POINTS HAS
GOTTEN TO WHERE- WILL TAKE A
MISSING PERSON REPORT VIA FAX
OR OVER THE PHONE- IN THAT CASE.
HAVING SOMEBODY THERE THAT
SHOWED UP TO TAKE THE MISSING
PERSON REPORT WAS ABLE TO LOOK
AROUND AND SEE SOME THINGS THAT
WERE OUT OF PLACE IN THINGS
THAT APPEARED TO HAVE BEEN USED
TO. CLEAN SOMETHING UP AND
DIDN'T MAKE SENSE- YOU KNOW
THOSE THINGS WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
SEEN SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
SOMEBODY THERE WHETHER
DETECTIVE WERE IN THAT CASE.
YOU KNOW IT'S A PATROL OFFICER
IT'S COMING OUT TO TAKE THE
REPORT. WE TALKED. THERE'S BEEN
TALK ABOUT THE GROUP HOMES AND
REPEATED RUN AWAYS OVER AND
OVER. AS WELL AS ADDRESSING.
THE RISK OF THESE REPEATED RUN
AWAYS. AND ONE THING THAT YOU
KNOW WE STARTED. INITIALLY WHEN
I WAS. RUNNING THE SYSTEM AN
OUTGROWTH. IS THAT WE- IF THERE
WAS REPEATED RUN AWAY AS- WE
SAID A NUMBER AND WHENEVER ON
THREE TIMES WE REFER TO OUR
YOUTH SERVICE OFFICERS. TO YOU
KNOW MAKE CONTACT WITH THAT
FAMILY THAT GROUP HOME WHATEVER
IT IS. AND TRY AND FIND OUT WHY
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM. I AM. AND
YEAH I'D I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER
THING WE'RE- AND YOU KNOW
SPEAKING ABOUT. GROUP HOMES
THEY CAN FAX IN A REPORT. TO
SAY THIS PERSON'S MISSING AND
SO DISPATCHERS IN THE SYSTEM
WE'VE CHECKED THE BOXES WITH
BETTER LEGAL REQUIREMENTS. AND
THEN THEY CALL AND SAY OKAY
CAME BACK ALL RIGHT GREAT WE
MEAN EARLY REQUIREMENTS AND
TAKE IT OUT. BUT WE NEVER HAVE.
A YOU KNOW A COP. GO THERE AND
LOOK AROUND AND SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON. IN THAT HOME AND- AND
TRY AND- TRY AND SOLVE THE
PROBLEM RATHER THAN JUST
MEETING THE CHECKLIST. I WOULD
SAY THAT THE SACRAMENTO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE HAS
JUST BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF
LINKING. DNA WITH CASES AND IT.
HAS DONE AN AMAZING JOB WITH
THE GOLDEN STATE KILLER AND
OTHERS- WITH THE ADVANCEMENT OF
NEW TECHNOLOGY. IS THERE MORE
THAT YOUR OFFICE IS DEALING
WITH IT IN YOUR VIEW COULD BE
DONE TO. UTILIZE THE THAT SAME
TECHNOLOGY TO DO MORE TO
IDENTIFY. IDENTIFIED
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE FOUND
ABSOLUTELY- AND WHEN. AND MARIE
SCHUBERT FOUND OUT I WAS COMING
HERE SHE CERTAINLY MADE IT.
WANTED ME TO MAKE IT KNOWN THAT
SHE'S MORE THAN HAPPY TO- TO
WORK WITH THE- THE COMMISSION
ANYBODY ANYBODY THAT THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE- IT AS GROWING- DAY
BY DAY THAT SISTER. I'M
FORTUNATE BE ASSIGNED IN THE
HOMICIDE UNIT- AND TO THE
EASTER RAPIST CASE. AND THE
PEOPLE THAT LED THAT AND
CRACKED THAT CASE ARE GETTING
JUST INUNDATED- DAILY WITH. A
REQUEST FOR ASSISTANCE FROM
OUTSIDE AGENCIES AND WHATEVER
THEIR CRIME IF THEY HAVE SOME
DNA IT CERTAINLY- IS A IS A
CANDIDATE. TO BE LOOKED AT FROM
THE INVESTIGATIVE GENETIC
GENEALOGY PERSPECTIVE. SO THAT
IS DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT-
WILL CONTINUE TO GROW AND
SHOULD BE LOOKED INTO AS FAR AS
THE- IDENTIFICATION
IDENTIFICATION OF REMAINS. IS
THERE ANYTHING MORE THAT THE
STATE COULD BE DEALING SHOULD
BE DEALING TO GIVE YOU BETTER
TOOLS THAT ARE RESOURCES TO
TAKE BETTER ADVANTAGE OF THIS
NEW TECHNOLOGY. I CAN'T X.
SPECIFICALLY TO IT- OTHER THAN
IT NEEDS IT NEEDS TO BE
ENCOURAGE I THINK TRAINING
TRAINING IS- IS HUGE I KNOW-
YOU KNOW MY SUPERVISOR IS
TRAVELING A LOT TOO- AROUND THE
STATE OTHER STATES AND
COUNTRIES TO- TO TRAIN THEM ON
THIS SO I THINK- ADDING IT IN
TO THE MISSING PERSON TRAINING
WHICH IS PROBABLY ON GOING I
WOULD ASSUME THAT IT'S A TOPIC
OF DISCUSSION IN SAN DIEGO
TODAY. BUT YOU KNOW OTHER THAN
ENCOURAGING THAT THE RESOURCES
RIGHT NOW- SEEM TO BE OUT THERE
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF THE LACK
OF KNOWLEDGE. AND DEVELOPING
FURTHER DEVELOPING THE
GUIDELINES TO WORK WITH- YOU
KNOW THE VARIOUS- PRIVATE
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT THE- AND
THE GENEALOGY ORGANIZATIONS.
HAS YOUR OFFICE PARTICIPATED IN
THE MISSING PERSON EVENTS THAT
THE CALIFORNIA DOJ HAS
DESCRIBED THAT THEY'VE PUT ON
IN THE PAST I DON'T KNOW I'VE
BEEN THERE TWO YEARS AND I'M
LIKE SAY SIGNED TO HOMICIDE SO
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'VE DONE
WITH THE THOSE EVENTS OKAY I
WAS GOING TO ASK WHAT THAT
EXPERIENCE WAS AND IF IT WAS
HELPFUL- TO THE TO INDIVIDUAL
CASES AND HOW THAT WORKED RIGHT
YEAH FROM FROM THE DESCRIPTION
I CAN. CERTAINLY SEE IT- IT IT
SOUNDS LIKE IT WOULD BE A
HELPFUL WHEN A GOOD VENUE- BUT
I DON'T HAVE ANY PERSONAL
KNOWLEDGE OF OKAY. WELL I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE AND JOINING US I'M SORRY
MY OTHER TWO COLLEAGUES HAD TO
LEAVE FIVE SIR I'M SURE THEY
WOULD HAVE HAD SOME QUESTIONS.
AS WELL BUT WE REALLY THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE TODAY AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING. TO WORK
WITH YOU. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU AT THIS POINT WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND OPEN IT OPEN IT UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS IF THERE IS A
PUBLIC COMMENT. MY QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND ADJOURNED THE MEETING THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH TO EVERYONE
WHO IS HERE TODAY THANK YOU.